daniel ellsberg leading activist in the
nuclear freeze movement author of the
pentagon papers during the vietnam war
how do the goals of american liberals
today differ from those who fought to
end the conflict in vietnam
title of tonight's talk or are you
asking me that is one of the questions
in
that we'll be
talking about tonight
i think that what people are learning
today about congregate day by day as it
leaks out
corresponds very much to what the
pentagon papers had to reveal
15 years ago about our government policy
making
in those days it took documents to
convince an american citizen that his
president might be lying to him
that's not true today it's because the
pentagon papers did come out and they
saw an awful lot of documents
that uh were very painful reading at the
time that men we'd voted for and worked
for a campaign for i'd worked for
several presidents
had been all carrying out a policy that
was entirely different from what they
told us
different aims different
different uh expectations
in some cases violating laws violating
our constitution doing it secretly a
covert foreign policy that was out of
control of the public i think that's
what we're hearing about today and
that's why
we're about to have hearings on that
subject i expect to learn a lot from
those hearings i just got cable and
c-span television for the first time in
my life in expectation of those hearings
i want to follow them i hope you enjoy
them would you explain for our viewers
who may have forgotten or may be too
young to remember your role in the
pentagon papers well you described me as
the author of the pentagon papers that's
not that's a little misleading i did
draft one of the volumes of the pentagon
papers there were 43
main volumes plus some negotiations
volumes all top secret
dealing with the history this was the
title history of u.s decision making
in vietnam from 1945 to 1968
the project started in 1968 and like
most americans the people doing the
study in the pentagon of which i was one
thought the war was about to end at that
point
president johnson had just
said that he would not run again he was
asking for negotiations and people
thought that it was about over actually
it had seven years to go
i was working on a project then the
pentagon so-called pentagon papers which
was to learn lessons from the pentagon
from the vietnam war
and when that study was completed by 69
i was at the rand corporation on
contract to the defense department
with i was the only researcher in the
country authorized to have the entire
study
in my possession to do a project on
lessons from vietnam
and as i read those volumes i thought
increasingly as i saw the war going on
that these were lessons that shouldn't
be just mine to learn and shouldn't be
just the pentagons to learn that the
american public needed to know this
information about how they'd been lied
to and how they've been manipulated into
that war
so
in 1969 i began copying those top secret
volumes that were in my safe i had
authorized possession to them
and giving them what i was not
authorized to do giving them to senator
fulbright then chairman of the senate
foreign relations committee and he
expected to hold hearings but ultimately
did not hold hearings on the basis of
those
documents
and eventually two invasions later laos
and cambodia
many american deaths many vietnamese
deaths later
i gave the documents to the new york
times and when they were enjoined
for the first time in our history from
publishing i gave copies to the
washington post and to 17 newspapers in
all for which i was put on trial uh
facing 115 years in prison
you uh of course never went to trial
perhaps you can i went to trial you went
to i was five and a half months in uh in
court but about the time
that we were due to go to summation and
go to the jury
after five and a half months in court
nearly after nearly two years in the
court proceedings
a series of revelations came out of the
so-called plumbers revealing that the
white house had illegally done
operations the analogy to today is not
coincidental it's almost a replay
that a set of people in the white house
had been
doing burglaries i had gone into my
former psychoanalyst's office and trying
to get material to blackmail me into
silence
i'd been there had been an attempt to
incapacitate me or murder me and doing a
speech in washington
phones had been tapped 17 newsmen and
had been tapped and many including uh
members of
the nsc staff i'd been overheard on
those and the records had been concealed
so as to keep them out of my trial and
after ten days of continuous revelations
of this cia and so forth
all charges were dismissed against me by
the judge on grounds of gross
governmental misconduct i believe by the
way that we are in for revelations of a
very similar nature in the coming months
what makes you believe that
uh it's very clear that the everything
we've heard everything that uh mr meese
has so far officially disclosed about
colonel north's operations indicate
covert operations run in violation of
laws of congress
and
in this case not it would seem against
an american citizen
but against the law and against the
citizens of another country in nicaragua
it would it seems very clear as many
people have already concluded in the
senate and the house which is why they
set up the committees that major laws
have been broken by the executive branch
and by the white house the role of the
president is not yet clear
but the role of people working directly
for him is clear we have a spectacle
of an executive branch
out of democratic control an executive
branch that has not submitted
to the legislative authority of congress
in the area where congress has a
constitutional authority control of the
budget we are talking with daniel
ellsberg who has just described his role
in the pentagon papers during the
vietnam war he is currently an activist
in the nuclear freeze movement i'll give
a little of his lengthy background he
was a strategic analyst for the rand
corporation for a number of years
different uh periods in 1964 he joined
the defense department as the special
assistant to the assistant secretary for
international security affairs went to
vietnam as a state department official
in 1965 and 66 while at grand the rand
corporation in 1961 developed the first
kennedy administration guidelines for
general nuclear war plans he has been
active with the nuclear free strategy
task force and the american peace test
which is demonstrated in washington and
at the nevada testing site since the
early 70s you've lectured and taught
college seminars you were in the u.s
marine corps from 1954 to 1957 i believe
do you find in the nuclear freeze
movement many of the same liberals
who've led the fight to end the war in
vietnam
well
many yes but the movements do differ
quite a bit the freeze movement is not a
campus-based movement particularly and
of course it doesn't have the veteran
phenomenon either
when it's
in terms of people who support
who want to see
a bilateral that is a mutual
two-sided ending to the arms race by the
soviet union and by the u.s and ending
to test the deployment and production of
nuclear weapons that's 80 percent of the
public that's the public i mean it's not
the vietnam war movement it's not any
movement that's the public to a first
approximation except for the people in
the white house in the pentagon and 20
percent minority
in terms of however the people have been
quite active
you get a much older generation
doing both of all kinds of activities in
this movement than i think you got in
vietnam which was much more of a
youthful
protest movement on the whole it's much
more broadly based all groups in society
i think are represented in it
it's about
i'm here in washington this weekend to
attend a meeting of the sane
board of directors that's committee for
sane nuclear policy and i was just
elected to the board
the uh that's a 30 year old organization
which has been working against nuclear
testing all that time
they voted
this weekend
while i was here
to merge with the freeze the national
freeze campaign which in terms of
actually activists seventeen hundred
chapters is the largest grassroots
movement probably this country has seen
of any kind
and the two groups the freeze campaign
and and sane merged uh just now i think
it'll be a quite unprecedented uh lobby
citizens lobby and grassroots movement
focusing right now
on ending at last after that 30 years
campaign ending the
testing of nuclear weapons we want to
see the u.s join the soviet moratorium
on nuclear testing the soviet cessation
of testing
preferably right now while before the
soviets test again
we will be going to the telephones in
just a minute or two please call us if
you have a question or a comment on any
of the subjects we have already raised
or any others that you're interested in
the the numbers which you will see at
the base of your screen are if you're
calling from the eastern or central time
zones area 202 628-2525
if you're calling from the pacific or
mountain time zones area 202 783-2727
[Music]
do you uh
find in the liberal opposition to
aid to the contras or to getting
involved in the war in nicaragua
some of the leaders of the old liberal
movement in vietnam
well again when you say leaders of that
movement they've moved on most of them
to other things happy hoffman has not i
noticed he's just facing trial
and has been to nicaragua a number of
times
i came into that movement indeed after
68 and after chicago protests
i came from the rand corporation from
the defense department from a different
background of most of people in that
movement in a way
my
my
entry was like that of the veterans in
vietnam who had that experience
and came into it
but
the point is i think that the movement
against our intervention in nicaragua
represents people young and old who did
learn a very different lesson from that
war
than president reagan learned
they learned that they don't want to
reproduce it in nicaragua or anywhere
else that
that america that it was uh
hard to give one word to it a mistake a
tragic error
i came to see it as criminal in many
ways in the sense that it broke laws of
our own country our constitution and
international law in many ways but even
people who did not and i based that on
documents in the uh that i'd seen my
experiences in vietnam
and that wasn't a judgment that was
shared by everybody who opposed that war
but it was enough to see that it was a
war that must end
and
it did end
because of our founders
of our constitution
their wisdom in providing ways for the
congress to leash in to rein in an
executive out of control it was one of
the major reasons for separating from
england and all to get out from the
tyranny of autocratic
executive control and the provision for
congress to cut off the money enabled
congress to end that war
on public demand by
cutting off the funding for the bombing
that is the way i think the arms race
can be ended i think it's really the
only way it can be ended congress must
take that responsibility for suspending
money as the house
did last before iceland in a strong
majority vote cut off the funding for
the testing of nuclear weapons
so long as the soviets were not testing
no soviet testing no u.s testing
that was
a strong majority vote and now with the
democratic senate
i think that there's a real prospect
that the congress as a whole will do
that if they do they'll be doing
something that has really one precedent
uh that was the way the vietnam war was
ended that's a precedent of power and of
success
we'll take our first telephone call from
milwaukee wisconsin go ahead please
uh good evening mr ellsberg how you
doing how are you where should i look uh
um is a survivor of the uss liberty
attack
that was back in 1967 i'm sure you
remember it well pardon me you are a
survivor yes i am sir
uh the crew of the liberty feels it was
a deliberate attack and we've been
trying for the last 20 years to to come
out
with this and have a government come
forward and tell us you know their full
story i'm sure you could shed some light
on this
uh
if you feel
uh that the government will ever come
out what the true story
to satisfy us
and
would you with your knowledge of the
government at that time be willing to
help us with our plight
i certainly would
have i have studied that not in detail
and i didn't know of it officially the
details at the time what i've studied as
i'm sure you're aware is that there is
uh very strong evidence the
circumstances of the attack the
prolongation of it the targeting
suggests very strongly that it was a
deliberate israeli attack probably
intended to keep the u.s from knowing
the uh israeli counterattack plans at
that point the fact that they planned to
launch an offensive at that moment and
they deliberately chose to
hit an allies
ship
in the fear that the president if he
knew that if he had that intelligence
indication might act on it to restrain
them
by the way to bring that up to date
that's a very uh obviously there are
strong the strong bases for our close
relationship with israel and at the same
time there couldn't be a more
spectacular demonstration if you like
that our ally any allies
interests may at a given moment sharply
diverge from those of the us
the fact that our ally israel could
could actually deliberately and
without admitting it covertly attack an
american ship and cause casualties is
the strongest illustration of that
obviously we're seeing that in the
current situation and i think that
you're the example that you bring up is
one the american people should reflect
on to uh
in part uh understand uh how it came to
be that uh
having chosen an ally the israelis in
this case to be our agents in dealing
with iran
we put ourselves in a position where we
were subject to some manipulation and to
actions that were not really in our
interest
c-span will be carrying this friday at 6
p.m a call-in program with david
horowitz and peter collier former
editors of ram parts magazine the topic
will be perspectives on the vietnam war
their article in commentary magazine
another low dishonest decade on the left
they will be taking a view somewhat
contrary to that expressed by our guest
tonight and we hope you will be here for
that uh
program we'll take another call now this
one from burbank california go ahead
please
good
good evening can you hear me good
evening we hear you loud and clear okay
i uh
uh mr elsa guys
i'd just like to say god bless you for
helping
get us out of vietnam i mean
[Music]
i cuz i was gonna be next
and uh you know
i would you know and i i supported the
conscience too i thought well you know
not because i like them not because of
the corporate country involved but
uh you know and i thought by doing that
that maybe our government might have
learned the right lesson but it doesn't
seem like that's what's happened i don't
care if you're democrat republican in
between or you don't know what's going
on
if you're going to support the congress
then it takes
the american people support and i think
that's something that our our government
officials have forgotten and we're kind
of lucky to have a daniel ortega because
if we do support the contras
then all of a sudden
our our public officials are asked the
question
what do we stand for and it's something
they want to you know something they
haven't addressed yet anyhow i thought
i got a cute little song it's only four
verses and it's for the members of
congress and i know you'll love it i
know you'll love it but and it's not
something you have to respond to but i
think you are worthy of hearing it and
if you can bear with me it's just four
verses and it goes like this
congress was deadlocked this must not go
on
i voted aid
to the contract i've got to be strong
against communism
i voted eight
to the contras
now i will win my next re-election
i voted aid
to the contract
ate to the region will trick everyone
i voted aid
to the contrast does that doesn't
nicaragua when the united states and the
soviet union does not look like a
chernobyl waiting to happen and i'll
hang up and i'll let you respond and god
bless you
well thank you you give me various
things to respond to there i must say
i'm i'm forced to reflect on the fact
that um
i was a contra
in vietnam i worked i was an american
contra in the sense in which president
reagan proclaims himself a contra
counter-revolutionary against the
revolutionary national movement i was
trying to win that war for america and i
i and for the people the vietnamese who
are on our side who could well have been
called contras at that point
a lot of them were my friends i
certainly can have sympathy in that
sense for the people who are
i think many of them very sincerely the
younger people in that country uh who
have
joined
the countries
just in the spirit in which people
worked on the american side in vietnam
and yet
sympathy and a kind of pity for people
who find themselves working essentially
for foreigners
in a cause which cannot and does not
have the support of most of their
country people men and women it's a
hopeless cause situation for them to be
in and it's not a situation for us to be
in hiring people to do that to fight
against their own countrymen i can also
re recognize i think from what i've
heard
uh the contra leaders from the
information we have and i think what
we're going to be getting uh in terms of
the leaders the country leaders we
backed in vietnam those vietnamese too
were drug runners
murderers
terrorists not all of them as i say some
of them were close friends of mine
people that i respected and others were
people that the united states should not
have had as agents and should not have
called allies and that seems very
clearly to be true of a number of the
country leaders who we inherited from
the regime of samosa
so
i was in vietnam because i thought
that um
the presence of americans could be good
for that country for those people
there were a lot of bombers along with
me
and napalm and troops were getting shot
at and shooting and our presence wasn't
good for that country or this country
and i think that would be true in
nicaragua
birmingham alabama do you have a
question or a comment
good evening good evening mr ellsberg uh
i was at the chicago nuclear freeze
convention last month and went to a
couple of your workshops and you were
absolutely wonderful i want you to know
that
thanks being from alabama i want to ask
you what is your opinion of how we can
best influence conservative congressman
conservative senators to vote for uh
ending the arms race our congressman
here in alabama are senator senators for
the most part they've always voted for
the m.s they've always
voted for star wars how can we influence
conservative southern
politicians to
vote in the arms race well the reason
i've been talking about congress
somewhat more than the executive here
tonight is because congress as shown in
the vietnam war in other cases
is more responsive
to the people they're closer to them
they have smaller constituencies they
hear more for their constituents than
that single or two elected men at the
head of the executive branch far more
responsive and in large part because
they face re-election every two years in
the house or six years
otherwise there's an old expression in
washington about congress if they don't
see the light they may yet feel the heat
and you speak how you can influence your
conservative congressman or senator's
house the answer ultimately certainly
you should reason with them and let them
know what you feel and what it takes to
represent your attitudes and those of
your colleagues and those who agree with
you and you should also let them know
that they work for you
that they are your servants that's the
glory of this country that's what we do
fight for in our wars
to defend and it's worth fighting for
our wars do not always serve that cause
of democracy very well but it's what the
people fighting the war at the fighting
level believe themselves to be fighting
for and they're not wrong to think that
it's worth it so you should let them
know
that uh
they will be fired
if they don't carry out the will of
their constituents not just yours of
course but to you should work to make
that a majority help make it a majority
opinion and that can be done very
specifically you can let them know that
what you want of them as your
representatives and public servants
is to use their constitutional power in
the senate as well as the house to do
what the house did last fall and that is
to vote to suspend all to cut off all
testing for nuclear weapons so long as
the soviets do not test
that could end testing forever
whatever president reagan or his
successors feels about it that would be
the public will the great majority of
the american people
do want that to happen just as they want
an overall freeze and the administration
has been ignoring that
as
as they have been ignoring a number of
other things it's time now for them to
feel the heat from congress how does the
nuclear freeze movement go about
lobbying congress aside from the
demonstrations you've staged from time
to time here in washington
the freeze movement on the whole was um
well they had very large demonstrations
letter writing uh lobbying of the usual
sort which is which means uh having
informed representatives in washington
going to the offices of the congressman
letting them know what bills we support
and helping them draft legislation in
some cases in a number of cases the
freeze brought
encouraged people to come on their own
to washington for major days of lobbying
it's only quite late in the game
that the freeze movement which wanted to
distinguish itself from the protest
movements of the 60s to tell the truth
uh and therefore stood aloof from uh the
tactic of civil disobedience for example
only really quite recently did it come
to endorse actions of the kind that are
going to happen at the nevada sestite
tomorrow as a matter of fact tomorrow
morning the 27th
where martin sheen is uh probably going
to be arrested with chris christopherson
protesting uh nuclear testing on the
anniversary of the first nuclear test
there that demonstration will include
acts of civil society it'll be both
demonstrations i think there'll be a
presence here at the doe on february 5th
we expect really quite a major
protest blockade as i say this is not a
freeze action this is an action however
which the freeze and sane have endorsed
there will be an action of blockade of
that test site
trying to delay symbolically with our
bodies
the
first american nuclear test of 1987
because that test
according to the soviets will end their
moratorium they will feel free to
presume testing after 18 months of no
tests
which means that that test will restart
a two-sided
test case
test program
in my opinion
for the president
to start the soviets testing again
by continuing our testing
on february 5th
would be an act as unwise
desperately unwise as his first shipment
of arms to iran
we need to help him
by resisting that policy san diego
california go ahead please
um mr ellsberg i think if you as one of
uh
democracy's martyrs in a sense and that
i imagine that you must have paid a
pretty big price both professionally
legally personally economically for what
you did is that one true two do you have
any regrets and it sounds like from the
integrity in your life that you don't
and three
um would there be any advice that you'd
have to potential whistleblowers either
in government and corporate service
today who may have to make moral choices
that really could affect their
professional or uh economic future thank
you well thank you for what you said
um
actually i don't think of myself as a
mother and it wouldn't be appropriate
for anyone to think of me that way the
the white house
in those days had uh intended that i be
a martyr of some kind
but they failed uh they were the ones
who went to jail on the whole president
nixon himself was impeached uh in part
because he he thought about me he had me
more on his mind than was good for him
but in fact they failed
to make me a martyr at all so
my
wife was with me throughout that
ordeal of the trial and that is an
ordeal and we go closer than ever and
that's the core of my life i have a new
uh
young son
and
a lot of friends
in i do have to say that my friends are
mostly
new friends
because everyone i'd known had a
clearance
uh really in the 15 years that i worked
for the executive branch
uh
i was kind of uh leper
after that trial uh
being with me at all i think i've i've
learned indirectly from some of them led
them to feel that it would jeopardize
their careers of course many disagreed
with what i'd done very intensely others
who didn't uh still felt that they
couldn't afford to associate with me so
i lost essentially all of my friends
with the very few exceptions obviously
that was a big price but there is life
outside the executive branch
there are a lot of friends available who
don't have clearances and the new
friends i've made are very valuable to
me
for those of you who may have forgotten
how big the pentagon papers case and
daniel ellsberg's role in it was back in
the 1970s i would refer to you to the
book by woodward and bernstein all the
president's men and let me read a line
from that book the disclosure that hunt
and liddy
uh two of the convicted figures in
watergate had supervised the burglary of
daniel ellsberg's psychiatrist office
had inextricably linked watergate in the
ellsberg trial in los angeles in the
post newsroom the two stories were often
referred to as watergate east and
watergate west is that the reference
bring back memories well i remember the
day when it it was revealed in the court
that
that the
white house plumbers haunted moody
who who did correspond in function and
sort of a role to colonel north and some
of the other
had burgled the psychoanalyst office
watergate had been big news on the east
coast for a while and the reporters
covering my trial certainly felt that
they were in a backwater they said you
know my god watergate meets the pentagon
papers it was exciting for them but it
was exciting for us and of course it did
lean to the end of the trial new york
city you are on c-span
hi um yes i heard mr ellsberg in new
york city on
wbai radio and i found found it very
interesting
my question is sort of related to that i
there's a program they have there called
contra gate um between 8 and 8 30 and i
listen to it pretty regularly when i
wake up and i hear
all kinds of stories on this this radio
show
about uh contra drug connections
a plot to kill ambassador thames
the ambassador to costa rica that the
contras and the cia were set up and a
host of other stories which
are
they they make they make the reagan
administration same seem like uh really
traitors and what what
i don't understand is why i don't hear
this in the mainstream press and i'm
just wondering if most of these stories
are fabrications by this radio station
wbai or if this is really happening and
the press is not reporting it
well i just spent last evening talking
to a very fine american
a very patriotic and dedicated american
named daniel sheehan
who is working for subsistence wages as
a lawyer
in a public interest law firm
a religious based public interest law
firm called the cristic institute
and they have taken on the defense of
two americans named tony arvigan and
martha honey
and named as defendants
in this suit 29 officials
i'm sorry a
slight slip but not entirely 29
individuals many of them former
officials or the united states
government
uh that they charge as having been
conspirators
in a
long criminal conspiracy
violating laws of this country which in
part had the effect
of severely injuring tony
avergan when he was covering a press
conference of eden pastora the contra
leader in costa rica and the charge with
a good deal of i was reading now a lot
of the evidence that they have in the
affidavit that supports that suit
is that these people some of whom were
then american officials at the time were
involved in trying to kill aiden pastor
because he wouldn't cooperate with the
cia the suit also involves these same
individuals in plotting to kill
with witnesses and participants
louis tams that you mentioned the
ambassador of costa rica uh
who was by the way a great culture
supporter and for that very reason was a
candidate for assassination
by these contras because his
assassination was to be blamed according
to the suit
on which is a sworn affidavit on uh the
sandinistas and be used as a provocation
or an excuse for an american attack on
nicaragua something like the
tonkin gulf provocations that were
involved
that led to our attacks in north vietnam
i've read a good deal i say the evidence
supporting this some of this is about to
come out
if these allegations are true and i i
can vouch that it's my judgment that
danny sheehan
of the christic institute defend
deserves great support
i'm very impressed by him and if these
allegations are true and are proven in
court
we will see that our government
has engaged in what can only be
described as a criminal conspiracy
whether or not
it was
authorized by the president of the
united states
we don't hire a president we don't elect
a president
to break the laws of the united states
to murder
or injure american citizens and
otherwise break laws such as neutrality
act or the boland amendment forbidding
money going down to nicaragua
his oath that we demand of him in the
constitution is to take care that the
laws are faithfully executed so whether
or not the president was aware
the allegations make a pattern of what
the suit calls racketeering and that's
not the business our government should
be in
i want to inject at this time into this
discussion an article that i know you
disagree with the article we referred to
earlier that will be the subject of a
c-span call-in program on friday at six
o'clock it is called another low
dishonest decade on the left the authors
are peter collier and david horowitz
david horowitz being i believe a former
close friend of yours is that true and
they are quite critical of the new left
uh and one of their criticisms is the
post-vietnam left is always ready to
believe the official soviet lie give the
soviets the benefit of the doubt or
where the abuses are too great at least
to understand in quotes horrific soviet
acts as a legitimate reflexive fear of
american power your response well i
think that's slanderously wrong uh i'm
very dismayed to hear my former friend
who's a brilliant analyst of the cold
war and
a strong leader in the fight against
vietnam
say such a thing he has certain elements
of the left known personally to him very
intimately of whom that could probably
be said to be true a very tiny minority
of the american public and of the
anti-war movement
but as a description of the majority
movement specifically of the movement to
end nuclear
arms race that couldn't be
less true
the freeze movement of which i'm part
was an original sponsor
put great emphasis on stopping soviet
testing deployment production of weapons
because we regard the soviet weapons
it's enormously threatening to the world
security having the capability obviously
like ours of ending life on earth and it
seems to us extremely important
that there should be no new soviet
weapons no more soviet weapons indeed
that there should be enormously less
we don't know any way of achieving that
that lee lets the united states
continue to proliferate weapons not that
we would like that to happen anyway it's
obvious that that can only be done by a
mutual freeze but um the people who most
claim that uh
the anti-nuclear movement
pro soviet slanderously and i i must
very sorry regretfully
include the president in that his
statements to that effect have to be
described in my opinion as slanderous uh
whether he knows better i don't know as
david horowitz certainly does know
better but uh
those people led by the president seem
to have no concern at all how many uh
weapons new weapons the soviets have the
soviets have in effect passed the switch
to their own testing to president reagan
they've said if you don't test in 1987
there will be no soviet tests just as
there were none in 1986
as i said before for him to press that
button by testing an american weapon
is deeply foolish to do it in the name
of anti-communism is uh bizarre
it what it means is that the president
thinks
it doesn't matter how many tests the
soviets make how many new weapons they
make as long as we test more as we have
as long as we have more weapons i think
that's deeply foolish and that
as foolish as some of the other policies
we're learning about now and it's up to
us as american citizens to change those
policies how about the reagan
administration argument that we have to
resume testing because we have fallen
behind the soviets uh in the development
of a new generation of nuclear weapons
well it's false
we've conducted some 24 tests while they
haven't tested any in the last 18 months
and even so
as dod department of defense and
department of energy spokesman have made
clear
people at livermore laboratory for
example have made clear we're ahead in
virtually every qualitative aspect of
the arms race certainly in such things
as the x-ray laser
the i will say the reagan administration
uh
did make the claim
that uh the soviets could have an x-ray
laser a bomb comptex ray laser a major
part of the president's star wars
program without further testing that was
so false
that livermore laboratory not a very not
what david horowitz would include in the
the left wing uh particularly uh
livermore laboratory made statements
saying no no that was not true the doe
they certainly could not have such a
weapon without more testing i'll say by
the way i don't want the soviets to have
an x-ray laser
the only way to stop them is for us to
forgo uh are having such a weapon and
that's a very good bargain for us eugene
oregon sorry to keep you waiting go
ahead please okay hi c-span um
i'd like to thank mr ellsberg for having
the courage to
turn over the pentagon papers to the
american people
i'm a vietnam veteran and
i currently own a small business up here
in the northwest
i'd like to comment on the
conscious situation that
is developing
now i i have to take exception when
when c-span uh mentions that he referred
to the people uh being liberals that are
against uh
uh against the conscience but the latest
poll that that i heard said that 68
percent of the american people don't
agree with president reagan's policy in
central america and certainly all of
them can't
can't be liberal
now
it seems to me that
if the reagan administration wanted to
uh wants to modify uh the
sandinista uh regime uh to uh uh more uh
along the lines of their way of thinking
they could have accomplished this
uh
to a much greater extent through
economic health instead of spending a
billion dollars on the contras and
trying to starve the nicaraguan economy
if the reagan administration had
economically
tried to help the
nicaraguan
government that they could
have gotten uh a lot more for their
dollar
and uh
i was wondering what mr ellsberg uh uh
how he what he feels about uh the
administration's chances of getting uh
another uh hundred million dollars for
the conscience i mean it seems like
we're getting close to having spent uh
about
a half a billion dollars or so on that
group of people and i believe that uh
there would be a lot fewer contras
joining up if we weren't putting
the economic squeeze on that small
central american country and i i also
think that the
contra leaders
and
lieutenants and officers are a bunch of
thugs and i like your uh your comments
please well i i obviously agree with uh
virtually everything you've said
uh
very specifically on the first point you
raise about the uh who who it is in the
american public
uh who opposes this the poll i saw last
week i believe it was a gallup poll
widely reported
showed a majority of republicans
opposing aid to the contras
just as by the way a majority of
republicans would like to see the
president uh negotiate a bilateral
nuclear freeze in both cases the
president is ignoring the desire of a
majority of his own constituency uh you
may or may not have noticed that it came
out during the republican convention
nominating reagan last
in the last election
they did a a poll of the convention
delegates there and a majority of them
were for the frees so to characterize
these attitudes as the attitudes of a
sec segment of the united states society
is is quite foolish as you say
uh and of course i agree
very much on the um
uh other lines that you said you do not
make a society more liberal by
terrorizing its countryside which is
essentially what the
counters are doing but i i think i
should add one thing to what you said
i think it's misleading for us to look
at the policy of the united states which
is very clearly i'm talking about
presidents reagan's policy i
made a slip there myself policy of our
executive branch under president reagan
is very clearly to overthrow the
government of of nicaragua the
sandinistas
i don't believe uh that they think
really in the pentagon my former
colleagues there and people who are in
vietnam that they will do that by the
contras alone
i'm sure the president is being told
that the only way to do that
would by be by u.s american armed attack
or invasion i don't believe by the way
the joint chiefs are recommending that
or ever have if anything i think they've
been a moderating liberal influence if
you like uh on that point but
they will follow the orders undoubtedly
if the president should send them in if
congress doesn't succeed in in
preempting it and stopping it cutting
off funds and getting that stopped i
think we uh prior to contra gate which
has probably weakened the president's uh
ability to do this politically i think
we had a very significant risk of
having pictures like that
come back from nicaragua possibly as
early as this spring and we may not be
have entirely eliminated that risk
because i think the president's
incentive to distract us
with a little war
will grow very great as he faces
talk and i'm not being rhetorical here
now as he faces serious talk of
impeachment and the destruction of his
administration
so i think we have to be
as
thomas jefferson said
vigilant
about our leadership in the months ahead
if we're to avoid
the body bags and having the cover of
time and newsweek look like that every
week the picture like that that you
referred to was not on camera at the
moment i am showing it now it is the
cover of this week's time magazine and a
cover story about
the movie platoon which uh
some think is uh one of the movies that
is changing the perception of the
vietnam war i'd like to ask you if you
think movies of this sort which time
calls the best movie made about the
vietnam war in the sense of being more
realistic
whether they have the power to change
the american perception about that war
and to what degree that change in
perception might be affecting the
american attitude toward getting
involved in nicaragua
well there aren't any movies of that
sort unfortunately
that's unique in my experience
that's not just the best movie made
about vietnam the vietnam war it's the
only movie about the vietnam war
and so far i hope there will be others
that that strive for that standard it's
an astounding movie i would say it's the
only realistic movie about war as i saw
it in vietnam that's ever been made and
i'm extremely happy to see the lines
when i saw it the other night i saw the
longest lines in my hometown that i'd
ever seen for a movie and i was very
encouraged to see that i would like
every voting american and every american
who isn't yet voting is coming to be of
draft age
uh young male to see that movie uh
shortly i would like i would love
congress to have to see that movie as a
whole i think that would end the contra
aid that the previous uh
listener asked about i can't believe
that they would vote money to send
american boys to kill and die
in such similar conditions in nicaragua
if they'd seen the realism of that movie
springfield virginia and the snowbound
washington suburbs do you have a
question or a comment for daniel
ellsberg oh yes
mr ellsberg uh well i would probably
fall within the uh eighty percent of
people that um
you say would like to see the nuclear
arms race stopped
i think uh there would be a significant
number of less people uh as a percentage
that that support the way groups such as
yours would want to go about it
you happen to mention um
you know
the soviets hadn't tested but there were
a significant number of people you you
may be personally concerned about
not being so naive as to trust the
soviets completely but there are a
significant number of individuals that
support you
who call for unilateral disarmament
who believe that if we don't attack
moscow that they'll leave us alone
and that basically support an
isolationist uh
sentiment in this country that prevailed
prior to world war ii that
barring an attack on washington that
there's nowhere in the world that
america should ever have to use military
force and i think that that
settlement is one of the reasons
you'll have a difficult time selling the
major while many people may agree with
the positions that you take the message
that you would go about it uh they won't
agree with
and i i don't think as a world power
if would you support personally that if
we gave no money to the contras at all
and the sandinistas invaded honduras or
anywhere else down there
uh that we then should attack them or
would you say well and that's no threat
either is there any place in the world
other than an attack on washington dc
that you feel would be justified using
american force
when i enlisted in the marine corps in
1954
it was with the example of the north
korean attack
across the border into south korea
i went in during the korean emergency
although actually the fighting had
essentially ended by the time i got in
and i went in
feeling that
that i was proud of my country that it
accepted a role as part of a u.n leading
a u.n
police force there against the principle
of aggression i thought
it wasn't presented as a unilateral
action i wasn't i wasn't didn't face
that particular issue of should we take
on the role of the world's policemen
alone it was certainly put to us that uh
the uh we did have the full support of
the u.n in opposing that aggression
you've described a situation of
hypothetical aggression
by the uh
nicaraguans into honduras and if the oas
called for denounced that as aggression
and called for combined action against
that
i would think that that
would could very well be appropriate and
with within american values in other
words i'm as opposed to aggression now
as i was when i was in the marines in
the 50s obviously that's not what we're
seeing down there we're seeing a force
that is hired managed controlled
equipped
against the law of our country against
the wishes of congress during 50 from 54
till 56
hired by americans run by americans
going across the border
to do largely murder against the
civilian population some attacks on
military forces of that country in that
country
that is aggression
i don't want my country ever to be the
aggressor it is right now and it has
been on other occasions that's a policy
i and i'll bet you
and a lot of americans want to see
changed
martinez california if i'm pronouncing
that correctly
and then correct me if i'm not go ahead
please yes mr uh ellsberg i'd like to
ask you a question i would i don't
consider russell banks exactly
a conservative yet this gentleman is
going around the united states of
america unfortunately he hasn't been on
c-span
raising money for the mosquito indians
who today and every day are being
murdered tortured and killed by the
sandinistas government
that the catholic church
in
nicaragua nicaragua has
their uh their
radio station their television station
they're a way to communicate with the
people been shut down by the communist
butchers in that country
uh
that the constitution which was an
excellent constitution that they
they just passed was suspended three
days after they passed it that there's
no civil rights in that country at all
uh there's no free press in that country
at all and there's about four hundred
thousand people who have decided with
their legs to show you what they think
of the great sandinista government and
they're residing now in refugee camps in
costa rica and honduras and i suggest to
you that instead of calling it the
nicaragua gate or whatever you want to
call it why don't you call it ask any
gate because some of this money went to
the afghan freedom fighters who are
fighting the russian tanks with their
molotov cocktails i haven't seen you do
one thing
not one thing to condemn the russians
about afghanistan where they make uh
hand grenades like toys so
kids can play with them and blow
themselves up you know uh uh i haven't
heard you say anything are you asking
cambodian people are you asking me my
opinion on afghanistan i'm glad to give
it to you a million of their own people
have been murdered by the communists
there the the refugees from uh vietnam
that you let down the primrose path of
communism where people jump on boats
with the
with their life in danger and leaving
that country and drove we're running a
little short of time let's give mr
ellsberg a chance to respond
i don't want nicaragua to be our
afghanistan
as vietnam was
as
i the soviets are aggressors in
afghanistan they're terrorists in
afghanistan how do i know because i see
them doing the same operations with 50
caliber machine guns i read about it i
read the effects i see pictures of it
that we did in vietnam and that was
aggression that was invasion that was
terrorism i don't want our country to
imitate the soviet brutality and that as
they're imitating ours now
in short i don't want us to have as i
say another afghanistan or vietnam in
nicaragua the various
uh injustices brutalities that you speak
of in nicaragua the other limitations of
that government which characterize a
country at war and don't in many cases
compare unfavorably with our own
performance at war and extraordinarily
better than the performance of our
allies like el salvador or guatemala
which i haven't heard you mention the
fact is put them at their worst put them
at you describe them somewhat
exaggerated but they're real you are
talking about real false real
brutalities of that regime down there
put them at their worst
do they justify american invasion of
that country do they justify your sons
and brothers and others and your voting
taxes to send down an invasion of that
country in my opinion no you have a
right to vote your taxes that way but
you're in a minority of americans and i
thank god for that we have a switchboard
lit up and only about nine minutes to go
if you'll keep your questions short
we'll see how many more we can get in
little rock arkansas go ahead please
good evening uh mr ellsberg have you had
against all odds that came out of cuba
prisoner for 25 years uh no is that a
validaris the prisoner yes
i've heard that's a very good book have
you read the book no i've heard of it i
read reviews i would be very glad with
you if you read the book and then maybe
you understand why it's so important
that nicaragua does not remain communist
i like to remind you of course
that vietnam today is a
hell on earth as cambodia is only
because the united states was unable to
finish its job in vietnam it's a fact
today
that the vietnamese people on both sides
are worth of way worse off than they
were would have been if america had won
at war
can we let mr ellsberg respond
yes
um
one small point i think that's worth
making
in our understanding of the situation
the administration routinely describes
nicaragua as if it were as unfree a
country as cuba
in
its various aspects that's grotesquely
untrue there are many parties in allowed
in
nicaragua which in fact
i have witnessed are free to criticize
and do criticize take part in the
assembly uh in a way that is not true in
cuba is not true in the eastern bloc
there are that difference but i don't
want to press that point it doesn't bear
too much on what we're talking about
today
the question is will the liberties
of the nicaraguans and the welfare of
nicaraguans
be improved
if the united states
reproduces
in nicaragua what we did
in vietnam and what the soviets are now
doing in afghanistan in my opinion
very tragically not uh
if you were a cuban
uh it would seem to me
understandable uh that you would
individually you would have every right
and it seemed to be very understandable
to feel that there were things happening
in your country that uh offended you
terribly that needed to be changed that
were deserved even revolutionary uh
efforts on your part if you called in as
a i'm not saying that you're a cuban
hypothetically here
if you were to call in misguidedly as
some cubans have done
hoping that on americans for combat help
hoping that american bombers would help
free your country you would be making
the same tragic mistake that the people
i worked with in vietnam
made
something would happen to that country
of nick of cuba and nicaragua
and if you think that hell on earth
is where the vietnamese are now and
imagine
they would be better off if we were
still bombing them
you were terribly misguided
santa barbara california you are next go
ahead please yes
i have a question for daniel ellsberg on
lebanon do you think u.s troops would be
appropriate use of military force if we
go in and clean out all the terrorists
uh i hope that's a kind of rhetorical
question because
i think the american people
getting a good look at lebanon
correctly saw that the president had
made an almost incomprehensible error
in committing american marines in small
numbers or large had he done so to
lebanon and it was democratic pressure i
think that caused them to reverse his
policy and pull those marines out after
they had suffered
serious terrorist casualties in there
again a situation where there are
terrible rights and wrongs on not just
both sides one has to speak of dozens of
sides in that country and it's a kind of
morass
in which for the united states to think
that we could go in there and police and
bring order to that situation would be
the kind of arrogance
of old men in power
that would lead again to the deaths of
innumerable young americans
lied in there by their leaders and
innumerable lebanese
for many lebanese right now lebanon is a
place of hell
if american bombers were added to the
individual terrorist bombers that are uh
terrorizing that place uh you would not
see order you would see a new order of
hell that the lebanese had not yet
conceived of freeport illinois we have
time for your call if you'll keep your
question uh short go ahead please i'd
like to call your attention to an
article in the wall street journal
thursday january the 15th
that cited 137 cases from 1798 to 1970
where executive action was committed
without approval of congress you keep
throwing around the constitution
and the violations of statutes of
statutes are different than congress con
constitutional law
and uh
the war powers act the bowling amendment
things like this have never been
checked to their constitutionality
would you have any comments on this yes
indeed the the war powers act is an
attempt by congress to regain some of
the powers that uh were clearly
specifically uh laid out for congress
exclusively the power to declare war the
power to raise armies and to make war
essentially
given exclusively to not the direction
of the war
to congress and which
powers which had been terribly eroded
not by law not by court decisions but by
the practice of president after
president as you describe some of those
early ones were small
naval raids
rather small demonstrations some were
not so small
president
wilson for example a great democratic
liberal
occupied nicaragua for uh many years as
he occupied haiti and dominican republic
with american marines
not the marines finest hour in actual
fact and not wilson's finest hour uh but
that sort of thing
on a much greater scale in the cold war
er after second roller did indeed erode
congress's role to a point where people
were almost willing to say well they're
not really in it anymore that's outmoded
vietnam revealed to us that that
constitutional power needed to be
revived the reason the president seems
to have broken laws in giving aid to
nicaragua right now to the contras is
that there was a law to break congress
had made a law which had no precedent
before vietnam vietnam had taught
congress its responsibility and its
power to act constitutionally to rein in
the president and that's why when he
ignored them he was not just doing
something unpolitical
he was acting illegally our guest has
been daniel ellsberg an activist in the
nuclear freeze movement and author of
one of the pentagon papers during the
vietnam war thank you very much for
being with us thank you thanks to our
c-span viewers for your calls and
comments have a pleasant evening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you'd like more information about
this or any other c-span program please
feel free to write to us
our address is 400 north capital street
northwest
washington dc
2001
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
up next the focus of our call-in program
shifts to events in the persian gulf
the guests in our studios for the next
hour or so are former state department
and defense department official daniel
ellsberg and the director of the center
for security policy frank gaffney we
invite your calls on the possibility of
military action in the gulf region
[Music]
[Music]
frank gaffney director of the center for
security policy does president bush have
the authority to commit the united
states to war in the persian gulf
without the approval of congress
well i think if it comes to actual
hostilities
and sustained engagement of u.s forces
whether you're looking at the
unvarnished constitution or whether
you're looking at the war powers
act version of the constitution he's
going to have to have congressional
consent
and daniel ellsberg former defense and
state department official the same
question to you does president bush have
the authority to commit the united
states to war in the persian gulf
without the approval of congress
no
not in our country
our president doesn't have the powers of
president saddam hussein or any other
country where the commander-in-chief can
commit the country to war
authoritatively
i think the founders of our constitution
felt that that was
the most important decision that a
country could make the decision between
war and fees
and they gave it exclusively that
decision the congress in order to make
it hard to go to war and to avoid
wrongful wars of various kinds i think
the war powers act i've come to conclude
is not only being ignored right now it's
it's really inadequate
it's being treated as a dead letter i
think the constitution got it right the
first time the answer is simply no it's
congress that has to make that decision
does it surprise you that uh more than
200 years after the constitution was
written there is still considerable
disagreement uh in washington as to the
meaning of that war powers clause well
it doesn't surprise me that various
presidents have uh are pushing against
the constraints of that clause i think
any executive branch
is in the words of jefferson a direction
madison to jefferson explaining why they
had given the power exclusively to
congress he said
all history shows
that the executive is the branch of
government most interested in war and
most prone to it
that was a profound insight at the time
and 200 years later history has
continued to confirm that over and over
so presidents indeed feel jealous of the
dictatorial powers of their adversaries
and feel that they're hampered by a
constitution that
ties the president's hands well that was
exactly the intent of that constitution
to tie the president's hands and to give
that power to congress to unleash war if
that should prove necessary mr gaffney
there has been a lot of debate in
washington this past week over what if
anything congress should do at the
moment about the persian gulf crisis
what do you think
congress might do
what do i think they might do or what do
they think they should do well either
one
well they have evidently chosen to do
nothing for the time being
my guess is that that will be
the case unless and until the president
does in fact
exercise force against saddam hussein
and i chose my words carefully in
response to your question i i personally
think that the president
is in a position and may well choose
to
use u.s forces
in a
rapid
strike against saddam hussein
and bring congress into the process
after that happens he may choose to do
that and there will be a horrific debate
about the constitutionality of it
afterwards but my my perception of what
the congress is doing and my guess is to
what they will do is to cede to the
president the responsibility
for acting and
carp yes criticize in all likelihood but
in the end leave the
responsibility for exercising u.s forces
in his hands at least until they come
back into formal session in january our
guests tonight are frank gaffney
director of the center for security
policy assistant secretary of defense
for international security policy uh
back in 1987 assisted assistant
secretary of defense for nuclear forces
and arms control policy from 1983 to 87
senior professional staff of the senate
strategic and nuclear forces
subcommittee
in the past and author of numerous
opinion pieces and articles on security
policy our other guest daniel ellsberg
former defense and state department
official you reveal the pentagon papers
to the senate i think you're best known
to the american public
for that to the senate and the press
during the vietnam war you are currently
at work on a study of the risk of war
posed by international crises you've
just recently
been published in mother jones the
nation and ticken is at the tacoma
tikkun
uh you mentioned uh mr gaffney the
possibility of a rapid strike
ordered by the president against iraq
what do you think the reaction
of the american public would be to such
an action
well i think it will depend a great deal
on when it happens and of course it will
depend in part upon how successful it is
my own view is
that if we
accurately
describe
the character of the problem in the
persian gulf which i don't believe
anybody certainly the official
washington has done to this point
there will be far greater support for
military action than there might
otherwise be and i believe that that can
be described succinctly as this we are
dealing
in saddam hussein's iraq
with a
an unacceptably dangerous correlation
of three factors
first a megalomaniacal
ambition on the part of the leader of
this country
second a
despotic control over this strategically
located country and third
a massive arsenal
including weapons of mass destruction
and my own feeling is
that those correlations
that
combination of factors gives rise to an
utterly unacceptable situation
in fact one that will produce conflict
in this very sensitive part of the world
later
for sure if not sooner and my feeling is
if the american people are
told of that fact and have it made clear
that what we are about
is preventing that conflict from
happening later under worse
circumstances with far greater costs by
acting quickly and decisively i
personally believe that the public will
be quite supportive and as will congress
mr ellsberg would you like to respond to
that well i'm happy to see i think we've
arrived at a point here of a very useful
disagreement between me and mr gabby
partly in matters of prediction where we
agree and i'm very happy is that he's
clearly saying that there should be a
public debate there should be a national
debate these things should be explained
and gone into more than has been done so
far
and indeed i would i would be happy to
see that i think the outcome would be
different
the reason i think that
is that
while i can actually accept entirely the
description of the factors that mr
gaffney has described
the threat the challenge that's posed by
saddam hussein and posed by his
aggression and we could we i'm sure we
could agree there are further the
potential nuclear capability in the end
and so forth he's describing only part
of what has to go into a decision by
either the executive or the country
essentially he's described the potential
benefits
of a military attack on saddam hussein
in disarming him of this threat that he
has now used aggressively of his
military capabilities of taking him out
of the picture in the middle east and a
lot of people arabs and others would
agree that that would be a desirable
thing to do
but that's as as mr gaffney knows you
know
very well
is only part of the considerations that
go into any choice of policy there's a
question of the costs
of this approach which amounts to a
preventive war really at this point it's
a response to aggression but it goes
beyond the response that the u.n has so
far authorized the arabs to a disarming
offensive attack which so far has no
almost no support except perhaps in
england
the costs of that would also have to be
looked at and i hope the upcoming
hearings will go into those and perhaps
we'll get to discuss those
how many americans will die in the
course of retaking kuwait
that's a very important question
some by the way have estimated already
figures on that ranging from ten
thousand to fifty thousand casualties
perhaps ten thousand dead in a matter of
weeks a pace of destruction far greater
than vietnam and a scale
comparable to vietnam
that's not the only cost to be
considered
iraqi civilians would die in very large
numbers from tens to tens of thousands
to perhaps a hundred thousand iraqi
retaliation is certain on israel in
egypt syria there's civilians there at
risk there's the question of terrorism
worldwide provoked by this uh
desperate scale is the effect on the
world economy
of
possible destruction certainly
disruption of the oil field
however long the effect is the immediate
effect is certain to be oil prices far
higher than we've seen yet putting all
those things together
i don't think the american people will
decide that the advantages of disarming
saddam hussein right now rather than
containing him at this point
are worth what the pentagon seems to
call these days the butcher's bill
there's just too much gas too much blood
that's prospected uh to be in that
gasoline i don't think they'll they'll
buy that and if it really comes to a
discussion which i which i hope will
occur
i think the policy will go otherwise and
the president will be denied
his authority to launch a preventive war
we'll be going to the phones in just a
couple of minutes please call us if you
have a question or comment you'll see
the telephone numbers from time to time
across your television screen mr gaffney
you served as assistant secretary of
defense for uh
nuclear forces and arms control
policy back in the mid 1980s
do you see any danger of escalation to
nuclear war by anyone in the middle
east well that's one of the reasons why
i think it is important
to
conduct the kind of military action that
i've called for
early because it is unquestionably the
case that eventually if not
next year
if not next month
certainly within a short period of time
saddam hussein will have access to
nuclear weaponry and i'm afraid to
ballistic missiles with which they can
be delivered over quite long distances
i think that today
the particularly given the character of
the forces how they are aligned that is
to say
the world essentially
aligned against
saddam hussein the risk of a conflict
around the kind of strike that i've
described
uh going into a nuclear
escalatory phase is very low indeed but
i frankly believe that everything that
uh
mr ellsberg has talked about
is
an argument
against waiting as much as it is an
argument for waiting in fact that it is
a far more powerful argument against
waiting
because frankly
the kinds of casualties that are being
talked about the kind of oil disruption
that's being talked about the kind of
attacks upon israel
and egypt and other countries that are
currently lined up against saddam
hussein
are certain to come about in my view if
saddam hussein is as
dr ellsberg puts it contained
at least for the time being to live to
fight another day that's the nub of the
issue i am not in favor of war for war's
sake i am not relishing the prospect of
anybody losing their lives iraqi
civilians american troops or anybody i
am simply quite concerned to be honest
that what we are talking about here
is
containing saddam hussein
in an effective way now
so as not to have to contend with a far
more unmanageable and far more bloody
far more costly far more disruptive
saddam hussein in the future i mean if i
understand you though you're not
proposing really containing him in the
sense of the cold war or the last 40
years
disarming i i picked up the term from
you i'm in favor of define how you mean
it and then let's talk about that if i
understand you you're in favor of a
disarming attack with the support
support and approval of congress in the
american people but you hope that they
will come to that i am i find that a
very different policy from what came to
be called containment rightfully i was
trying to use the term to distinguish
between what i think is an effective
policy of containment in this case as
opposed to one word where we hope
against hope that we will be able to i
think you're taking i think you're
taking the word containment as a kind of
slogan i'm sorry i'm pasting it on a
policy because it does have a favorable
sound that can't really be called it or
it's very different from containment
disarming decapitating
annihilating destroying his forces is
something very different from what we
chose to do against a far more better
armed and more ominous and more
dangerous opponent and that was stalin
and that was stalin's successors uh
virtually all of them up till the
present were as brutal as saddam hussein
which is very brutal dictatorial
aggressive in ambition but the choice
was made not to go for preventive war
but rather to confront them with
counterforce which meant living
reluctantly and with anguish with a
situation in which he imposed the
dictatorial rule on east europe
unwillingly later they went into
afghanistan their own rule at home was
equally dictatorial
we heard throughout that period
voices saying at least with at least as
much plausibility as now is what you've
just said
this man this country must be rolled
back now let's go now rather than later
and this particular premise that you've
made here which is the premise on which
arguments for preventive war is based
war later with this dictator this
country is inevitable
if i believed that i would certainly
have to take very seriously you know
your your proposal for preventative war
war now better than war later the truth
is the future isn't that certain the
people who said war with the soviet
union was inevitable and therefore we
should go in 1946 or 1953 or some other
date
in retrospect i think we're clearly
wrong you might disagree but i'm glad
that we did not go to war over hungary
or czechoslovakia or afghanistan despite
the tragedy that was involved for the
people of those countries they would not
have been helped if we'd gone to war
right now the people of kuwait i feel
quite strongly would not be helped and
you haven't given that argument of
course but to say that we should go
there
because of what the president tells us
about the anguishing tragedy that's
going on in kuwait is is kind of a
mockery and perhaps you agree
we would be destroying kuwait in order
to save it now in terms of the larger
region when it comes to avoiding the
threats that he called
i don't think that the future is that
certain that war is certain inevitable
and that is the only judgment uh that
one that leads directly to this argument
uh clear argument for preventive war i
think the argument is is uh there's
every reason to just to go on the
judgment which most people in the world
seem to be making
that in the u.n that saddam
brutal as he is can be confronted by
overwhelming force as he is now being
confronted in saudi arabia can be kept
on the other side of that line in the
desert so that he is not get into saudi
arabia the blockade can continue
and we should forego the immediate costs
by the way i've gone on here but i
noticed neither of us have really yet
argued
no you did address the question the
question of what the nuclear risks in
this situation are i'd like to say one
thing on that i agree with you of course
the risks are low they are not as they
are even lower than they were let's say
in the cuban missile crisis where we
confronted a nuclear enemy they were low
there but higher than i would have liked
i lived through that but i think we
should see in this situation
that even though saddam hussein does not
have nuclear weapons at the moment the
risk of nuclear war is unfortunately not
zero in this situation
reputable papers have quoted
unnamed officers on the whole and some
named officers in two countries
among our
more or less quasi allies at this moment
who have threatened that they would use
their nuclear forces if
chemical warfare were used against them
which is a strong possibility you name
those two namely no i can name the the
stories basically the london times and
the london observer have both the london
observer in particular has had major
front page stories uh quoting members of
the
british forces as saying that they were
prepared to use nuclear weapons if
chemical weapons were used against them
israeli officers have said that and
israeli analysts have said that israel
would use its nuclear weapons if
chemical weapons were used against them
i don't think these are idle threats it
should be said that both countries have
disclaimed that as an official policy
but the disclaimers are not thoroughly
convincing either so i think there is a
serious risk that has to be taken into
account we want to get to the telephones
we'll take our first call from columbus
ohio go ahead please
yes what i want to know i saw right
after the troops started over
to the persian gulf i saw bush come out
in maine
and on a tv spot and he said
uh well he had a smile on his face and
he came bouncing out that side door and
he said well they'll have to take
another look at the cutting the defense
budget now do you think that might be
one of the reasons we're over there
i i i personally do not ma'am i i think
that uh
there are some who are skeptical enough
of uh
the the president and of the uh
the defense department who will give me
an argument on that point but my own
view is
that we have moved forces there
quickly because we anticipated i think
correctly
that in these circumstances let alone in
the future saddam hussein's aggression
if not checked would have resulted in a
further toppling
of pro-western regimes in the gulf
i would like to think that congress has
been checked in its uh pell mel rush to
gut the defense budget i i must tell you
however in looking at what actually
happened
on the floor of the senate floor of the
house it uh it did not have
the effect of staying
all of the hands all of the knives all
of the budget cutting that uh that was
in the offing before kuwait and i think
as a result that the job the defense
department has to do of sustaining
forces and presenting the capabilities
to fight as complex as difficult and as
far off a conflict as might now be
involved
are going to be made more difficult as a
result of congressional action to pick
up on something mr ellsberg
said that i have seen
no stories in this country literally
none raising the possibility that uh
ally some of our allies might use
nuclear weapons uh why do you think that
the american press is not addressing
this nuclear question
i should say first of all that i think
that i have seen stories on the possible
use by israelis
i'm not sure have you seen the brits
in particular denials i might say that i
think the um the american press on the
whole
has not been i would say as good or
certainly as detailed in describing the
possibilities of offensive action here
uh as the british press has been right
across the board as early as august
i started following that because i
became aware that the london times and
the london observer and the independent
were all predicting
that the u.s would go to offensive
action before long that by the way woke
me up very sharply
of course the president's uh description
of his reasons for sending the latest uh
hundred thousand hundred and fifty
thousand has made that now an um
current here the the shaping of our
forces for offensive action frankly and
now to get back to the mo the question
comment you made a moment ago
my first reaction to the first uh set of
forces that were set there sent there
the in smaller numbers and to the
blockade in the embargo was really quite
favorable
uh i felt uh here my old former
colleagues in isa international security
fairs and in the pentagon have the
chance really to use a new way of
dealing with an aggressor not only to
contain him which was fine they were
doing that but to bring economic warfare
to bear on an aggressor in a way that
had never been possible before before
the end of the cold war and i was i was
very hopeful about that and that's still
a possibility in this situation
but
the
what as i say woke me up was learning
from the british press and i can't
answer your question why the american
was so slow to do this the la times was
faster than others the new york times
has really been very slow on this issue
but what woke me up was the the notion
that we were going to a major war the
relation to the defense budget is is
comes down to this i i'm sure
that mr gaffney and i have a lot of
disagreement about what the what should
happen to the defense budget after the
ending of the cold war roughly a year
ago i would say that major cuts were in
order at that point and now that we are
getting the kind of cooperation from the
soviets that we see in this situation
but if i believed that it was desirable
for the u.s to fight wars in the future
not against the soviets but on the order
of wars against iraq often described as
the third most technically sophisticated
forces in the world
uh after the soviet union in the u.s
then i would have to admit the defense
budget can't go down it so happens i
don't want to see those wars fought
we're having a little trouble with the
telephones uh do we have a call from san
francisco at the moment yes go ahead san
francisco sorry to keep you waiting oh
that's okay uh i just wanted to make a
comment i think the polls are down on
the president because the people think
that we're going to war over oil and i
think that's not exactly true i think
we're going to war to dethrone a man
who's brutally killed his own people and
other people in kuwait who has had um
executions i just read in the paper of
his own soldiers who disobeyed him who
were
trying to
flee iraq and i think that's why i think
the president is going in there and i
think we all as americans to support him
okay thanks for your call what about oil
how big a factor is it well i'd like to
uh certainly i think many people have
pointed out that uh in the president too
that
if it were not for the threat to the
control of oil that's posed by this
particular dictator we would not be
sending the forces or taking the risks
that we are and uh i think a lot of
people in fact support that idea as an
element as an important element in the
situation when it comes to the brutality
that the caller just spoke of she's
certainly right
the brutality is real it's terrible to
think of war on this scale as an answer
to that poses the question what do we do
about the other dictators some of them
are current allies who are just as
brutal just as expansionistic assad
of syria for example uh the uh the
iranian the iranian leaders uh with
their willingness to sacrifice life in
the in the recent war
uh
the same with the same i'll say same
with the nuclear question that you that
you pose which is certainly a serious
question i'm very i am concerned about
the possibility of iraq getting the
nuclear weapon in some years i'm
concerned about pakistan getting it this
year south africa other countries do we
really use preventive war against all of
those as the answer i think what i would
suggest is that formula that i
outlined at the beginning
that where you have the combination of
megalomaniacal ambition as well as
a geostrategic key position and despotic
control and there is no question about
it this guy's a world-class despot
and
the
the incipient or actual
weaponry of mass destruction in one's
arsenal that's where i think you you sit
up and take notice and certainly where
you're faced with an act of aggression
like this
you you've i believe got to got to deal
with you and try to take a few more
telephone calls here ortonville
minnesota go ahead please
hi ortonville
hmm
trying doesn't always mean that you get
a uh call does it again uh mr gaffney
let me ask you uh are you satisfied with
the level of the american intelligence
operation
in the middle east both before and after
iraq's invasion of kuwait
well as daniel ellsberg could tell you
the problem usually in conflicts like
this is not
the absence of intelligence
there's always intelligence the problem
is sorting out
what is useful valid information from
the noise
and in particular
getting your own wishful thinking
out of the way and i think what clearly
happened here the reason i believe we
are in the mess we're in today
at least as far as trying to roll back
saddam hussein out of kuwait is
concerned is
that the bush administration
failed to
accept and act upon intelligence about
an imminent invasion by kuwait and by
iraq of which there was abundant
evidence
and moreover failed to say
that that will produce war with us or
other dire consequences for you saddam
hussein to the contrary
again not a failure of intelligence our
diplomats our state department were
saying to saddam hussein things that
he i think quite reasonably interpreted
as a
suggestion that it would be okay with us
if he did go into kuwait we'll try and
hopefully try the telephones again
fresno california go ahead please yes
how you doing all right good um i'd just
like to say if we go to war with iraq it
seems to me that
the winners and this is egypt syria
iran and israel uh and the losers is
going to be iraq and us
the reason i say that is i think that
syria and iran the only reason that
syria is on a side and iran is staying
neutral is they want us to devastate
iraq so they can move on in because
that's going to be
i mean the natural resources there on a
defenseless country what's going to
happen after thank you very much for
your call
can the united states possibly come out
of the current situation in the middle
east as a winner either one of you could
i just suggest that
i very much take dan's point about syria
i think it if we learned anything
from the iran-iraq war
it should be that
making common cause
certainly in a sort of open-ended way
with these tyrants and
looking the other way if not actively
encouraging their weaponry
accumulation and their
territorial ambitions is a serious
mistake and i would hope that whatever
comes out of this
crisis
we certainly do not want to encourage
assad of syria
in his own megalomaniacal ambitions in
his own effort to maintain despotic
control of his own territory and expand
his control further and his own program
for acquiring weapons of mass
destruction how would you propose to
deal with that i'd be interested to hear
i think you've got to be keeping him in
check fully as much as you are working
against the most imminent problem right
and this is this is where we made the
mistake in the iran iraq war i think is
we
completely
let go of controls
particularly on technology on credits
and on the assistance that was provided
by our allies
military and otherwise as well as the
soviets
[Music]
well i think we may ultimately have to
and we shouldn't kid ourselves that he
is going to be on our side i think even
in the present crisis so let alone down
the road so your approach yeah i i
actually you surprised me a little uh i
thought she would say no we should
cut off his supplies perhaps embargo him
diplomatic and then i would have asked
you why not do the same with uh with
saddam hussein but you are more
consistent than that and i just want to
point out you are offering an approach
then which i i hear you're you're
sincerely
uh committed to and by the way which i
don't regard as a foolish approach or
not worth discussing by any means the
case for preventive war is as strong as
i've ever heard it made in this case i
don't think it's good enough but i do
point out that if one uses that approach
that the premises on which it based
point to a series of wars not just this
one but war against syria
against iran surely possibly against
other leadership later
and others i think they're we have to
find a better way
to suggest to my attention
one of the things that i believe is
hard to calibrate
hard to
estimate in in
advance but one of the things that is
certainly true
of the effective use of force against
tyrants against despots against those
who are trying to conduct aggression is
it gets the attention of a lot of other
people who have the same thought in mind
and the failure of will
that would result were we to walk away
from this crisis now to to simply say to
uh saddam hussein okay
you're you're in charge would i believe
only invite those very wars down the
road let's bring the audience into this
discussion hillsboro new jersey go ahead
please
oh yes now that uh
iran is friends again with iraq
uh and like if there would be a war do
you think or uh iran would get involved
with the war on the side of iraq
all right
i don't i i'm not the expert to ask i
don't know if that's right
but i don't think anybody knows it does
uh that question though is very much in
key with one that was just asked that we
didn't really address uh i do agree with
the previous caller who said that uh in
in important ways both the us and iraq
would probably be losers in this war
putting aside a real possibility of a
very very effective technological six
day war which i'm afraid has wishfully
captured the imagination of some people
in the pentagon i think that's very
unlikely and that we would both find
that it had been a very costly war but i
don't think that iraq and u.s are the
only potential losers here
israel for example seems many people
there seem to be quite hopeful about
this war and want to see iraq disarmed
but in the process if israel became
involved directly in the war which seems
to me almost certain for example saddam
hussein himself will probably assure
that i would say by attacking israel
a u.s israeli war against an arab muslim
country
seems to me i'm convinced by those
experts that i've read that suggest
that that will almost surely cause
popular uprisings against most of the
arab countries that are now aligned with
us and throw the middle east into
turmoil into flames in a way we may be
involved in in counter-insurgency's ways
for a very long time that would be a
series of in vietnam's it could go for a
long time i think that would not be in
the security interests of israel or
egypt the present regimes in egypt
morocco and elsewhere tunisia may
actually fall or likely as a result
including saudi arabia so i think
there's there will be many losers in
this world
again this is one of those
imponderables but i believe that at
least as powerful an argument can be
made
that the fanatic
islamic radicals
that exist in all of these countries
will be emboldened
by a saddam hussein who has stood up to
and in fact beaten off not only the
united states but let's remember the
entire international community
bringing down those friendly governments
that are currently aligned with us in
the region and i believe ultimately
assuredly
bringing about a middle eastern war
involving israel
it can go either i do need to ask you
one i'm sorry i have to ask one question
that i'm just very at this point
that's a serious consideration i don't i
don't agree that it's as strong a
likelihood but that's the disagreement
between us certainly i'm not an expert
on that but i do need to ask you
from that line of argument then what is
your feeling retrospectively about the
policy of containing the soviet union
rather than taking what were very more
than provocations which were strong
aggressions in hungary in czechoslovakia
and elsewhere as the occasion for an
all-out war against the soviet union
what is your own opinion should we have
done it and when should we have done it
i'm delighted that you brought us back
to that because i wanted to respond when
it was in
in play
i think that you were dealing with a
fundamentally different situation
you had a soviet union that uh depending
on which point you look at actually had
nuclear weapons thermonuclear weapons
ultimately you had a soviet union didn't
make them safer millions of men under
arms in place throughout eastern europe
it was as a practical matter the best
that one could do under the
circumstances to think about containing
them and i would suggest that the most
important and fundamental difference
between the two situations is we had in
western europe
other democracies
reliable allies upon whom we could build
a common security framework the same
with the exception the distinct
exception of israel in the middle east
less than 15 minutes to go we'll see how
many telephone calls we can take
philadelphia go ahead please an
interesting answer uh yes given the
basic ideological differences between
the common person middle east and the
common person
uh in the west
it seems to me
difficult to approach it only on the
plane uh that we're approaching it at
present which is uh on the plane of uh
monarchs and
and uh oil tyrants and those types of
people
and
if if we follow it through on that level
or that plane i just feel it's in we're
we're in great danger
of
being a part of something much larger
than just a saddam hussein okay what do
you mean by the basic uh ideological
differences well
basically
what i'm talking about is the
the islamic thought
and
uh the western capitalist thought
of
how people should conduct themselves
i don't think that our differences
uh
are that great that we have to be
brought to war over them i think
the real reason is that we're over there
is due to our uh
you know our multinational interests our
oil interests
and i'm you know i don't personally i'm
a member of the libertarian party and
we're looked upon as uh bleeding heart
liberals and our views are not really
that way at all but
okay thank you for your call and see if
we can get a response
oh
well thank you we'll let that stand up i
think there are fundamental um
cultural differences that it would be
foolish to ignore
uh one of which is i think an attitude
about individual human lives
uh it is clearly the case in the middle
east particularly to the extent that
things get wrapped in a
islamic religious
cover
that the willingness of the leaders of
many of these countries whether they're
tyrants like saddam hussein or autocrats
like
others in the region
to expend
quite willingly quite uh casually tens
and hundreds of thousands of lives
which is simply anathema to those of us
in the west is not to be ignored and i
think in fact what we've seen saddam
hussein
play to rather brilliantly
especially in arousing people like
daniel ellsberg is the argument that he
will
without thinking twice
sacrifice
hundreds of thousands of his own people
in the process of killing more than weak
and stomach and that is
in my view
something that argues for preventing him
from having control of those people
rather than
our decision to acquiesce in his uh
continued rule mister
are you really saying that
that it's only my attention uh that has
been caught by these very credible
threats that he's making of engulfing
in fact
i think that the people in the pentagon
that a moment ago you thought uh you
said you thought might be uh toying with
the idea of some quick simple six day
war i don't think that's right i don't
sense that upon my former colleagues and
your former colleagues in the pentagon i
think most military people are are very
conservative about this i think a lot
depends on what kind of war you fight i
think that's true but will you disagree
i think uh the air force unfortunately
is is the service in which there
probably are some to be found like the
former chief of staff dugan whose views
after all are not different from his
predecessors curtis lemay who just died
or senator goldwater for that reason and
general
the air power approach here i'm not
saying that they're dominant i i agree
with you that i think uh both army navy
and many civilians have taken another
look i would just suggest that that
if you decide
to maximize casualties
by throwing
heavy mechanized ground units against
heavily defended positions
which is i think the preference of some
in the in the army um you will succeed
and saddam hussein will be able to
effect very expensively just again
change the tucson arizona end of this
conversation go ahead please tucson yes
i just want to congratulate mr ellisberg
on his views
i am an arab american
and i've been on the two side of the
fence
and i hope that mr ellsberg is one of
the
policy maker in this country because he
really put his his finger on so many
psychological and
and so many political
uh problem in this region and this i
just want to add to that one comment
is the arab
sociology or physiology or the way they
think is always
me and my brother again is my cousin and
me and my cousin again stranger
and i don't know if the the war breaks
tomorrow
i don't know if all those arab countries
which is for one egypt which is says i'm
not going to attack iraq
thank you very much for your comment
we're going to take another call from
detroit michigan go ahead please
detroit yes sir you are on i have a
question for mr ellsberg and also one
for mr gaffney the one for mr ellsberg
would be
if he has any idea of how many
billions of dollars other than the
5 billion
in the u.s department of agricultural
loans
that the u.s has given to
iraq to bolster its military position
and then for mr gaffney uh he seems to
suggest militarily
vanquishing any country that could
attain
nuclear weapon capability
i was just wondering what his ideas were
to handle the countries that
already have attained it
two very good questions gentlemen
uh i don't know i can't give details of
um
uh how much aid has been given
altogether my impression is that in
terms of the military
might that we're facing right now we
have to thank ironically
our new friend the soviet union which by
the way to its credit has has apologized
in effect has acknowledged error which
is rare enough uh it may not undo the
error but it's it's rare for them to say
we made a mistake to build up this
monster to the extent that it has been
and of course the french and the chinese
and many others contributed to that i
think our contribution was in aid
credits essentially for agriculture uh
which of course helped their overall
picture earlier by the way we we did do
something quite significant in giving
intelligence information to the iraqis
and i believe also to the iranians at
various times during iraq's aggression
against iran in that war
a sign of a
i think mr gaffney has alluded to this a
mistaken policy over several
administrations really a couple of
administrations
a kind of bad judgment about how to deal
with saddam that does not give
confidence to me
in turning over the judgment of war and
peace exclusively to the same executive
branch or the same group of people
it's the it's that reason i think that
one gives it uh to this messy process of
public information in congress uh to and
i see mr gaffney nodding on that it even
occurs to me there's a cultural aspect
to this too we hear a lot
about the
pride of arabs as a major factor in the
pride of both muslims but in particular
arabs and certainly that's a factor in
predicting that saddam hussein may not
do what he certainly should do and that
is to back down in the face of this
overwhelming force that's mustered
against him
i just want to say that's but that i
think is not a major cultural difference
at least when it comes to leaderships
i have worked for bosses in the pentagon
in 64 65 and later in the 60s where i'm
sorry to say the pride of presidents
is not all that different from the pride
of arab leaders the unwillingness to be
embarrassed to accept a failure to admit
a mistake the willingness instead of
that to avert that factor we haven't
talked about to avert admitting error or
mistake by risking a war that could be
catastrophic that i'm afraid is a is a
characteristic of leaders on all
cultures all parts of the world arab
muslim jew and american and that's
really why congress said let's try to
avoid wars that are caused by the pride
of kings give the decision to congress
and mr gaffney there was a nuclear
question addressed to you well the
caller oversimplified rather
substantially my position i i think that
we need to be mindful of countries that
are trying to acquire nuclear weapons
uh and particularly be concerned about
those that uh that have that combination
of malevolent will and despotic
tradition
as to those that have them already again
i i think as with the case of the soviet
union your options are somewhat more
limited i do think
that there is a powerful argument to be
made
in terms of dealing with those countries
that do have nuclear weapons
with our own effective credible nuclear
deterrent and ideally from my point of
view with an effective defense against
nuclear attack as well and could i just
come back to a point you made at the
outset that i haven't responded to
you asked about the question of how is
it that we haven't seen more american
coverage of this threat that our allies
might use nuclear weapons against a
chemical attack by iraq
the interesting thing another lesson
that i believe we must urgently learn
from this iran iraq this iraq kuwait
business
is that it is madness for the united
states to contemplate eliminating its
own chemical retaliatory capability
these countries at least in the case of
great britain
have chosen not to have a chemical
retaliatory capability to deter chemical
attack as a result they have no choice
but to go to nuclear weapons
the reports are that israel has chemical
weapons but i think they nonetheless
believe that the threat of nuclear
weapons will be a more effective
deterrent we are shortly i believe going
to enter an agreement
that will deny us the capability to have
chemical in-kind deterrent capabilities
saddam hussein and his ilk will always
have them and i think it would be
madness for us to rely on threats that
may be hollow of a nuclear response to
such an attack owensboro kentucky go
ahead please
uh yes
speaking as a veteran who knows the
capabilities of the machines of war i'd
like to ask their opinions on the what
kind of situation you think will result
in this country with already disgusting
domestic problems
concerning the vets returning and the
unthinkable degree of care in va
hospitals and the trends towards only
the poor
being the ones that are fighting and
dying in these wars
i don't think the machines will work
anywhere near what the enthusiasts of
whom there are some
in the
in the air force and elsewhere imagine
in fact when i read the optimistic
estimates of some associated with
general dugan and i don't know what his
successor is saying now
my i was absolutely astounded because
i'm well aware is gaffney that people
are serious in the pentagon they're
conscientious they're not uh lightheaded
basically and these these estimates in
some cases of no u.s combat casualties
or hundreds were so frivolous and so
irresponsible i could hardly imagine and
then i remembered uh i know i'm speaking
to a veteran here
i was in the marines during peacetime i
was in vietnam as a civilian but i saw
combat as a civilian as an observer
and saw the way things the machines
really work over there on both sides
uh i had to remember that it has been uh
15 years or since we were 17 years since
we were at a serious war
and of course we've never been in a war
against an enemy as technically well
armed as iraq since the second world war
so a lot of people are if if the war
does come a lot of people who advocated
it are going to be very unpleasantly
surprised and that includes air force
casualties i'm sorry to say as well as
their victims elsewhere i'm looking at a
story in yesterday's on the front page
of yesterday's wall street journal and
the headline is protesting a war is
always easier when there is one i'm
going to read a passage because you were
quoted in this story mr ellsberg and the
point that the wall street journal makes
is that the anti-war forces
go back to the vietnam war this time
quote can't seem to kindle a controversy
and it quotes you as saying i'm
perplexed and dismayed by the silence
and passivity of the public and congress
and i don't have a good explanation
explanation
for it you have any idea why yes i i did
tell the writer of that a number of
speculations but it's true i have been
perplexed and dismayed i don't feel i
have the full answer one difference from
64 65
and now
in the context of a great similarity in
both cases um
i think i see the executive branch
planning threatening preparing for and i
suspect many of them expecting
a war which will be a very major war and
planning to do this without the
unauthorization from congress that's a
an ominous similarity but a big
difference is that this time
the administration is being far more
candid as of the last month or two the
british papers got it earlier but as of
this week
and this month and even since that story
was written there is much more awareness
that the war is impending and even so
congress has not reached to grasp that
responsibility uh you you ask why i'll
give you a couple of speculations uh one
is
that i'm told by people who are in the
military family support network the alex
molnar the father of the marine in the
persian gulf started uh having written
an op-ed piece in the up it in the times
many people have gotten in touch with
him
several thousand now and he points out
that a major difference is that we have
a volunteer army
that really
gives me a lot to think about because
i've supported the volunteer army
concept for 20 years and i'm having to
rethink that if it's true that that
means that most especially white
middle-class well-educated people feel
quite remote for this their children are
not at stake and if that means that
they're not interested in exercising
their responsibilities as citizens on
this and that they don't care if other
people's children get destroyed
that's a serious difference and we may
have to change we are out of time our
guest tonight have been daniel ellsberg
former defense and state department
official and frank gaffney director of
the center for security policy thank
both of you thanks to both of you for
being with us tonight thanks to our
c-span viewers for your calls and
comments have a pleasant evening
that concludes our call-in programs this
evening a reminder to join us tomorrow
evening at 6 30 eastern time when the
guests on our call-in programs will be
the research director for fairness and
accuracy in reporting martin lee he'll
talk about media bias and we'll take
your questions and comments again that's
tomorrow at 6 30 eastern time 3 30 on
the west coast
we'll take a break now for some
programming information and then it's
today's hearing of the senate ethics
committee
[Music]
next a discussion on the future of
nuclear weapons held today by the global
structures convocation in suburban
washington dc the program is titled
manhattan 2 ending the era of nuclear
weapons
the panelists include allen k president
of the american talks issues association
the program begins with william pace
director of global structures and runs
about 90 minutes
good afternoon my name is bill pace i'm
the director of the third global
structures convocation
on human rights global governance and
strengthening the united nations
the purpose of this convocation
at which
a thousand people are attending this
weekend
is to bring together the human rights
community
the women's movement
the peace and disarmament groups
environment and development experts the
religious community
to discuss strategies for approaching
the upcoming world conferences and
meetings
and summits that are planned
in occasion on the occasion of the 50th
anniversary of the united nations in
1995.
there is an extraordinary array of
meetings
uh occurring now globally and decisions
will be taken as the secretary general
in his message to the convocation has
indicated decisions that will be taken
in the next two years that will
determine the future
50 years of the united nations these
include
decisions on the role of citizens in the
united nations
there's a third world women's our fourth
world women's conference a population
and development
uh conference there is a working group
that has just begun
on security council expansion and reform
at the u n and it says and other matters
which includes the united nations
charter
there are the global new global
commission on sustainable development
that will have two meetings
will be the implementation of the world
conference on human rights
proposals the vienna action plan
and one of those proposals the
establishment of a
new
commissioner high commissioner for human
rights has just been announced and
adopted
and there are this enormously dangerous
area of peace and disarmament the agenda
for peace
and the efforts to provide and promote a
safer world
just in recent
weeks we have seen for the first time
in my life and i was born the first year
of the
nuclear age
the first time a few weeks ago the
united states of america and
the former soviet union
who are still nuclear superpower states
agree
to stop targeting each other with their
tens of thousands of nuclear weapons
and stop targeting any other people on
this planet
it's now critical
that those
citizen groups
who have worked and sacrificed for so
many years
to try and promote peace and disarmament
take advantage of this next two years
and now we need to target strategically
how we can achieve
nuclear disarmament on a worldwide scale
the global structures convocation
is honored to have
one of the
foremost thinkers and leaders
in nuclear disarmament with us this
afternoon for this special panel
daniel ellsberg
is a former official of the defense and
state departments of the united states
he served in vietnam
he released as many of you know
the study of the united states
dealing with
our
decisions on getting into vietnam
the famous pentagon papers
in 1961
dan ellsberg
drafted for the kennedy administration
guidelines for the joint chiefs of
staff's
general
nuclear war plan
guidelines
he was active in the negotiations during
the cuban missile crisis and since the
end of the vietnam war
he has spent his time researching
and pursuing efforts
to achieve to curtail the nuclear arms
race to end the nuclear arms race he is
presently director of the manhattan tube
project which is the subject of this
afternoon's uh
discussion
at the
physicians for social responsibility
organization here in washington it's
with great honor to again
to see dan ellsberg again and to
introduce him to you thank you
[Applause]
ugh
thank you
it's very uh
interesting hearing that introduction
to realize that
someone who's
clearly
younger than i am but nevertheless
a substantial
responsible
adult here
has never lived in a world in which
there was not a nuclear threat
someone of my generation and i was 14
when the war ended not very old still
did grow up in a world in which there
were no nuclear weapons
the project that i'm
director of is called manhattan project
two
in recognition of the fact that it
started in 1992 which was 50 years
from one of the birth dates of the
nuclear age the beginning of the crash
project to produce a nuclear weapon that
was known as the manhattan project
manhattan district project a number of
the people who took part in that very
effort have been on my advisory board
for the last year of this work the idea
of a manhattan project 2 which has some
unhappy associations of course because
the end of the original manhattan
project
was
the destruction
of two cities and all their inhabitants
i so in a way a controversial uh
association
to bring up
but the idea of manhattan project two
is an effort of undoing so far as
possible
the work of the original manhattan
project and the other manhattan projects
the equivalents in china england france
germany uh not germany yet
um
but uh possibly some undeclared station
uh nations like india
pakistan
israel and of course russia
that work will never be totally undone
the nuclear threat
in at least the distant form will always
be with the human species the
possibility of reproducing
plutonium and highly enriched uranium or
putting together weapons and even an
alert system will always remain as a
conceptual possibility as even a
practical possibility forever
essentially uh just as
in in a very important sense the waste
products of the weapons produced so far
will from in human terms be with us
forever plutonium with its half-life of
24 000 years of toxicity
and explosive danger meaning that we'll
uh half of it will be still here in 24
000 years and another half of that 24
000 more years
essentially indefinitely for human
history
but
that doesn't mean that we have to live
with the level of threat that we and the
russians and some other nations
to a lesser degree have contrived to
create
over the last 40 years and we don't have
to live with that really any longer
with the ending of the cold war
the era of nuclear threats the era of
imminent nuclear danger the era of the
possibility of nuclear weapons exploding
on
humans quickly
without going through a prolonged
process of
degeneration of politics and the
production of weapons
that should be over and in the minds of
most americans i think and most people
in the world the threat is over
they not only think that the danger has
receded to a point where it's on the
level of other dangers
uh in the world
and that that is perhaps true
given the the enormous dangers that we
are facing in other respects in the
other cause but they're really acting as
though there were no nuclear problem
anymore as people say it has gone off
the radar screen it's no longer on the
agenda for practical purposes it's
simply not a matter of concern for most
people
that's very regrettable
for several reasons
first of all it's a simple matter of
fact the danger is still with us
the danger that characterized the
nuclear era in most people's minds for
the last 40 years above all
has receded very greatly and that is the
danger of an all-out exchange of weapons
the 10
000 weapons each of us and the former
soviet union which would essentially
destroy most life or all life in the
northern hemisphere conceivably all life
on earth through the phenomenon of
nuclear winter
that danger has certainly receded in the
short run gone down perhaps to near zero
in fact certainly not two zero
the weapons that made that threat real
still exist and although many of them
are no longer on alert a great many
thousands of them still are on alert
and the welcome change of the symbolic
change of retargeting the weapons away
from cities the weapons on alert
two as the new york times put it
delicately to wales in the sea uh as the
new targets um apparently an an attempt
to get under the skin of greenpeace uh
uh in particular
by uh emphasizing that
uh that can be reversed in a matter of
minutes literally in minutes uh you
don't even have to wait into a crisis to
decide to retarget those missiles so
that isn't that's a symbolic change
which is welcome it isn't the kind of
real change in risks and dangers that we
need in this world
the second reason why it's too bad
people have stopped thinking on the
whole about nuclear weapons is that
there is with the end of the cold war
the greatest chance to reduce the
remaining dangers that we've ever had
and i let me define what those remaining
dangers really consist of
back in 1945 the slogan was born
no more hiroshima's
the uh at the hiroshima memorial in
hiroshima
the slogan is put i think rather
delicately
the mistake
will not be repeated
i'm afraid that the chance of more
hiroshimas
has not only not disappeared it is
growing it is less it is greater now
than it was probably five years ago and
it is on the upswing
i'm distinguishing between the uh the
chance as i say of the imminent
destruction of the northern hemisphere
and something that is very much smaller
in scale
but still
horrendous
by standards and of any any standards
other than the historical destruction of
hiroshima and nagasaki and that is more
hiroshima's the destruction of
individual cities small or large in
regional conflicts around the world
more than one probably more than one
bomb at a time more than one conflict
over a period of uh years and decades
and the likelihood by the way that that
would stay entirely away from the u.s is
not very great
in such conflicts a number of which the
u.s would probably be involved or be
seen to be involved the chance of
terrorist weapons
or
adversarial weapons going off in the
united states is not small
when i say this chance is growing i'm
thinking in particular of the fact that
the very breakup of the soviet union
which ending the cold war has made
possible a solution to this problem
in the short run exacerbates it or
immediately exacerbates it
it offers the possibility that countries
that want nuclear weapons have a new way
of getting them much cheaper than before
much faster than before much easier and
that is to buy them
from agencies not probably from the
national government in russia or the
other states that still
have weapons on their territory
but uh from local factions from military
factions of various kinds in a country
where
uh terribly strapped for hard cash
in which ideological authority
relationships are breaking down
we have here a substance uh just the
plutonium and highly enriched uranium of
immensely greater value than uh than
heroin
platinum anything else you could name
as valuable as substance as there could
be and thousands
of examples of that substance actually
in the form of transportable weapons
that could be stolen lost captured in
some way diverted to countries that it
why those countries might want them i
want to get to in a moment but we have
it's very clear in the world that a
number of countries are actually defying
international opinion at this moment
north korea iraq in efforts to violate
their actual treaty commitments
not to acquire such weapons so obviously
there are more than one country in the
world that places great value on
acquiring such weapons and as i'm saying
they can follow the attack
of the earlier nuclear states and of
india and pakistan of uh producing their
own plutonium or uranium
slowly and very expensively or now
they have a much quicker way of at least
aspiring to that and that is by paying
for it uh from agents of the former
soviet union
so that threat then is a very uh
significant one
and one that we should be very concerned
about at the same time with the ending
of the cold war the chance for
international cooperation
bilaterally multilaterally under the u.n
and on and in connection with
large-scale multilateral systems like
the
uh nonproliferation treaty
and the regime of inspection with the
international atomic energy agency and
so forth
all of these things uh make possible now
with with the cooperation that's
possible with the end of the cold war
an actual effective ending of
proliferation
if we work at it
but that will take a kind of effort that
no state in the world is yet leading
is yet showing
in an adequate way
i'm happy that president clinton has
mentioned the problem of
non-proliferation as often as he has and
with as much emphasis as he has
but the last year has not shown us the
changes in u.s policy or the u.s
leadership that even would come close to
the leadership necessary to uh to end
proliferation
i'm not saying that everything that they
have failed to take any good steps in
fact i could i'm sure we will in the
discussion name a number of things i'm
happy that clinton extended the
legislative moratorium on testing of
nuclear weapons
i'm happy that he is clearly in pressing
negotiations now for a comprehensive
test ban
but i have to report unhappily after
working in this town for the last year
that clinton had to override advice
very bad advice
from his own officials
in the national security staff in the
defense department in the state
department to make both of those good
decisions which were entirely in accord
with his campaign promises
which were to seek a comprehensive test
ban
uh in contrast to that he had high
officials who were still there in fact
who gave him the incredibly bad advice
on the one hand that he should not seek
to negotiate a true comprehensive test
ban
but try to negotiate a
supposed test ban which would allow
indefinite testing at the level of a
thousand tons of tnt equivalent one
kiloton
uh equivalent
which would have been recognized by
everyone in the world close to this
subject as the negation of a
comprehensive test ban as a continuation
of u.s testing at a lower level but a
level uh quite adequate to develop
dangerous new weapons small weapons of
the kind that would be most dangerous
for use in limited nuclear wars uh and
for possible diversion to terrorists one
kiloton weapons
should be contrasted for example to the
effect on the world trade center
of about 500 pounds
of tnt
uh imagine testing at the level of 1 000
tons of tnt and imagine the effect on
world stability if we led the world in
producing such weapons and encourage
other countries to have them the perfect
terrorist weapon the effect on the world
trade center of a thousand tons would
have been significantly different on
cnn uh and by every conceivable
measurement
than 500 pounds
and yet
he was getting the advice from people in
the tradition of the recent
administrations who did not want a
comprehensive test ban
that we should insist on testing forever
at that level next he got advice that uh
that he should not uh that we should do
tests
of uh full-scale tests of nuclear
weapons immediately even while
negotiating
uh tests that the
services in the defense department said
they did not need uh they rejected the
idea of using the weapons that would
follow from their tests there was no
military justification for these and yet
uh clinton was being advised still in
his administration by people who said
for reasons that we can go into in the
discussion perhaps
that he should
test while negotiating
let me describe
he clinton didn't do that and he didn't
do that in clearly in considerable part
because he got good advice
and a little more than advice
from senators uh
who uh just described what he was
proposing in in the one kiloton taste
there's a clear violation of the
legislation that had been passed more
than a year ago
and of his campaign promises he saw a
couple of dozen editorials saying that
there should be no further tests and
that a comprehensive test ban should be
sought and he heard from the grassroots
in large part they kept him straight
that was democracy acting as it is
supposed to act
in a country which um
has
more
leeway more support for such democratic
pressure than probably any other large
country more support for free speech and
more
leeway for the legislature to direct
the
administration in various ways they
saved him that process saved president
clinton from
great mistakes
i'm emphasizing this point not to
criticize the administration
but to say that on the one hand we have
had a demonstration this year that
public pressure and the congressional
role editorial role can influence
this administration
probably more to give it credit than
president bush would have been
influenced by this that's an opportunity
for us
and on the other hand we have seen that
we need to exert that pressure and that
activism because unfortunately
we don't have an administration in in
terms of its middle level officials and
its uh bureaucracy
that is prepared to take the ball away
from us and show leadership in ending
proliferation
1995 will be the 50th anniversary
of the successful completion of the
manhattan project in in building nuclear
weapons uh
let me take the trinity test of a weapon
in july of 1945 uh as uh the
the evidence of that success rather than
the use that was made at the bomb
thereafter
it'll be the 50th anniversary then of
the trinity test the 50th anniversary of
the first and of course later of the
first use of the nuclear weapons
it will also be the year
of the renewal or not
of the non-proliferation treaty
which most nations in the world have
signed although a number including some
undeclared nuclear states have not
signed
unite the president
is very anxious that there be at that
time an indefinite renewal of the
non-proliferation treaty which is
certainly desirable
but it's not at all assured
given the policies he is still following
and even if he got that it would clearly
not be enough
to stop proliferation we need more than
that
that's obvious because iraq and north
korea had both signed the
non-proliferation treaty
and clearly that had not stopped them
from efforts to proliferate
it's obvious that we need a strengthened
regime probably not by changing the
treaty but by adding to it agreements
multilateral agreements it will make for
much stronger inspection it will stop
future korea's stop future uh iraq's
from being able to in secret to uh get
the material and to pursue
the weapon
but to do that we'll need
arrangements for inspection like that we
are pursuing in iraq right now and the
arrangements that we're pressing on
north korea which they are currently
refusing
we can't get that by war as we did in
the case of iraq with all these
countries it'll have to be by agreement
countries will have to agree
multilaterally in a global scale
to submit to the kind of inspection and
verification as i say that we are
pressing on iraq now that's a
strengthened regime that's not in the
non-proliferation treaty
they will have to cooperate in pressing
for those inspections
and perhaps in pursuing sanctions
boycotts conceivably even military
action multilaterally against countries
that persist
in violating those those restrictions
how are we going to get that degree of
international cooperation
compare this problem with the problem of
producing the bomb
which could be done unilaterally in fact
in nearly every case has been done
unilaterally
or the problem of arms control that
we've seen for the last 40 years which
we thought of as almost entirely a
bilateral problem
very difficult with not a lot to show
for it but with some success but
procedurally rather simple just two
parties to it
we're talking now about agreements that
have to be effectively co-op
collaborated in by virtually every
country in the world
obviously a more complex problem
what will make countries willing to
submit their their territory essentially
uh restrict their own sovereignty
by submitting themselves to this kind of
inspection and accepting the kinds of
constraints that they will not acquire
the weapons they will not test them they
will not produce them they will not use
them
it is difficult to imagine countries
doing that
while half a dozen states in the world
not only possess the weapons which the
others are agreeing not to acquire
but are using those weapons
testing them
building more
maintaining vast and unnecessary
arsenals
that which they spend money producing
the material for more weapons despite
the fact that they already have more
weapons than they need
it's simply impossible to imagine that
you'll get either the agreement or more
important the implementation of that
agreement
in a world that's that discriminatory
as these other countries have been
pointing out for a long time
to this date
as i'm saying the people for instance
who proposed to the president that we
should continue testing nuclear weapons
were in effect saying to him
go ahead boss
press for non-proliferation in the world
but do it under the following conditions
that we continue to test nuclear weapons
even while we're negotiating and after
we stop negotiating
say to the world you can't test
we can
clinton overruled that point
but he hasn't yet overruled a number of
others exactly similar conditions
these same bureaucrats like their
predecessors in earlier administrations
they didn't invent this policy
are saying yes we all agree
pursue non-proliferation get all those
people to agree not only not to acquire
the weapon but to observe that agreement
to be inspected to uh to bring sanctions
to bear on violators and so forth
while we tell them
you can't produce material for weapons
highly enriched uranium plutonium
we can
we accept no restriction on that and we
accept no uh no inspection we have no
arrangement for inspection as a nuclear
state of our own production of physical
material we're not producing any at the
moment
but we have not submitted to any
bilateral or multilateral restriction on
our ability our right to start producing
tomorrow if we want to
and a major reason and that means that
we haven't even pressed for a bilateral
agreement that would stop russia from
producing plutonium which it is doing
not because it needs the plutonium
but because of inertia bureaucratic
inertia basically because it's jobs over
there and in particular because some of
the uh reactors that produce the
plutonium also produce electricity
for the
local cities
now there should be a way in the modern
world to get electricity to those cities
uh in a way that does not involve adding
to the world's stockpile of plutonium
of course there is
but russia says in effect
we will stop if it is bilateral if
there's a bilateral agreement that would
involve bilateral inspection
the u.s
attitude has been under bush and reagan
and still under clinton
why should we be inspected
quote as one official in the nsc said
if russia doesn't want to be a
superpower that doesn't mean we're not a
superpower
and superpowers don't let themselves be
inspected by foreigners crawling over
there
our unwillingness to be inspected has
meant we have made no effort
to inspect
the implementation
of the
unilateral undertakings that russia has
taken to dismantle its warheads
we're have we have no measure of
international inspection and have not
tried to get any of them
which is clearly not in our good or the
russians good or anyone else because it
opens the door to diversion of that
material in a situation where there's
enormous incentives and opportunities
for them to do it this is
extraordinarily short-sighted behavior
on our part
to fail to try and if we tried we can
almost surely get it to try
to get a bilateral or multilateral
arrangement for international inspection
on both sides of the dismantlement of
warheads weapons there is no provision
for that at the moment
okay
again we're telling the rest of the
world still
you can't
threaten nuclear weapons we're against
that that's bad but we can
uh you can't produce the material as i
said you don't here's another one you
don't need any weapons
we need
thousands of weapons
the world war the cold war is over
uh we've made agreements for great
reductions of the nuclear stockpiles on
both sides but reductions that would
leave each side with literally thousands
of thermonuclear weapons
incidentally
uh president bush
to his credit achieved a significant
reduction in start two
um
over a year ago
to reduce both sides to this very high
level of 3500 but
amazingly little attention was drawn to
the fact that president yeltsin at that
time had said that he preferred a level
of on both sides
of 2000 warheads
or 2500
we use president bush set secretary of
defense baker secretary of state baker
to use his great negotiating skills to
bargain yeltsin up
from 2000 to a mutual level of 3 500.
now how it could be in our interest for
the russians to have or be challenged to
have 3 500 weapons instead of the 2000
that they proposed
is hard to explain
of course the explanation has to do with
the fact that our military uh preferred
themselves to have 3500 level and were
willing to pay the price if they even
thought of it as a price that the
russians too would have 3 500 weapons
aimed at us or the whales but could be
re-aimed at us very quickly
again incredibly short-sighted uh
thinking
their reasons for doing this and if they
had reasons were not good reasons and
they were not challenged adequately
either by congress or the public in
general
we can really conceive of getting the
kind of
un-sponsored
multilateral international cooperation
with a non-proliferation regime only
when all countries and above all
the nuclear states and above all the
leading nuclear state the us and and
russia
abide by the same restrictions that we
are asking of the other countries
in the absence of that it's just
inconceivable that we will get this
cooperation
the rule in other words has to be
nobody tests
nobody produces nuclear materials
for
weapons or indeed for civil uses the
economics of civil uses are not worth
the risk of diversion to weapons program
nobody threatens nuclear weapons
first nobody threatens to initiate
nuclear weapons for any purposes
and the superpowers
current super and the other nuclear
states all produce all
proceed with a policy of deep reductions
far below what has yet been agreed to in
start two
probably certainly by 1995 probably by
the end of this century there will still
remain a distinction between nuclear
states and non-nuclear states
which will put a pressure on some of
those non-nuclear states to join that
club but the pressure doesn't have to be
that the nuclear states retain the kind
of privileges dangerous privileges of
threatening uh producing and of holding
thousands of weapons that they now do
and press the discrimination that far
i want to make uh
finally i'm almost at the end here and
then i want to have discussion but i
want to focus on one aspect of that in
particular
that program and that is the continued
willingness or insistence of the u.s on
its right to threaten
the first use of nuclear weapons
so-called first use threats
that was always the heart of our nato
policy the continuing regular threat to
initiate nuclear war in the event
of a
non-nuclear attack a conventional attack
by the large forces of the warsaw pact
the warsaw pact no longer exists the
former soviet union no longer exists
that threat that supposedly justified
the threat to initiate nuclear war in
response has disappeared
there is no significant rationale for
any remaining threat by the u.s to
initiate nuclear war and yet we have
maintained that right
we've actually gone further
we've used nuclear weapons
more than a dozen times since
nagasaki secretly mostly
we've used them the way you use a gun
when you point it at someone's head in a
confrontation
whether or not you pull the trigger
you're using the gun
and if you get your way
whether you're a criminal or a policeman
or whichever side of this confrontation
you're on if you get your way without
pulling the trigger that's the best use
of the gun that's why you bought it
we've used nuclear weapons in that way
in intense crises more than a dozen
times
a few other countries have done the same
ashay has done it a few times no one as
much as we have
in other words we've set a precedent
over 40 years for what pakistan did just
three years ago
with its undeclared nuclear arsenal
not
seymour hirsch
won a couple of pulitzer prizes for
investigative reporting
did a job on that crisis a year ago in
the new yorker
and asserted on the basis of high-level
uh intelligence sources some of whom he
named
uh one being robert gates later head of
the cia
that
uh pakistan in the course of a crisis
with india over kashmir
had actually
taken its weapons out of storage
assembled them taken them out of storage
and hung them on fighter planes ready to
go against india in ways that were be
would be known to india as as they were
known to us
communications intelligence
and other means and for photographic
needs
that was a use of the weapon
it was a use by the way not only against
india
but against us
because it got us into that crisis in a
way we wouldn't have gotten otherwise
gates himself was pulled out of cia
though this wasn't his great area but as
an authority as a representative of the
president he was sent immediately to
pakistan and india to negotiate that
crisis
something and in the favor of pakistan
basically something pakistan undoubtedly
does feel they would not have gotten
without having that weapon and the
ability to choose in other words it was
pointed and affected us in a way if you
don't help us if you don't take our part
if you don't involve yourself we might
use this nuclear weapon because we would
then have to
a wonderful example to set to ukraine
that has the same kind of incentive
uh to have to keep those weapons
whatever they agree today they will be
confronted with the temptation month
after month after month
will we get visits from a baker will we
get visits from strobe talbot if we the
day after we really give up those
weapons for the last time if we get into
confrontation with russia
they can't want to use nuclear weapons
very quickly it would be suicidal
they could very well want nuclear
weapons to point at russia
because that would bring the u.s rushing
into that crisis very quickly in a way
to say don't make ukraine feel they have
to do this settle this one give them
what they want
that's not an unreasonable that's not a
crazy belief that those nuclear weapons
would be valuable to them which may
explain why that
rada uh the parliament over there is so
reluctant
to let go of them
that's the kind of incentive we have to
overweigh some way if we're to reduce
the incidence of weapons in the world
and the likelihood that they'll go off
because the trouble is that the more
people
who point those weapons in more crises
the more the likelihood that some of the
triggers will be pulled eventually
that's obvious to everybody if you do it
that's the reason to my knowledge in my
mind the greatest of dangers
in in likelihood
is not these weapons getting into the
hands of certifiably insane people
leaders there aren't too many of them in
the world although
jaronovsky has frankly a kind of
recklessness to him that is indeed very
very worrisome
but
in general that's not the problem
the problem i see is simply that those
weapons will get in the hands of leaders
in india in pakistan in ukraine in
iraq iran whatever
that are not less reckless than our own
leaders who have been willing to point
those weapons in the past who are not
crazier but not more prudent
than we who have set the example
how good a position were we to tell
pakistan that this was an a bad
precedent to set
in that time it was dangerous
not only had we been setting the same
precedent for 40 years later that same
year in 1990 the u.s chose to use its
nuclear weapons
in the same way
when president bush was asked when
secretary of defense cheney when vice
president quayle was asked separately in
press conferences do you rule out the
use of nuclear weapons
against saddam hussein in the gulf
confrontation
the first use
they could have said
yes we rule it out
each of them said no
we don't rule it out
they used the weapon
that was a use of the weapon that was
pointing the gun
and many people have now prided
themselves with understandably on the
fact that it was a successful use
saddam did not use chemical warfare
against us when he could have he may in
fact have been deterred by the thought
that if he did that we might pull the
trigger on that weapon or if we didn't
the israelis would with ours with our
tolerance
so it may have worked very good
but we really do have to ask whether
there wasn't some other way to achieve
that that deterrence
because the cost of doing it that way
was to set a
vivid example
for the pakistan for saddam himself for
the rest of the world
both as to why they needed nuclear
weapons because they might face such
threats from the u.s
and how they could use those weapons if
they got into a situation
if they faced their own saddam hussein
as the indian chief of staff was quoted
as saying after the crisis the lesson he
drive from the gulf war was
don't confront the u.s without nuclear
weapons
not necessarily not a very wise lesson
but not a good lesson from our point of
view for people to be drawing and uh by
the way it isn't just an issue of
confronting the us it's confronting
other countries where they might have to
make the same threats therefore
it seems of urgent importance that we
give up a threat that no longer has any
rationale any legitimacy to the extent
that it did during the cold war
and encourage the states of the world by
every means we can to commit themselves
multilaterally
never to be the first to use nuclear
weapons we certainly cannot get that new
ground rule unless we submit to
ourselves
obviously verbal declarations are not
enough
but along with those commitments you
would need also to change the deployment
of nuclear weapons by us i want to give
bush credit on that score
without intending this particular effect
by taking nuclear weapons unilaterally
off u.s ships
and encouraging the russians to take
them off their ships which they did
he was moving very significantly to
making concrete
the commitment that we would not
initiate nuclear weapon warfare in local
uh
confrontation
north korea is under less threat than
they used to be thanks to that we took
bush took the weapons out of korea south
korea took the weapons off the ships
nearby
that was in the direction of giving
north korea the assurance they have said
they wanted
that if they are not to have nuclear
weapons they should not be under the
threat of being attacked with nuclear
weapons
still of course the weapons can be
returned quickly in fact two senators
have recently suggested very unwisely
that we should return them to south
korea
that is not the way to get north korea
to decide it can live without nuclear
weapons
or implement the treatment
and
they can be returned we i have not yet
told korea north korea in simple flat
terms we will not initiate nuclear war
against you initiated under any
circumstances
and yet we're trying to get them to live
up to their agreements to forego nuclear
weapons without the assurance
that they won't have nuclear weapons
used against them that's the hard way to
get nonproliferation
it's the way that is bound to fail
there may be no guaranteed way to keep
these countries from getting it but that
is not the way there are some necessary
conditions
the american public i think uh and i'm
going to call early in the discussion
period on a man here who has conducted a
very valuable series of uh let's let's
wait a moment alan if we could and get a
couple questions but i want to have the
chance to have him tell about a poll
that was done recently
which did in fact show that the american
people understood the point i'm just
making about the usefulness in
particular both of ending testing
multilaterally and of ending first use
threats in a way as i say unfortunately
that clinton's uh
officials
with the exception of hazel o'leary
who has been uh from my point of view on
the right side of these issues in the
administration but with that exception
uh they haven't gotten the word
but as they've there's a long statement
in washington in this town and on the
hill people in congress may not see the
light but they'll feel the heat
they did feel the heat on testing
if we generate heat on these other
things that are needed
the ending the production of fissionable
materials ending first use threats
pursuing further
commitments to reduce our forces far
below
start to there is every reason to
believe that clinton will get that
message as he did on testing there is
every reason to believe that the
russians will join us on this as they
we could not have counted on 10 years
ago but now we can
now
now before they get a new leadership
that might not be as willing to agree so
that the whole process is really quite
urgent and the necessity of doing all
this
uh before the non-proliferation treaty
comes up for review in early 1995 is
again very urgent
so in short uh i would say with that
non-proliferation treaty conference
coming up in uh spring of 1995 we can't
even wait for the 50th anniversary of
the trinity test this
july
to get a lot of these commitments we
have to move on them this year
we can do it and that is what we must do
thank you
[Applause]
let me take a couple questions and then
i just to get started here and then i
would like to turn to alan kay to
comment on this poll yes
the trident submarines no longer
armed with those
missiles that they're making in
texas el paso and used a cart across the
country they're not in on the tridents
anymore no
on the contrary
those not only are those missiles and
warheads still on the trident
not only are they still
un
not subject it is still the case that
they are not subject to any physical
arrangement which would keep them from
firing keep the pre the uh commander of
that submarine from firing those
missiles on his own belief that this was
the appropriate thing to do uh against
the wishes of the president that remains
true the navy has still successfully
warding off
uh physical uh control of those weapons
that had the air force and the army did
submit to on their uh and not only is
that the case but the um
uh they were still in the budget and in
the physical uh production process
new trident submarines new trident
missiles and new warheads for those
missiles this is any among other things
aside from the danger of it and the
effect on arms control an incredible
waste of money uh at a time when the
administration is understandably crying
uh poor man about its uh
from human inaudib but there is money in
the budget for sea world submarines to
attack russian submarines that are now
in port
no longer being deployed
trident submarines that have no con that
whose missiles have no conceivable
justification under the arms control
agreed a treatments we've already signed
or any other uh strategic justification
in short the inertia of this process is
is going on to a degree that's extremely
dismaying
what has changed is the or is about to
change is the immediate targeting at all
times of those weapons on
russian city since russia is interested
in being part of nato as are its other
former allies in the warsaw pact uh the
idea of instant readiness to incinerate
the people of all of their cities
uh no longer seems as urgent to both
sides
so they're they're going to a computer
they're going to an arrangement where it
would take probably five to ten minutes
to retarget the inhabitants of those
cities
um
that's a quite minor symbolic change
yeah let
you mentioned the non-proliferation
treaty and that uh we are proposing
indefinite renewal
but this has created what they call the
nuclear apartheid where with the
those who have and those who don't
and you're proposing revisions to it
uh why don't we suggest uh not renewing
it until we get the revisions
who is the we by the way uh that you're
thinking of in that you mentioned that
we are going to we ask we the united
states is asking for indefinite renewal
this is a very interesting question
could i just ask who you are
representing or what from what point of
view you're asking that question i'm
representing myself i'm from the
methodist church in in southern
california and we've been interested in
uh nuclear
uh problems in fact our bishops
have put out a pastoral letter on the in
defense of creation
but so the nuclear question the nuclear
threat
okay that's what didn't mean to
challenge you because quite the contrary
that's a very good question
uh the case for
saying that the the treaty really should
not be renewed indefinitely
um until
uh not only uh the nuclear states begin
to live up to the uh obligations they've
already
assumed but until they really assume
further obligations that level this
playing field that bring them under the
same restraints as other countries and
that that prospect of not renewing the
treaty is the only thing that puts
pressure on the nuclear states
this is the argument that's made
to begin obeying their own obligations
and to begin willing to show leadership
and moving forward and that's a very
it's a very strong tactical argument
basically
um
the
uh the other the extension of that is
that if everybody does simply and
definitely extend without
these changes in policy by the nuclear
states
what will make them at last begin to
comply you know and they'll forget about
the problem that is it's a serious issue
uh and i've i've been in many
discussions in washington on that i've
been persuaded
that along with a lot of other people in
these discussions but i i could be
unpersuaded in further argument i
suppose because it really is a difficult
question
that
it is important to try to get indefinite
extension
uh in 1995
uh
that the alternative of a of a rare
short-term extension looking towards
it's argued
would be a signal to the rest of the
world that this thing is not going to be
indefinitely extended the race is about
to be on
you know everybody's going to do it
remember the the behavior
of most states considering this treaty
that they're most concerned about is in
most cases not that of the current
nuclear states or the current nuclear
superpowers anyway it's the possible
behavior of their neighbors
their neighbors and their possible
adversaries who might acquire these
weapons
uh even if the nuclear states continued
blatantly to ignore their obligations
which they have done so far a lot of
countries remain anxious to see that
treaty remain and that's because they
remain anxious to to have a commitment
by their neighbors and their adversaries
that they won't get nuclear weapons
and that would remain whatever the
nuclear states do up to a point
uh so if on the other hand they failed
to renew this thing uh now the one time
it's up for renewal uh i i find the
argument fairly strong that people will
say
my neighbor is gonna get this thing
pretty soon i better start right now
um
as i say this i'm not trying to this is
not the last word on the subject but i i
could easily make the case on the other
side as perhaps you're waiting to do
there i won't call on you to do it right
now there is a case to be made on the
other side but
and nor by the way i don't think it
would be the end of the game or the or
terrible tragedy necessarily
if uh other countries
did do what they have threatened to do
and that is in 1995 if the u.s and
russia and the other states have not
made progress in restraining themselves
along with others
these states have said we simply won't
sign indefinitely we'll wait
well the there would still be a lot to
do then and that wouldn't necessarily be
a bad situation but i personally am
focusing right now on the importance of
getting the us to do them and and russia
and the other nuclear states which will
i think follow our example considerably
uh to do the things
that will encourage everyone to sign you
know indefinitely a a little over a year
from now i think that is the immediate
immediate problem
if the us totally fails to do that then
let's look at this again uh as to what
it's good to do on the way of the treaty
tactically a year from now but right now
i think it's terribly important and i'll
give you one specific example where that
cuts
following the legislation of last year
which under bush
which compromised on a date for the
comprehensive test ban of 1996
facing a bush administration that didn't
want a test van ever
so they took a rather long term away
1996 as the deadline unfortunately
that's a year after the
non-proliferation treaty a conference
clinton has unfortunately continued to
talk about 1996
or his his officials have i'm not sure
he's uttered that deadline but a lot of
his officials say we're trying to get
this by 1996. that's just not good
enough
they have to be told as a lot of
editorials have said already we need
that treaty signed by 1994 or early 1995
we must go into the non-proliferation
treaty showing that it'll last after 30
and 40 years
at last we have met our commitment
to end the testing of nuclear weapons
and not put that off for another year
and ask for trust on that issue so he
needs pressure on that and that's what
i'm saying
if if there's no response to that if
we're nowhere on the comprehensive test
ban if we're still threatening first use
and so forth
then we have to recalculate this all a
year from now but now let's say let's
get the states into compliance let me
ask get one last question and then i'm
going to ask allen k to speak
yes
can you bring us up to date on present
status of manhattan project 2 and plans
for its future
well i've told you pretty much what
manhattan project 2 is in the sense of
an agenda the idea by the way of it was
to try to bring the same urgency
and priority to ending the nuclear era
that the u.s
gave to the original two and a half year
project to start the nuclear era
i can't say that's been fully achieved
in the clinton administration obviously
i wish it had in other words i wish that
the clinton administration had simply
adopted the agenda of manhattan project
2 and said that's our program
and uh which i think they should have
done been perfectly reasonable for them
to do it
i don't think by the way they would have
been subject to much criticism or
opposition if if they had i don't see a
large constituency certainly in the
public but even in congress that's
pressing them uh in the inert policies
that they're actually following i think
they could change them
but they're they haven't changed yet
where the project where my project
however is has
some basis for hope
is that the agenda that we
formulated over the last year as a
useful package of things that i've
described has been adopted by a very
broad coalition of groups and
individuals and organizations in the
country in this country
uh there is a campaign for the
non-proliferation treaty
right now
uh
which uh uh was launched just a month
ago
uh with uh funding for an executive
director
funding we didn't have in my narrower
project uh and which is going to be
pursuing press education pressure on the
administration lobbying and grassroots
effort to achieve essentially all of
these things it's i can give you an
address or a phone number if you want
further information from them it's uh
housed at the stimson center in
washington
and um it's it is i'm got getting
underway in a very gratifying way i'm
part of that i'm part of the steering
committee on that but there are about 30
groups
of all kinds including very important
arms control groups such as the arms
control association
the center for defense information the
national resources defense council
center for
a number of others about 30.
so the federation american scientists
have agreed on this this approach
so that's looking good could i ask alan
to talk a little about this poll because
that bears on what i've been saying
about the american public's attitude
and introduce yourself if you're sure
don't think uh by the way let me just
see hands how many people right now are
sitting on questions that they want to
ask
quite a few okay you have to keep i'll
have to keep that in mind and alan we
have to be out of here in half an hour
so i think we can address those
questions and i'll ask you to be greek
but i'm anxious to hear that okay um
this was a brief survey that was
commissioned by the campaign uh for
non-proliferation
and my own
yes i'm about to
uh my role um was to help them do that
i'm the president of the americans talk
issues foundation which is a non-profit
organization
that uses small balanced teams of
polling and issue experts to design and
conduct
large sample telephone surveys of what
the american people want for policy and
legislation
and that's different from what the media
polls we're all familiar with that
does do
because those balanced teams
like currently they
include stan greenberg who's president
clinton's pollster
and fred steeper who was george bush's
pollsters the really top-flight people
they're needed to make sure that we
under we test the bias of questions it
is quite possible to move people
to answer questions in ways that
are very confusing if you're not
a
student of polling and most people of
course aren't
so uh we do we're able to get go in
depth into
what people want
and
uh you have
in the late 80s we did a number of
surveys on nuclear issues
uh which confirm
that there is a kind of
collective wisdom to the american people
on these issues
that might surprise you
tested then and then also more recently
this is
the desire that americans by 2 1
is that ultimately all
nations get rid of all nuclear weapons
as opposed to only a few nations
including the u.s have a small number
there's also support
for a wide range of arms control
agreements
and i'll just comment now on the on the
most recent changes that come out of
this survey
when we asked
do you think we should or should not try
to get the russians to agree to balance
reductions below the 3 500 which is the
current threshold 84 percent said we
should try to do that
six seven years ago you would have had
to include in the wording
that the that it uh be verifiable
and balanced
and there's a much stronger
understanding of the need and
the value of this kind of poll another
question is
let's talk about preventing the spread
of nuclear weapons the non-proliferation
treaty is a global agreement that does
that it's up to renewal in april
of 95. the united states wants to make
it permanent some nations say they would
be easier to do so
to do that if the nuclear test ban was
agreed to by 1995
we may miss that date because the
bureaucracies are moving slowly and
something a test ban is not that
important
80
then agree that the president should
push to get a nuclear test plan approved
by 1995.
i think i'm going to skip here there's
quite a few questions but it's really
too detailed
yes
on the no first use
the very distinction
that dan ellsberg made is a thing that
got us a majority in favor of no first
use for the
first time a a larger majority than
you'd ever seen before sometimes there
were and that is that the alternative to
no first use is is not that
we threaten to use
but that we
work together
with other nations so that we all are in
favor of no first use when that is the
alternative
uh then the american people
and about
64
agree with that and
okay we have a lot of questions i will
do my best
to uh against my normal instincts uh to
try to give short answers so we can deal
with a lot of these questions i'm afraid
i i often give in to the temptation to
go on at length go ahead
about 10 years ago you had reported
publicly that there were about 19 known
threats direct threats by the united
states to use nuclear weapons and i
don't mean just the indirect threats of
not uh refusing to make a no first use
pledge but correct
what is the current figure
well that's a good question i haven't uh
i did we keep finding out about
threats that were kept secret from the
u.s uses of the weapons that were kept
secret from the u.s public though of
course not from the people threatened at
the time uh for example uh after i gave
that compilation of some 19 or so cases
uh we learned with remarkably little
concern or interest in the public that
in the last days of the carter
administration there was a crisis
over iran a soviet threat to iran
that led to
a determination by carter officials that
we would have to be prepared to use
nuclear weapons if they went
non-nuclearly into iran and some of the
high officials were reported as saying
that they felt this was the most intense
crisis since the cuban missile crisis
now that was kept secret from the public
during the election campaign of 1990
but uh in 1980
but
uh not secret from the russians it was
made clear that but drew very little
attention since then but just leaping up
to the present of i've already mentioned
the uh the gulf case uh in which by the
way the u.s was not the only one to give
the answer that they did not rule out
the use of nuclear weapons
there were weapons in the area
reportedly belonging to several nuclear
states certainly israel but possibly
britain and france also had nuclear
weapons in that area none of which it's
interesting to notice deterred iraqi
aggression
against kuwait
may have helped against chemical warfare
but as i say at the cost of a very
serious precedent
so the list in short there would be
probably half a dozen more cases that i
would add to that and they're still
going on and as i've said we have begun
to see cases now in the third world
against each other as in the case of
pakistan against iran
uh against india i'm sorry
yeah
yeah um regarding his vision for the u.n
john kennedy stated the absolute power
to destroy all nations must be put into
the absolute power of all nations um and
your view is it desirable and or
feasible to transfer nuclear arms to a
restructured united nations
uh
that certainly the
is not going to happen obviously in the
short run at this moment the american
people seem to be end in
seem to be extremely resistant to the
idea even of putting american troops
under u.n control and even in an
operation at which the u.s
in principle approves but they feel that
must be under total command of the u.s
the idea then that we're anywhere
within even seeing distance or imagining
distance of of giving control of nuclear
weapons to the u.n is is clearly a
higher order of impossibility than even
i usually deal with
nearly everything i try to do is
impossible but some things are more
impossible than others
and um
the um
uh fortunately their miracles do happen
uh in a good way but it can also be true
in a bad way
if you would look far in the future
and ask this question
can we conceive of um
these nuclear states i'm sorry of states
of the world
foregoing indefinitely acquiring nuclear
weapons
despite the fact that some states
persist indefinitely in maintaining
these weapons
an indefinite can there be an end to
proliferation
while there remain two classes of
nations those who maintain nuclear
weapons and those who do not
it's hard to believe that we can end
proliferation in the long run under
those conditions so we have to think
very hard of solving what is a very hard
problem a very hard problem even to
imagine a solution to and that is how do
we end a situation in which states that
now control nuclear weapons somehow
forego at least control of those weapons
or
now some people have begun to think
about that
and one can think of various stages of
that effect which begin to look possible
again not in the short really short run
but in a longer run not too long around
specifically
even in the short run we could and
should go beyond the retargeting that
yeltsin and and uh clinton have just
agreed to
uh to actually taking these weapons off
alert not only should we not be
instantly
ready to use them against each other
we should not be instantly ready to use
them against whales or really anyone
there is no need for it it's dangerous
it leads to the possibility for an
authorized action
for false alarms of various kinds it's a
kind of danger and a precedent the world
should not be setting that means we
could take those weapons on both sides
under inspection
totally off alert
and there are various stages of doing
that you can take the warheads off
missiles and that should be done as a
matter of fact
uh you can take the you can go further
to take the bombs away from the planes
we've moved in that direction but you
could go further you could take all
tactical weapons out of europe for
example on they're not in europe uh any
longer but on the russian side but they
are on the u.s side it should be very
much our interest to get tactical
weapons out of that which are the
easiest to transport steal lose whatever
use in civil war out of the hands of
russian military that's an urgent need
it's not going to happen as long as the
u.s maintains its deployment so you
could seek to end the deployment of
those tactical weapons on both sides you
could put them under international
monitoring control say we eliminate
tactical nuclear weapons because we're
not going to initiate nuclear war under
any circumstances let's say that's
urgent for a number of reasons
next you can talk about you can think of
dismantling those weapons to some degree
separating their various components in
various cases none of this at this time
would involve any risk to u.s security
we have no need in the world today
for a fast reaction under any
circumstances
even even though
we do retain or even so long as we do
retain some ability to retaliate for
determined purposes
we don't have to have that ability to
retaliate immediately
and we can thus move to get all the
weapons off alert under control and the
next phase would be under international
monitoring and international control
those are stages that in principle could
be done fairly fast with cooperation
uh the last part would be
close to what you said that in the end
no nation really has national control of
those things that there is an
international monitoring and control of
a vastly reduced
number of nuclear weapons in the world
and we can we can approach that fairly
quickly
so uh
in short i think you have pointed to a
real possibility and a necessity for the
long run
uh although it's not a short run option
didn't the inf treaty take all tactical
nuclear weapons out of europe no the inf
treaty by the i stands for intermediate
range nuclear weapons those are
basically the pershings and cruise
missiles of of ranges of some 1500
kilometers or more
it didn't or more it did it didn't
affect at all the now the same treaty
did allow for some somewhat shorter
range missiles to go medium range the
russians said if intermediate range how
about the next level down the 900
kilometer and 600 kilometers so forth
they did go down in a good direction but
the end of that was that they left
thousands of tactical nuclear weapons on
both sides in europe then unilaterally
i'm sorry then unilaterally uh bush and
i want to give him credit for this
did remove most of those weapons from
europe and from ships and gorbachev
followed suit
again credibly so that was a very good
move but the then with the breakup of
the warsaw pact
all the russian weapons were removed
from
eastern europe
like east germany
um and uh and even from the then from
the parts of the soviet union that after
the breakup so there are no tactical
weapons in uh ukraine for example they
have strategic weapons but not tactical
no tactical weapons in the other states
of the outside russia
but russia is a very big place
and they there are no current
restrictions on ground-based tactical
weapons existing in or numbers of them
in russia
it's very much in the world's interest
that those weapons not only be
taken out of deployment
but disassembled and under international
inspection i don't have to explain why
are we moving to do that
no
because we really so far have not tried
to uh we don't want to restrain our own
deployment that's not a good reason
so there's a lot left to do
oh
well the they range from uh they used to
have some very short range called a davy
crockett a very small one with a range
of a few miles but no
you can't detonate
if it was a very small warhead
but uh supposedly so uh you mean it
would endanger the troops themselves
small nuclear detonation but some are
they're all very large but the so-called
tactical weapons they used to say
averaged the size of the hiroshima
weapon
uh
the however they went much lower
uh some of them like the davy crockett
were very much lower than that
uh and it's tactical is defined in large
part by the range but that's the range
of the delivery vehicle a plane
obviously can deliver anything from you
know a mile to 100 miles to 200 miles
depending on 500 miles depending on the
range of the plane cruise missiles again
there are some cruise missiles that have
fairly short range
a lot of those have been removed from
deployment but on your comment on the
smallness of these things
uh and uh let me
let me make
the following comment
and violating my
promise give only short answers but i
think it is worth bringing this up
because people have lost track of the
range of what we're talking
it's often said that a test ban
achieves nothing because you can make
hiroshima type weapons without testing
them which is true
a test ban in itself will not stop other
countries from acquiring
small relatively small
uh hiroshima type weapons we didn't test
our own hiroshima weapon we tested the
nagasaki one which was a different
design
we knew the hiroshima would work
india and pakistan and israel have
acquired nuclear weapons without
bothering to test them presumably this
smaller sign
but the thermonuclear weapon which came
along about 10 years later after the
hiroshima nagasaki one
does need to be tested it's not only
larger but it's much more complex very
hard to know unless someone gives you
the calculations which can happen
to know whether it will work without
testing it a test ban would keep india
and pakistan
from moving
to thermonuclear weapons h-bombs
from the fission weapons now the a-bombs
that they now have
does that matter
and i want to a lot of people would i'm
not going to take the time but i would
guess if i asked for how many people
here could really even in this audience
would know the difference
between an a-bomb and an h-bomb
experience has taught me that even in
very concerned groups of activists
people have forgotten what they probably
once knew about that difference
the best way to that i know to to make
the point
of what that difference is
keeping in mind that virtually all of
the strategic weapons that we point at
the whales now but that we have pointed
at russia and russia has pointed out 10
000 on each side these are all h-bombs
thermonuclear weapons fusion weapons
ten thousand of each and a lot of the
tactical are also each of them
an h-bomb
is a bomb that requires
a nagasaki type a bomb
for a trigger
to detonate
any one of the ten thousand
the twenty thousand altogether strategic
h bombs
requires a nagasaki bomb as its
detonating cap
and when you look at when i talk about
hiroshima's more hiroshima's as a
prospect you've all seen pictures of
hiroshima
and of nagasaki
you should reflect on the fact that what
you're looking at is the effect on a
city
of dropping on it exploding on it
the percussion cap
of a modern thermonuclear weapon
of which some
over 20 000 exist in the world today we
do not have 20 000 cities in the world
or anything close to it
that's the difference
bad as it is for india and pakistan to
have a few mostly disassembled fission
weapons
in their arsenals and it is bad for the
world as a precedent and it's a
possibility
it is worth keeping them
from increasing the explosive factor of
their weapons by a factor of one
thousand
which they would have done if president
clinton had followed the advice
of his advisors
uh last spring
and had proposed and announced to the
world that the u.s was going to test
indefinitely
at a thousand tons equivalent that's an
invitation to india and pakistan to say
well we can we can live with that we can
test with that
and uh they wouldn't have to limit
themselves to a thousand tons and they
would have moved to h-bombs from that
that is worth avoiding
okay now i will see if i can keep my
promise to make the quest answer shorter
yes
please
yeah um
two questions did the polls show any
difference between
men and women as regards the answer and
um
that's a good yes there is a difference
women
are more fearful
of
nuclear weapon
uh
and also more willing to
uh
re use them
to
defend us unfortunately so it is a
reverse effect a small reverse effect
if you give me a moment i can pull out
some numbers but
um
it's contrary to what you might have
expected the other very brief question
is
i heard professor gail grace say a few
years ago at a conference when gorbachev
was in power he said nothing gives me
more glee than to go to washington and
see the
discomfort
this computer of the
generals and other high officials who
built up all their egos
on having an enemy
now i think nothing gives me more worry
what is happening to the psyches of all
these people
who have
fix their minds
and emotions on this situation you've
described i mean hordes of psychologists
should be pouring into the
american military to handle this
well several years ago with the
beginning of glasgow's and perestroik
onto glasgow one of gorbachev's advisors
uh
arbatov
said made the threat the warning we are
going to do something very serious to
you we are going to deprive you of an
enemy and when on on uh in december
of uh
1986 i believe it was
um
no it was later 88 the thing i'm
thinking of at a u.n speech gorbachev
actually announced that he was
unilaterally
removing the tanks from
5000 tanks from east germany
the tanks which had been by their
blitzkrieg capability the justification
for our first use nuclear threats for
all those years and he was removing them
back
uh that happened to be on december 7th
1988 and people in the pentagon
did observe that it was worse than pearl
harbor that
they had suddenly destroyed the
rationale
for our our deployments
but uh a a peculiar and and unhappy
phenomenon has appeared which is really
suggested by your first question
we have a new president
with
focus on domestic needs
who needs desperately a redirection
of the
government spending that has been
addressed so long to arm sales but above
all to military needs a redirection to
real needs that have now become
intolerable and you know urgent
in our inner cities in the environment
and pollution in the need for
infrastructure and so forth he needs
that money
and yet he is not proposing
to cut the defense budget
despite the lack of an enemy
uh it has proven possible and he's not
doing that alone
when he said in his state of the union
message i was really quite appalled by
this and by the way i i was quite
impressed by much of the message both
his delivery and a lot of the message i
was i was very happy with
but when i heard him say
do not cut my defense budget below what
i have allowed that would hurt our
national security
i was not only appalled at the untruth
of that comment that it could hurt our
national security to make large
discriminating cuts in that defense
budget but i was appalled at the fact
that both sides of the aisle both
parties leaped to their feet and
applauded that statement so he clearly
has support for that think of what he's
saying
at a time when he the whole the issue of
the day is where he can find money for
his health plan and for all the other
needs that he's cutting
the defense budget he is defending is a
defense budget with money in it for
seawolf submarines for tridents for more
for more missiles when we're promising
to cut the missiles for
more um
aircraft carriers at a time when we have
lost these enemies last point uh that my
wife brought to my attention recently uh
actually
she showed me a chart
from the uh from a committee a coalition
for new priorities
establishing uh taking into account the
fact that as people say well we haven't
lost all our enemies
there are still uh
bad bad guys in the world there are
still threats regional threats there is
syria there is libya there is iraq there
etc
the threats have multiplied as the
pentagon likes to say there are more of
them used to have just one now it's
gotten very complicated
and
she showed me a chart
adding up the defense budgets of all of
these countries
if you add up the defense budget
of
syria
libya
iraq
north korea north vietnam and cuba
and iran
the seven countries there
they add up to a little less than 10
of american military spending
remember that for 40 years we faced an
opponent that spent as much as we did
they could afford it less they went
bankrupt first
on that
and having lost them they have not been
replaced
by some comparable capability even when
you add up the whole world
of that possibility and despite the fact
that all of those countries that are
that uh conflict with our human rights
attitudes and and are and our regional
threats to some extent you add up to the
fact that they are spending less than 10
percent of what president clinton is
proposing to fund this here that's
obviously a vast
waste of resources that we cannot afford
at this point
yeah
uh
how possible is it for uh someone to
devise and and put in place a nuclear
bomb as
as was done in the trade center uh
could a nuclear bomb easily be put into
some a building like that
uh by you know various a group
well that's uh that could be answered in
various ways the
the bomb
a bomb
uh
small enough uh to be uh there it's very
possible nowadays to have a bomb that
would uh be vastly more powerful than
the one that destroyed the world trade
center said that was 500
yes i'm seeing a nuclear bomb uh in
other words with the the uh
you wouldn't need the car that was
needed for that 500 pounds of explosives
to transport it wouldn't the car would
not be filled by a nuclear weapon its
trunk
would scarcely be filled by a nuclear
weapon that would be let us say
a thousand times
well yeah could be a thousand times more
powerful than that but it wouldn't have
to be a thousand times
ten times twenty times a hundred times
that would be fairly easy now
in physical terms then quite easy uh can
you get something like that into the
country uh ask yourself how many tons of
cocaine and
marijuana and whatnot get into this
country despite our efforts to interdict
it and the answer is very simply yes
uh they're having some effort yes you
could get a bomb like that into this
country either disassembled or assembled
and of course we're facing in the world
today the possibility of quite
sophisticated which is to say
high-yield low-size
weapons from the former soviet union as
a possibility but it doesn't have to be
that that sophisticated
and uh there is by the way one other
little uh problem and that's the problem
of a non-nuclear attack
on a nuclear reactor
those nuclear reactors all over the
world in our country europe everywhere
russia
are in effect in effect
land mines that have been it's as if
they had been emplaced by adversaries in
advance of any conflict and they can be
triggered fairly easily by a non-nuclear
attack
of various kinds that's one of the great
worries of south korea
if we pressed too hard on north korea
and we have really a right to do that
uh internationally in view of their
violation of the non-proliferation
treaty but if we moved too fast
uh on on north korea to the point where
they were tempted to retaliate
in a crazy suicidal mood
uh one of the first things they would
almost surely do is attack with
conventional means the reactors uh near
the border which would simply wipe out
most of the northern part of south
vietnam have immense uh problems i'm
happy to see that uh in the face of
pressure from the chinese and the
japanese and koreans all of which and
south koreans not to do that that
clinton is moving carefully on this
while still maintaining the necessity
uh over the mid-term
of uh and not too short
uh of uh getting north korea to comply
he is working on that including positive
inducements but i'm glad that he's not
working too fast because an attack on
those power on those nuclear reactors
would be catastrophic
one more question really out here
well i don't want to let tim you've had
your hand uh
i feel that the greatest danger in the
world today is these unemployed soviet
scientists
going out these other countries and
getting employed at a high wage to
produce bombs and other nuclear
what evidence is this happening in there
oh well it is a it is a significant
danger it's a very great danger uh
reportedly scientists have actually been
stopped in russia
on their way when on their way to i
think
north korea in one case
to produce ballistic missiles and to
produce various weapons of mass
destruction and certainly at a time when
they do feel unemployed when they're
when their income is
minuscule compared even to ours let
alone to our nuclear scientists
uh the temptation for them to do that is
very great
i wouldn't say that's the greatest
danger
because you have to keep in mind it's
one thing for them to go out and advise
people how to process uranium reprocess
it how to put it together and all this
that's a very long costly process
uh for somebody eventually to leave
russia with a suitcase
uh with a bomb in it
is a more immediate and more greater
danger
yeah you really don't have time for any
more because there were a couple more
hands up
what are you saying
of the uh
all of the other sessions that are
scheduled we have under secretary of
state work and
assistant secretary of state chad for
human rights i'd be happy to answer
questions then after the session of
anybody and alan has his data here if
people want to pursue uh what he was
describing we want to take this
opportunity to
thank daniel ellsberg
[Applause]
and alan kay for his extra and
we'll answer any questions here in a
minute and again thank you for coming
today
the global structures convocation met
today in suburban washington dc to
discuss the future of nuclear weapons
you can see this part of the discussion
again at around 4 10 a.m eastern time
overnight here on c-span 2.
we're going to continuing of the house
small business committee looking at the
impact of so-called super stores on
small towns
and that's a look at the c-span 2
program schedule
next a panel discussion sponsored by the
discovery channel on the effective
watergate on american politics
the discussion begins with a clip from
an upcoming discovery channel series
entitled watergate
participants in the symposium include
former staff members of president
richard nixon and producers of the
watergate series the discovery channel
is a cable network based in bethesda
maryland a suburb of washington dc
well welcome to you all uh we very much
appreciate you coming to
reminisce with us about events that
occurred 20 years ago
this is a
going to be i hope a very illuminating
morning
for you all
given the distinguished panel
or panels that we've assembled to
talk about in some cases their
involvement in the watergate
events of watergate and in other
instances the reporters and the
journalists who are
painstakingly putting the history of
watergate together for yet another
generation to better understand this
part of american history
my name is greg moyer i'm executive vice
president
with the discovery channel
i'm in charge of programming
and it's with great pleasure that we're
here today
in collaboration with times books to
talk to you about
our a television series and a book about
watergate
i'll begin with the television and then
turn over the microphone to my colleague
peter osnos from times books to tell you
about his product
first this is a very
this was a series that we embarked on
over two years ago
and it grew out of a very successful
collaboration that the discovery channel
had with a production company in london
run by brian lapping
brian is with us today and will be
available for your questions later
brian and his company produced an
extraordinary uh series of programs for
the discovery channel and the british
broadcasting corporation at the time
that were aired at the time of
the coup in moscow when
we had determined that it was important
to chronicle the era of gorbachev's
reign in that country
and at the time of the coup the programs
were just coming
getting ready for air here and
they had the foresight to have contacted
all the relevant people in that
term tumultuous set of circumstances and
we had an extraordinary oral history of
the six years of gorbachev's reign
what was so compelling to me at that
time was the commitment to telling the
story correctly the commitment to being
historians something that came before
producing television if you will and it
was that level of
of care and concern for the facts and
for the story that made me extremely
excited to enter into a second major
collaboration with brian lapping and
his producer norma percy
they came to me with the idea that we
should do watergate
i think that they had already uh uh
had some interesting conversations with
uh fred emery who is at the time the
london bureau chief or the washington
bureau chief of the of the times of
london
and fred had uh covered watergate for
his readers back in in the uk
and they they had the sense that there
was a story to be told and i remember
sitting in our office and just sort of
looking out the window and thinking well
people 20 years hence really care about
watergate
well
i'm not sure that unprovoked they would
care about watergate but let me tell you
if you have a chance to watch even the
few clips of this series i think you'll
see what extraordinary television this
really is
i am
also pleased to say that we've been able
to uh through the collaboration of of
times books and fred's work been able to
spend probably more time researching a
five-hour piece of television than goes
into
nearly any other kind of production i
mean the attention and the time spent to
the research component of this project
is almost unprecedented certainly in
discovery's history
that's because all the major
participants who were interviewed for
the program which number about 55 were
all pre-interviewed extensively prior to
the inter intervention of cameras and
microphones this isn't the kind of a
series where you just go and you click
on a lapel mic and say let's talk about
watergate to john dean now this is some
something where you plan your questions
you understand the material and you
frankly put the
people involved under cross-examination
i'm sure they'll be able to tell you
more about that process
but what occurs then is something that
is most electric and it it's actually
built in the in the editing process
where you find that one participant
answers or finishes the story of another
and it adds to the the narrative power
and the intensity of the of the
experience
so i am extremely proud of of these five
hours of television i think it's
important that as i said before another
generation of americans is introduced to
this incredible political story and i
think it's awfully uh it's awfully good
for all of us who lived through those
years to go back and remember the twists
and turns that occurred in the early
1970s
so i'd like to now bring up peter osnos
and have him make a few introductory
remarks and then we'll show you some
television peter
uh well on behalf of times books at
random house i'd like also to
welcome you all this morning
it's a particular
pleasure to see so many familiar faces
from a
watergate era
that i had the privilege of
watching in washington
none of them have changed they just look
exactly the same it's extraordinary what
watergate did for them it was the secret
to permanent youth
there is a washington adage that timing
is is everything and by that standard
i think this couldn't be a more
appropriate time for the discovery
channel series in fedemary's
terrific watergate book the passing of
richard nixon
has of course reopened the debate over
nixon's role in american history
that's been compounded by the unlikely
appearance of h.r holdem and extensive
diaries i mean a bestseller of summer
reading it was not something that
anybody would have predicted
thousands of pages of agate from h.r
holdem and people seem to be fascinated
by it
then comes threads book and the
television uh series which enables us i
think on the whole to to tell the story
of watergate and this is what fred's
done and i think it's what the series
does to tell the story of watergate as
though it had not been told before
for a generation of people
many of them who were infants at the
time of watergate are now full-fledged
grown-ups
and tomorrow they will be reading about
hearings on whitewater
uh and they will be reading about
altman's testimony and cutler's
testimony and all of this stuff that's
going to be drawn it is essential that
people understand where this all comes
from in a sense it all comes from
watergate
and fred's book
which of course we had the privilege of
publishing um
tells that story with extraordinary
detail and precision
when fred first approached me
in a garage across the street from the
washington post
25 years ago no no actually
when fred
when fred firched first approached me i
thought
i had i knew fred's reputation i knew
his work i knew that he was the
presenter of panorama in britain which
is a 60 minutes type program actually
a first class piece of work um
i thought why is this brit
the right person to tell this story and
uh chris fred was here during the
watergate period
and covered it had the very difficult
job of explaining watergate back to um
to his readers in fact to his editors
in london succeeded in doing that
obviously maintained an interest over
the years but fred is also and i could
tell that from my very first encounter
with him a prodigious reporter i mean
his energy and enthusiasm and curiosity
and just his general range for the
subject was really amazing
and
in a really astonishingly short time
he's turned out this very lucid telling
of watergate
in a way that really i do think serves
the purpose that it was set out for it
let's tell the story as though it had
not been told before
obviously readers will find spin of one
kind or another truth is it's as
straight as it can be and i think it
allows people to make judgments about
what history is bound to record as one
of the most important periods
in
american life and certainly in the 20th
century so without further ado greg is
going to set up some of these uh
wonderful clips
for the first part of the uh for the
first panel then after questions there
will be clips for the
second panel and i think you'll find it
all
remarkable morning thanks again for
coming
[Applause]
well i'm not sure who had the tougher
challenge putting 55 interviews and
countless hours of tape into a five hour
program or
our own ian hubble who had to somehow
find a way to take five hours down to 15
to 20 minutes
but what we are going to present to you
now is about a 15-minute uh compilation
reel of the first three episodes of the
of the
miniseries break-in
cover-up and scapegoat which are the
episode titles um i should tell you as
well uh that we will be airing the
watergate miniseries on the 20 the week
of the 20th anniversary of
president nixon's resignation from
office we're going to take the first two
episodes and run them back to back on
sunday august 7th and then run
consecutive hours uh
on mondays tuesday and wednesday at 10
o'clock all of it will be repeated in a
stack the following week sunday in the
afternoon
so without further ado break in cover up
and scapegoat
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello i'm daniel shore
only one american president in history
was forced out of office and when he
died 20 years later it was without a
state funeral in the nation's capital
i'm talking of course about richard m
nixon
two years and two months before he
resigned to escape impeachment his
undoing began here in the building
called the watergate watergate gave its
name to a turbulent chapter in american
history
watergate the worst political scandal in
american history finally destroys
president richard nixon
the president who opened new doors to
russia and china quits the white house
in disgrace
he resigned rather than face impeachment
for ordering illegal acts
well when the president does it that
means that it is not illegal
two years before he resigned the
president's re-election committee had
broken into his opponent's headquarters
in search of damaging intelligence
there was pressure from the white house
from me and from the president to the
committee to get their campaign
intelligence activity going
the breaking team was caught and the
white house launched the cover-up that
ruined nixon
the staff itself
was not doing very much as a matter of
individual initiative they were carrying
out richard nixon's instructions
day-to-day
now nixon's closest advisors give
evidence that the watergate break-in was
just won in a series of crimes
instigated by the president himself
on june 12 1971 nixon's elder daughter
trisha married law student edward cox
the president described it as his
happiest day in the white house but the
happiness was short-lived
the next day coverage of the wedding was
upstaged in the nation's leading
newspaper the new york times led with
the pentagon papers a massive leak of
top-secret documents tracing three
decades of growing american involvement
in vietnam two and a half million tons
of bombs ago
in october 1969 my my friend tony
rousseau and i began copying the
pentagon papers
to give them to the american congress
and share them with the american public
the american public didn't get them then
it took two invasions later before the
newspapers began releasing them
now
they've got them now
ten days later the new york times
published another damaging leak the
story gave away the u.s fallback
position in nuclear missile negotiations
with the soviets
the president summoned erlichmann and
his protege bud
grog when i walked in the president was
standing up behind his desk
then he started to pace back and forth
and he
told me that he that this kind of uh
leak was intolerable that we just could
not stand any more of them i remember
him
slamming his fist into his hand saying
how dangerous this was and it had to be
stopped he wanted a lie detector test
given to everybody he wanted the name of
the guy who was responsible he wanted
telephone taps he wanted you know this
and that and this and that a lot of
hyperbole a lot of hubris in the in the
oval office
the president's demand for line detector
tests on a massive scale was recorded
like everything said in the oval office
by the hidden taping system mia just
installed
nixon's first target was his foreign
policy staff
um
put fear into these people was how
erlichmann noted the president's
instruction but the fbi dragged his feet
and never identified the leakers for
nixon
for years billionaire howard hughes had
been secretly financing both political
parties and the nixon campaign
nixon was determined to find out about
the o'brien hughes connection and what
damaging information o'brien had on him
i first saw it in the form of a memo
that
had been dictated by the president on
air force one to haldeman saying isn't
it about time we make
uh larry o'brien accountable for his
retainer with howard hughes
larry o'brien's office in the democratic
national committee now became the key
target of the bugging operation
it was located in the huge luxury
complex called the watergate
we have uncovered the only existing
written evidence of the authorization of
the watergate project
for 20 years it was thought that all
copies of this memorandum had been
deliberately destroyed by the aide who
wrote it for haldeman
this is a truly amazing document to
service at this late date and what the
document says
is that gordon ladies intelligence
operation proposal 300 000 has been
approved right there in big black and
white letters
if haldeman knew about this
there is no doubt in my mind that
richard nixon knew about this because
everything that haldeman knew
he knew for the sake of richard nixon
and it's just inconceivable to me that
this type of information which nixon
loved
would not be shared with him
in june 1972 president nixon flew home
from moscow having just signed the first
superpower treaty to limit nuclear
weapons he was re-election-bound an
international hero but about to become a
domestic villain well of course it will
not be lost on uh many people in his
audience both in the capital and
elsewhere tonight but uh
this is a
pretty good way to
impress a lot of voters
the president
of the united states
[Applause]
i suppose this is just about the peak of
richard nixon's political career this
morning
[Applause]
[Music]
as nixon saved his triumph five of his
men were arrested in washington caught
red-handed inside democratic party
headquarters in the watergate office
building the same team had committed
other crimes for the white house the
president and his inner circle saw no
option but a cover-up
the president's men set about organizing
their hush money richard nixon's private
lawyer herb calmback got the assignment
combat collected 75 000 of nixon
campaign funds but he needed to find
somebody to deliver it
[Music]
i got a call to come down to washington
and to meet with mr herbert comback
i came to the hotel in washington dc
i came up in right away he was didn't
have socks on and he apologized for that
and i'd been in the army in the navy and
he apologized for not having his socks
on at any rate he got in into this story
that
uh
he had met with john dean
a park bench across from the white house
dean said that on the highest authority
it was decided
that herb combat would provide funds and
that tony lassowitz the only one that
they could trust would distribute
said funds to those who broke into the
watergate
a building
so now he's uh he has an anti-shea case
and he's got 75 grand in it
the 75 000 now he's taking it out of the
at the shade case and putting it on a
bed
now 75 grand you know it's quite a bit
of lettuce and there was a laundry bag
in the closet one of these that very
thin brown paper that you
put your laundry and leave it out the
door and i
plucked all that cabbage i put it into
the bag
tied it up with the string maybe twice
over put it under my arm and said we'll
be in touch now i'll wait your
instructions
[Music]
in the end of watergate a crucial time
for president nixon with the weeks after
his second inaugural in january 1973.
during that time he could probably have
saved his presidency by making a clean
breast of political espionage and
apologizing for it he chose instead to
go the route of cover-up hush money and
designated scapegoats
it was uh inevitable
as soon as they started down any road
they were going to find me there because
i'd been everywhere
so the press was just surrounding my
house and it looked like they were going
to camp out indefinitely and the
president called and he said well john
why don't you go to camp david
and get away from it all
dean readily accepted the chance to
escape to the rustic presidential
retreat
but nixon's hospitality had a sting in
its tail
i said
that john dean
should make a report
and i said we or we have to have a
statement
dean knew the president needed a
scapegoat before the senate hearing
started
and he began to fear he was hit
if i put all that i had done in a report
the president one could say well this is
all i ever knew this is the first time
it was ever revealed to me and used that
as a shield but also use it as a sword
against me
so i started walking in the in the woods
up there and i got to thinking about
what am i going to do when i have to
testify
well i pulled my ore as as hard as
anybody in the cover-up i thought it
unfair that i was being asked in essence
to take the fall and it angered me
by the time john dean returned to town
he had made up his mind he would not be
the president scapegoat
subcommittee will come to aldera
dean's appearance was carefully staged
horn-rimmed glasses instead of his usual
contact lenses and a new short haircut
dean's testimony described all his
meetings with the president in chilling
detail
the meeting with the president that
afternoon with alderman ehrlichman and
myself was a tremendous disappointment
to me because it was quite clear that
the cover-up as far as the white house
was
was concerned was going to continue
republicans were absolutely helpless to
do anything with dean's testimony
accordingly keeping the republicans away
from dean before he testified paid off
baker had to digest 245 pages of complex
testimony as dean delivered it
i said this is like trying to shovel
smoke you know there's so many facts and
they go in so many different directions
i don't have the foggiest idea really
what our
objective is what are we after i i want
to try to focus this inquiry i'm trying
to focus on the president
what did the president know and when did
he know it
baker's question was subtlety itself he
sounded as though he was being tough on
the president but he was actually being
tough on dean
can you tell us whether or not you can
shed any further light on whether the
president knew
of the break-in of the watergate complex
on june 17th you mean did he have prior
knowledge of it yes
i uh
cannot testify of any first-hand
knowledge of that
i asked butterfield if there might be
any uh validity to the suggestion made
by john dean in this testimony that
there was a taping system in the white
house
that was a direct question
so i said i remember saying i don't know
why i said this i said i'm sorry you
fellows asked me that question well i
was sorry
yes there was
and they said
could you tell us about it the democrats
investigator could hardly wait to tell
his boss
and he came up his face was drenched his
eyes were bulging
and the first words that came out of his
mouth is the president bugged himself
the chief counsel met his deputy and
they set off to see dean
sam dash and jim hamilton came out to
the house
mo and i were there but sam really got
right down to business and what he told
me is he said that uh
john
there's a taping system in the white
house how do you feel about that and i
can remember that
mo and john i believe was sitting on a
couch and i was standing by the
fireplace and i did that on purpose
so i could gauge john's reaction i was
watching him very intently and sam told
him
and i never will forget it john broke
into this huge smile
this beaming smile i couldn't have been
more elated
i said sam i said everything i've told
you you're now going to find a record
for
[Music]
great
that is just
a taste
i'd like to now bring up um
a distinguished journalist who uh will
conduct the panel for it for us this
morning the first panel
he needs very little introduction in
this town he's been working
prodigiously for 50 years at his craft
and is still one of the best mr daniel
shore
[Applause]
let me start here
uh
i'm not only privileged but really quite
fascinated to be involved in this whole
event
the
television series the book aside
this event this morning is in its own
way quite extraordinary
it's something like a class reunion
it is
something like a meeting of veterans of
a war on opposite sides
meeting at the battlefield in the
coolness of the evening to discuss how
the battle went as seen from various
sides
of people
who were adversaries once
today come and reflect and look at what
it was all about
uh in it i didn't assemble a panel in
quite that way nor have anything to do
with deciding who would be on the first
but who was on the second but as i saw
who was on this first panel
of the six panelists
five
are almost in themselves
a history of what brought president
nixon down
if you start first of all with
daniel ellsberg
as you saw in those clips
he was one of the triggering events
which helped to send president nixon and
company up the wall result in the
creation of the plumbers and
precipitated a lot of events after that
then you have james mccord
who was
one of those
who was involved in the watergate
break-in
and who then helped to break the
cover-up
first writing a letter to judge john
cerrika
after they had all gone to jail been
sentenced
and told telling that there had been
hush money and cover-up and perjury
and that was in itself a triggering
event
i must say jim i can tell you now what
i've not told you before that
you did not do me a lot of good right
then because
in march
1973 i wanted to take a trip to europe
and my employers at cbs said do you
think there may be any further watergate
developments
and i with that
crystal ball which has served me so well
said
i don't think so i think probably
there's more to it than just the people
who broke in and liddy and hunt
but i think they've got enough power in
the white house to be able to cover it
up successfully and i think this is
probably the end of it
i
went off to europe
mccord's letter was disclosed i got a
call in europe from cbs saying do you
have any more predictions you would like
to make
right
then we had of course
has been also seen
john dean
again a precipitating event was his
falling off
escaping from the white house
with the information that he had those
chilling thrilling words that
he had told the president about a cancer
on the presidency
and then after that you had the sam dash
the chief counsel to the senator evan
senate watergate committee
uh who conducted what you might call one
of the better congressional
investigations i mean compared to
subsequent ones
like the iran gate and so on
this was one that he were there they
really were looking for information got
the information
laid the basis for subsequent
impeachment it was
the information
from the senate watergate committee that
ultimately helped the house judiciary
committee to start its impeachment
investigation and then finally alex
butterfield now familiar to you if not
before then familiar also
from these clips the one who revealed
the taping system that in the end
provided the smoking gun and a whole lot
of other guns
that that brought president nixon down
is quite remarkable
as i thought about it that without any
one of those five
certainly two
the result the outcome might have been
quite different and president nixon
could have survived were it not from
accord word not the deen were not for
butterfield were not
for sam dash
and then finally
there's one more person i wanted
introduce doesn't kind of
fit into that
it has miss norma percy
who didn't do anything to nixon then but
has done a lot to him since
so if i ask all five of you to come up
and take your places or six of you to
come up and take your places
in fact i could have saved time by
asking you to come up and take your
places while i was talking
and
now let me also tell you about the
ground rules i'm going to ask each of
these six
to open with a short statement i'm about
to put them to them a question a
question which they don't know yet last
night we we had a meeting in which we
discussed what we were going to do today
and i told them i'll ask you this
question and then i'll ask you that
question but i woke up at five o'clock
this morning i said no that's
that would be a popular thing to do but
it would be wrong and
and uh
so i'm going to throw at them for each
one of them
a question which i'll ask them to be
brief in responding to
and then i would like if they want to to
address each other and comment on what
the other has said and i would like to
really see these people who might not
have been talking a lot to each other in
all cases in 1973 and for have a chance
to address each other across now
this silent battlefield that lies behind
us
the question i want to ask you starting
with you dan
is
now you look back
you played a singular part in a singular
episode in american history
now these years later
would you do it again are you glad you
did it would you do it differently
i can say very briefly i wish that i had
given the pentagon papers
to the newspapers of in 69 rather than
to the senate which did nothing with
them at that time and i really have to i
can go a lot beyond that i wish
desperately that i had emptied the
contents of my safe
in 1964 and 65 and brought it over to
senators morrison gruening and the
others on the senate foreign relations
committee
in 64.
senator morris once told me when
volunteering to speak at my trial that
if i had provided the proof that i had
available which five years later i put
out in the pentagon papers
of the hoax of the tonkin gulf
raids and the secret planning in 1964
for escalation
during a campaign when he was when the
president was running on not expanding
the war secretly planning to do it had i
done that senator morris told me
the tonkin golf resolution would never
have gotten out of committee
and if it had
he said it would have been voted down
what he was telling me was that i could
have perhaps
averted seven and a half million tons of
bombs fifty thousand american casualties
a couple of million vietnamese
casualties a very heavy responsibility
to bear so i have to say that i wish
that i had thought of doing it then i
didn't remotely
think of that in 64 took another five
years of war and being in vietnam for
two years to make me realize that
congress needed and deserved that truth
and that i should not have been
participating in the lies as i had so
long thank you now james mccord
you did something which some people
would consider to be disloyal you after
all you worked for the president's the
committee to reelect the president in a
sense you worked for the president
a lot of people were willing to take it
and go to jail
they wanted some money they want to pay
off all the rest but they sort of say
well this is the president and we'll
take it you at one point simply broke
you couldn't take it anymore and you
wrote that famous letter to judge sirica
you glad you did it
very much so then um
immediately after the watergate break-in
i had told my family
that i'd made a mistake i needed to set
everything straight with my lord
and with my family by telling the truth
i told him that
however i had to pick the propitious
time that was a phrase that i used
because i had only hearsay testimony
from one man gordon liddy
about the key planning in two secret
meetings in john mitchell's office with
dean and michelle and magruder
and liddy
where the watergate break-in was planned
i knew that i had one shot at getting
the story told and if the white house
discredited why that was the end of the
ballgame
so i waited until after the trial when
the two key witnesses government
witnesses jeb magruder and bart porter
perjured themselves that strengthened
what i had
i put it together in a letter to judge
sarika went to him
he refused it the first time i had to
try twice to get him to take it
second time his curiosity got the better
of him he accepted the letter
it was a letter describing the cover-up
white house cover-up that had gone on by
for nine months by my neighbor next door
and
that perjury had been committed
followed that then with interviews with
the los angeles times the first ones to
break the story
of the cover-up john dean and magruder's
role and ultimately mitchell and then
sam dash
immediately after that
i talked with him
i told him gave him the names of those
four who planned the
break in mitchell dean magruder and
liddy
and in turn the names of 10 people
roughly who could substantiate what i
had to say
sam did a
superb job of calling those people
before the committee getting testimony
substantiating the story
and ultimately did a marvelous job in
his committee so
i have no regrets okay john dean first
of all
and aside a couple of asides
for you i was just recently looking
through some records and found a letter
you wrote to senator sam irvin as
chairman of the
judiciary constitutional rights
subcommittee when he was investigating
the fbi investigation of me
and trying to find out why it happened
you wrote him a letter saying you don't
understand where all the fuss is about
you will not appear before his committee
you don't understand what all the fuss
is about it was a simple matter that i
was being considered for a white house
job which was filled at the time and
that therefore they had neglected to
tell me i was being considered for that
job i
thank you details details details right
thank you also for uh giving me
uh what is perhaps the most electrifying
moment i have ever spent in television
when covering the senate watergate
hearings and you testified that there
had been enemies lists
drawn up
described as unscrewing our political
enemies and i was live on television
when somebody handed me the first list
of 20
and read down and found my own name at
number 17
while i was reading the list at number
20 i recall was this was the sainted
mary mcgrory paul newman was somewhere
else
let me then ask you
you were with perhaps
i believe i've replaced you on the list
[Laughter]
well exactly i think that that
that if there were an enemies list drawn
up in 1973 it would be an enemy's list
of one
john john dean
and you've had to live with yourself
uh ever since that time any regrets did
you
looking back the fact that you were
going to be made a scapegoat as you saw
it and you didn't want to be a scapegoat
so you had allowed the whole thing to
come tumbling down
good thing to do
well there's no doubt
that it is
difficult
to be the one to blow the whistle and i
wouldn't portray as anything other than
a very unpleasant role
but i had
it didn't happen in in one sudden moment
but as
the watergate
cover-up
began crumbling and i began trying to
convince long before it did fall apart
my colleagues that it wasn't going to
work
it became very apparent to me that a
number of them
were interested in me taking the fall
for them and i didn't see it that way
and as i as i saw some of my my
colleagues telling me
well i don't really remember it quite
that way john it became very apparent
that they were going to tell a different
story than i was
and as that process evolved
and then started accelerating i i really
found myself losing
respect for a lot of the people i had
had a great deal of respect for
because i didn't really think that's the
way it should be i thought we ought to
all stand up and say this is what
happened these are the
serious mistakes we've made we should
carve this thing away let the president
do what he can do with it and we should
get out of here because we've messed
this thing up pretty badly well that
didn't sell
but
the fact that
i had made one decision that was just
a decision i wouldn't
alter under any circumstances that was
when i testified i was going to tell the
truth
and i made that very clear so there
really was never any surprise there
couldn't have been any surprise to my
colleagues
that when i did testify i testified to
what i knew to be the truth
and i have no regrets
you're a good lawyer you explain how it
happened and there shouldn't have been
any objections
but look at it very large are you glad
you did it well glad isn't the right
word
i just feel that it was the i was
certainly felt it was the right thing to
do
20 years later
i wouldn't do it any other way
okay
now next sam dash uh your role was also
really very key
you in the first place
were the one who arranged for for john
dean to get sufficient
immunity to make it possible for him to
testify the white house strategy the
point was that nobody gets immunity and
nobody can be allowed to testify
uh
to the prosecutors and to the grand jury
and you seeing a challenge and an
opportunity said well if they won't if
they won't let them testify there maybe
we can give them some immunity and
they'll testify to us
and so you managed to bypass that whole
operation and make it possible for john
dean to find uh a forum you also then
dealt with jim mccord and he also came
before you and so
certainly without you and your committee
i don't want to personalize it as being
only you
none of this would have happened i guess
i don't have to ask you if you're glad
you did what you did well isn't this the
question of being glad dan
i don't know any other way to have done
it
and i think the important significance
of watergate then
is missed by this series of television
and the book not because they were
seeking to do it but they were telling
the story as if it had never been told i
think the significance of watergate is
that the first
institution to tell the american people
the full story of watergate was the
senate watergate committee and that's
within our constitutional system of
government the constitution requires the
congress to oversee the executive and
tell the american people so democracy
can work
when the government engages in crimes of
this kind of this was quite a serious
tragedy and therefore
but for the senate watergate committee
as you said dan
but for our investigation i don't
believe mccord would have had anybody to
talk to really
john dean would never have been able to
come before us butterfield would never
have been able to talk about
the tapes and but for the hearings that
we put forward to inform the american
people what happened and the american
people responded with a sense of outrage
because they understood through that
summer of 1973 there would have been no
impeachment proceedings uh there would
have been no prosecution because
archibald cox would have been fired and
nobody would have cared but because of
the summer of 1973 and our hearings the
public was sensitized and they knew how
outrageous it was when cox was fired uh
it isn't that we did something special i
think we did our job that for
unfortunately isn't done always by the
congress i don't think before after
congress took on its constitutional
duties the same way sam irvin senator
sam irvin deserves the greatest credit
of carrying forth the work of the
constitution that the constitutional
government worked
a president resigned without any
precedence before but we had no
revolution no bloodshed a new president
came into being
this was the way the founders wanted it
to work and i think it was a remarkable
event that the public has not forgotten
okay now
all of this
was necessary but not sufficient
to bring down all the four of you so far
with necessary parts but not sufficient
parts to bring down
a very popular president then there was
a singular event
i talked to alex butterfield
last night some and by the way i think i
want to make public an apology i made to
him privately
during that period i interviewed live on
the cbs morning news a man named
fletcher prouty
who alleged that alex butterfield at the
white house was serving the interest of
the c.i.a in the white house and because
it was live television there wasn't much
you could do about it
it turned out later that wasn't true
fletcher priority has now gone on to
much greater things doing oliver stone's
work in jfk
and uh
for what sometimes happens on live
television to the extent that causes you
any injury or grief let me apologize to
you for that right now
last night you also said however that
the the word that seemed to have gotten
around
that the reason that you reveal the
existence of the white house taping
system
uh was that you thought that maybe bob
holdman had or maybe larry higby had and
that therefore you were afraid of being
entrapped into a position of perjury
that was not true you did not think that
they had done it uh you were doing it
for you were making this revelation uh
for reasons entirely of your own
you provided a smoking gun
you provided an awful lot of guns that
went off
uh you must have been at times appalled
as you look back you were very close to
president nixon you told me last night
that he was the last person you saw
before he retired at night and you spent
a lot of time with him presumably
admired and respected him
and you pushed him out of office
first of all uh you're forgiven for the
matter of the cia
but uh
yes i was close to him i worked some 20
feet away from the
from the president for nearly four years
and was in and out all the time
but by that time i was at the federal
aviation administration and was called
up to
testify and usually when i was called
before
investigative bodies it was to give
an insight about the white house and how
it worked
what the
president's aids relationships were to
him and to each other and that type of
thing and i had no reason to believe
that i was being called before
the watergate committee for any other
reason in fact i don't think i was but
during the course of that uh four hour
uh interview one friday friday the
friday the 13th i hadn't thought of that
of july of 73
they did this was the interview with don
sanders staff yeah
the senator watergate committee the
interview with the staff they did
mention the fact that
they had this
paper there that looked to me as though
they said where might this have come
from and
shoved a paper my way which looked to me
to be
a transcript of the tape it was in such
detail
but i took that as a sort of fuzzy
question and i had decided in my own
mind that
even though there was only one chance in
the million they might mention tapes i
was very aware of the tapes i was the
one who had given the order to the
secret service for them to install the
tapes at haldeman's direction and all
during john dean's testimony i kept
saying well everything rang true i knew
everything john was saying was true i
knew the the way the white house worked
the way the inner sanctum operated
and but when they gave me this paper i
said uh
um
that i took that as a sort of a fuzzy
answer and i uh
a fuzzy question and i had determined to
give a fuzzy answer to a fuzzy question
but if the question were direct then i
felt i had no choice but to respond
accordingly
so
you had no choice
there were people who had thought it
with a higher loyalty was to purge
themselves there were people who thought
that there's a point of view yeah when
you're protecting the president you lie
so what do you mean you had to well yes
a lot of people think i should have said
excuse me and run to the telephone
but this was an official investigative
body and i did feel that i had an
obligation to respond directly
and so uh but in that occasion i said
yes uh
this looks too detailed the president
did have great retentive powers
but
this looks too detailed for that and let
it go later on
don sanders picked up on that and asked
a question which i felt was direct he
said were there ever any taping systems
in the oval office
and i'd already described this little
dicta belt which the president had but i
told them also about the elaborate
system with eight microphones embedded
in the desk of the president et cetera
so and i certainly have no regrets about
that although i did lose a lot of
friends at the same time i got a lot of
nice letters from
from others
but uh people forget we were all working
so hard there i didn't dwell on it too
much president
i never had any contact with the
president after that and as soon as i
came back from the soviet union where i
went the next day as sam
mentioned last night
i realized i was out in the cold it's
easy to tell when we'd have a
sub-cabinet meeting over at the white
house people were
clearly avoiding me unless we were
walking down the hall or something then
a few people would come up and shake my
hand and say nice going but no one
really wanted to be seen
talking to me and you would do it again
oh yes uh-huh very very yeah very
clearly i would do it again
and finally norma percy who is the
head of documentary production
for brian lapping associates which
produced this thing you you hear my
voice on it you may see me i must tell
you i'm sometimes a little embarrassed
because
so little of this represents my real
work it's the work of norma percy and
her people and brian lapping
and having heard these people
i'd like to hear what you think now
well they all they all said pretty much
what they said to us i mean what we set
out to do is give them a platform to
talk about watergate 20 years later when
they finally could
and they did i mean all we did was bring
them together and let them talk
them and the tapes i mean i think what
sets water gate apart from everything
else is the white house tapes the fact
that
i mean sam really has the best line in
the series the president bugged himself
the one lesson of watergate is if you're
going to commit a crime uh don't take it
particularly on a voice activated tape
system
the fact that
there are all those hours of what
richard nixon was doing there on tape
for
when it was discovered all the
investigators to hear
is what sets watergate apart from all
the other scandals
and for a journalist it's just
extraordinary to go out to the archives
put on earphones and listen to john dean
and the president plotting
um
to give a million dollars in hush money
to shut up burglars i mean the president
of the united states and the oval office
and um you know for us that was really
exciting and we tried to put that in the
program too
all right now you people don't meet
together very often and i don't know how
often
you will want to have these class
reunions maybe every year as you get
like it i'd like to before going to the
floor for questions to give any and all
of you an opportunity to address each
other comment on what the other has said
or ask each other questions about things
still not clear in your mind would any
of you would like to could i just
talk to my friend butterfield uh god god
bless him uh but for the tapes john
dean's great credible testimony in june
of 1973 would be the word of one man
against the president and we all knew at
that time
and others and the we all knew at that
time that it needed corroboration and
and butterfield gave us the ear the ear
witness
but i think what you have to understand
is that you were called for the purpose
of finding out about the tapes
john dean gave us the first clue that
there may be a taping system
and i and my staff began to follow a
strategy we called setting up satellite
charts where we took the president
holdem and erlickman and we try to
figure out who sits around them who
works with them
and we really got about a couple hundred
people and we call all of you in
and a lot of questions were being asked
but in among them was something about
taping so we didn't know whether you
knew or not
uh but you did thank god
sam i just might add one thing that
the only area of my testimony
where i speculated
was about the tapes
the it was an odd decision because i
tried to make everything just a flat
statement of fact
but when i got to thinking about the
fact that that i believed i had been
taped i just said to myself well
particularly with the conversations with
the president
and i did i seriously believed it
because of nixon's actions his behavior
on a couple of occasions suggested that
the man was trying to make a record
uh and he didn't do it very well a lot
of leading questions and the questions
were
opposite of what we talked about before
so i said there's somebody making a
record here but anyway when i speculated
it i i i did it uh thinking
well if i believe i'm taped people will
obviously say the man is not lying about
a conversation he believes he was taped
about so that's really why i put that
speculation in my testimony well it
turned out also when we found out about
the tapes since you didn't know about
them
uh as we saw on this little skit
uh you reacted exactly the way we hoped
you would react when we let you know
that there were tapes
i don't know if len garment is here
can't talk to him he's on panel too
right yeah but but uh
i don't know if lem i don't i don't know
if len remembers this but at one point
i said something to len about the fact
that i had
prepared and had to keep a record of
some of my
uh activities in the oval office and i
was hinting that i had taped
uh later some of the the uh the tapes
would come out where mr nixon expresses
great concern that i've made a taped
record and i've always wanted to ask len
if he ever shared that with anybody else
uh that suggestion i had made
no okay
so they just thought i was taping also
all right john and sam
uh are you there can you hear me
over here over here right over here
panel two in the wings
uh one thing that has always
demystified me a little bit
um maybe because i made a lot of
assumptions that was that were either
naive or or or strange
was
and is the amount of uh
importance that
is attached not to the discovery of the
tapes but to the fact that the question
was asked
uh higley had come to me and told me
about the taping system and it's going
to be examined by
the senate group and his question was
well what do i do i said well if they
ask you the question you talk the truth
and if they don't ask you the question
you don't have to volunteer it and don't
dance around because you get yourself
into trouble and then i took them
through a drill on that i assume
i i really did assume that
because it's such an obvious question is
there a taping system and i've always
been kind of
sam or john sam in particular can answer
this question for me
why was it
an issue that had to be
approached with such
gentleness and and well not gentleness
i like useful yeah strategy and subtlety
we simply ask any of these because we
didn't expect we didn't expect to get
the truth uh hold him and we asked the
question he lied to us higbee lied to us
uh we had to develop a strategy of
getting people who had no self-interest
involved we asked hundreds there was i
assumed that the
taping system
would come out that was inevitable i
don't believe so
i don't believe so i don't believe so
but for the strategy i think and but for
going i don't think but if uh we would
never got to butterfield there'll be no
reason for us to have called butterfield
an investigation but for our suspicion
that he was at least somebody who could
have known about it well i don't need to
uh
i think what happened i don't need to
minimize the importance of all the
contributions made it's just that it
always struck me as little strange that
somebody wouldn't come in and say now
look was it after all this was an
administration that you sam and your
colleagues knew was up to its ears and
buggy but only three people knew about
the taping system nixon
all the men in butterfield perjury to
the years oh my god
are you surprised whoops sam i'll tell
you what
when panel 2 is on you sit there with
that microphone
and you resume your conversation with
garmin
when he when he is up there i just want
to add one small fact which i learned
from alex butterfield last night that
there were only three persons other than
the president in the white house who
knew about the taping system no no
alderman higbee and you
no haldeman
and higbee irvin didn't know no haldeman
and higby no erlickman definitely didn't
know haldeman higbee and me
and the president
and al wong
chief of the secret service well chief
of the technical security division of
the secret service and the two
people who worked for him who installed
the taping system i think that's
something like seven people when i left
the white house i had
haldeman's permission to tell
who john
bull steve steeple who was going to take
my desk and i had some
buttons on my desk that operated the
taping system in the cabinet room
okay uh
in june
john earlier
the
president your tapes
and see what went on then you must have
a micro if you're going to keep talking
you have to have a microphone
all right dan ellsberg i'm going to give
you the last word before we go well the
second almost last word two quiet people
off in this corner
well no then and then and then the
general court as i listened to land
garments assumption that the tapes would
come out uh it occurs to me that 21
years ago when we heard about these
tapes
a lot of us thought that by now we'd
have them and we'd be able to get to
read the transcripts listen to them and
at last answer senator baker's question
what did the president know and when did
he know it they looked at the tapes of
the cover-up but talking to and i'd like
any comments if you have from john and
alex but i got the impression this
morning raising this question with him
that it's their belief that the
president would have known what haldeman
knew that haldeman would have known
everything that all this discussion of
the planning and all the propositions
should be on a tape somewhere but hadn't
been listened to because the special
prosecutor didn't focus on that point i
have a proposition to put you first if
you confirm is that your is that your
belief that we could answer those
questions and the question that
particularly interests me what was the
relation between the vietnam strategy
the secret vietnam strategy the threats
of escalation everything else that had
to be protected from leaks
and watergate i would like to get that
from the tapes and i would propose that
five years from now with the 25th
anniversary of nixon's leaving office we
should have those tapes
well the archives have the tapes and the
archivists were themselves very anxious
that they should be released and there
have been suits filed on behalf of
president nixon while he was alive and i
think his estate still
trying to block the release of some 950
hours of
thousands or several thousand isn't that
oh
many of whom have heard all the tapes
and believe they should come out uh have
not been successful so far in getting
them released jim mccoy i'll give you
the last word
i really have two questions i'll cut it
down to one if you want one deals with
the conflict between the john between
your testimony
and charles colson about january 8 73
the first day of the trial the second
question
deals with this million dollars on march
21st
um i'd like to elaborate on that one if
you would the second one but the first
one is this
the first day of the trial january trial
my trial seven men january 8 73
i got a call at night at midnight from
tony ulassowitz who was on that screen
carrying a message from john dean
and in order to be to plead guilty not
to testify and take community if i was
called before a grand jury and that i'd
be rehabilitating a bunch of other
things
um
earlier that day
my lawyer f lee bailey's partner nfl
bayley ran the show
took me against my will
to the lawyer for hunt not my lawyer but
hunt's lawyer bill william bittman
there i was to hear and barker who rode
with us we're supposedly to hear a pitch
about a pardon this is the first day of
the trial
i got very angry i got a short fuse
anyway
and
i was angry at being taken to another
lawyer's office to hear a pitch about a
pardon when that lawyer didn't work for
me he worked for for hunt and barker
likewise bittman was not his lawyer
well they left me there to cool off for
a half hour my lawyer while bittman and
he met together and they disappeared
they came back my lawyer said you'll get
a call tonight from a man you you know
from the white house
and that's when this this call came now
the question is this
is jack caulfield you're talking about
yes
on an oval office tape of january 8th
charles colson is heard
talking with nixon that day january 8th
he says i got hunt to plead guilty
can't do anything with mccord
but i need to pardon
for hunt
nixon answers
i can give a pardon for a hunt but i
cannot pardon the other men the other
five six men
that's not the story that subsequently
came from your testimony in the first
place colson denied denied under oath
before the house judiciary committee
that he ever talked with nixon
during the trial about a pardon for the
men yet here it is on tape
but your
testimony is that
you
talked with colson
and that there was a quote a general
assurance of a pardon given for the men
by the president which was to be passed
down to these men that day that's your
senate testimony
now that's not the story that the men
were told they were told that they would
be pardoned meaning all of them
but nixon only promised it for one man
now where what's the truth did colson
lie to you did you
what was your version of this jim i
think you're mixing some apples and some
oranges on this one
first of all on my
i don't have my senate and testimony in
front of me but as best i recall
uh the sequence of events
what happened is that colson
had spoken with bittman gotten an
agreement as to
the
the pardon arrangement that would be
given to hunt
and then coulson himself went to the
president uh contrary to erlickman's
instructions to do so
because coulson told me he just thought
this was too important to not directly
speak with the president about
it was after
he reported that fact back to
to me and then again to ehrlichman that
i said well what's going to happen to
everybody else because this word is
going to get out
and
at that point i was told that we'll
we'll have to just give the same kind of
general assurances to everybody
and i think that's uh i don't i doubt if
that was ever raised with the president
because i think uh
uh coulson kept it confined to hunt when
he went in there
well but the president said the other
men cannot
the tapes obviously answer the question
no they don't yes they do but they don't
answer this question
these men
hunt and four cubans immediately
thereafter pled guilty in reliance on
the promise of a pardon but that's not
what nixon said but that's what they
were told in the message from colson to
them
and you told me
that night through yelaswitz
a general assurance of a pardon
but coulson conveyed the message to
bittman
and in turn to barker that all the men
would be pardoned but that's not what
nixon said so these men went off to jail
remained silent in reliance upon a
pardon that nixon never promised to him
but they thought he did you see the
deception i mean i i why don't you
to continue the conversation
all i can say is we can sum up by saying
clearly somebody lied that's right
and how shocking that is
uh
i want to allow a few minutes i mean
this is also
your your symposium as well
and
we as expected when you get people
together with fascinating things still
to say
uh it's very hard
for me to cut them off but i'd like to
allow a little time for you yes
i would like to ask and i suppose that
mr dean and mr butterfield would have
special knowledge of this
why sorry why was the taping system
installed to begin with is there an
answer to that question all right that
microphone is a television not a public
address mic and that's so may not have
carried did you hear the question yes i
heard the question why was the taping
system installed in the first place
right and and i'm sure i do know the
correct answer to that richard nixon
had this uh what was was very history
minded
we had a system called i'll try to be
brief about this
memoranda for the president's file so
everyone who met with the president even
other staff members had a second person
sitting in there taking
notes or taking mental notes about what
transpired
so uh and those
came to me i kept this file for
historical purposes the taping system
really just duplicated that and he just
wanted everything on tape and the
president gave the order to holland the
memo to the file didn't work very well
either no it didn't work right we got
60 of the i try to answer it at least
from information we got from witnesses
uh that when president nixon became
president the uh courts had already
ruled that the uh
and that congress had taken away the
power of presidents to
give their papers
uh to museums and take a tax deduction
and he had a tax accountant from los
angeles tell him that the statute didn't
speak of tapes
uh just papers and that if he put a
taping system in he wouldn't have to pay
taxes forever and therefore the
information we got from insiders was
that it was to
cut down on his taxes maybe greed is the
answer uh and the other answer i think
you might ask is why did he burn them
sam i don't believe that i worked on the
estate plan and it wasn't in there yeah
well
but essentially let me just say that it
was in there for no sinister purpose i'm
certain of that
and that richard nixon acted
all together oblivious of the tapes they
did not inhibit him in any way i mean it
did well as we know
no we forgot about them they're
automatic but but let me i'm sorry to
follow up on that but uh if john dean's
impression me very sensitive antenna and
if his impression is correct that at
certain points the president was trying
to get him to say certain things that he
would have on record and try to lead him
toward the desk where the microphone was
then he must have been aware of times
that was late though
that was late but one has an impression
reading the tapes are certain things are
being said in order to have them on
record even when they're not strictly
speaking true
i think the the important thing to make
is that they were automatic in the oval
office and when you have automatic tapes
that are operated by a trigger and the
president doesn't have to toggle the
switch you can forget about that okay
now i forgot to tell you we have two
microphones in the aisle and if you
approach those microphones with your
question then
you'll be heard here as well as on yes
jim this is james hamilton who played
some little small role himself
can you come up to the mic here i need a
microphone can you hear me
um john uh
president nixon died just a few weeks
ago
and i would like to know
your feelings your emotions
at that event
well jim i i was called by the
media
within an hour of his first being
transported to the hospital
and uh
asked to comment and i i decided at that
point i really the question is clearly
what did i have to say about watergate
and i thought well this really wasn't a
time to talk about that so i refrained
for the next uh several weeks from
taking any press calls and it did not
comment i was frankly
uh
pleased for the family and the friends
that the the funeral and the uh
accompanying ceremonies really weren't
uh
focusing on watergate
uh i thought that was a relief for them
but i was also surprised
that there was not more attention to
watergate during those
uh those few days
my own emotions
obviously when any figure that we know
well
passes it reminds us all of our own
mortality
and that we're just here for a short
time to to do what we can do
uh he certainly uh is a figure that
dramatically affected my life and i i
had one passing thought of how odd
that i would play the role in richard
nixon's career that i played
yes sir oh yes good morning
my name is john barrow
i along with carl schaffer and paul
lieber
arrested jim and four cubans
right now this is the time by the way to
point out i think what may be a small
pictorial error uh in showing a car
coming up to the watergate with light
splashing you were you were in an
unmarked car weren't you uh yes all
right
that up
that your uh
ex-fbi
dr baldwin couldn't pick out
because you were really looking for
druggies
yes
i tell you i feel that the
gym by the way it's been 24 years i
guess hi
much better to see you today than before
i feel along with the other police
officers
that there was a
very significant
piece of evidence
uh
and by nature what i'm saying is that it
was a vanguard key
that was taped to a yellow spiral
notebook
that we had to forcibly recover
from mr martinez that night
as he was attempting to dispose of it
ten days later
an fbi
document 302
confidential memorandum
was linked that key was taken to ida
maxie wells desk which it opened
my question is miss percy
why was such a crucial piece of evidence
left out of your documentary and by the
way i've seen your documentary prior to
today
on once again why was such a crucial
piece of evidence emitted from your
documentary
and for the panels uh
viewing i do have copies
of the key
of the notebook
and of the confidential fbi
report with me that i would be
let share you with but let you see it
and i'll sit down and let you just
answer that please thank you
we filmed martinez
his story doesn't corroborate yours we
spent
something like three months looking into
the stories related to that
it's what we were commissioned to do the
program
in order to follow the lines
that you're suggesting
and we couldn't find any evidence to
support it
and that's the because there's no
evidence it doesn't appear on the
program
i think that jim mccord might have an
another answer to that
um is the mic work
i when you get through i have a question
of you if you don't mind
which is pertinent to the arrest
my lawyer
bailey his partner in december pitched
me three times to use a false defense
that cia was behind the watergate
operation
i blocked it and refused every time
because not only was it not true i knew
that it would destroy cia completely
the others were willing to go along with
it i would not because i knew it was
false they knew it was false but they
thought it would get him off now here's
my question
my lawyer on december 21st
1972 in his office in boston in bailey's
office in boston thumb through a file
and he says one of the two police
officers who arrested you
said that at the time of the arrest you
said you were working
for the cia in the break-in
i said what
i said is absolutely not true
was that let me ask the question and
i'll follow up was that you or was that
the other fellow
okay
well jim there was three of us okay
and i can assure that it wasn't me okay
now the metropolitan police then went
through their files and said
this officer's notes show no such
statement from mccord
now the implication of that is very
powerful
either the prosecutor silbert and
glanzer
were forging a document
and giving it to well just a minute john
before you get carried away reporting a
document and giving it to my lawyers
saying this is what the metropolitan
police officer said or my lawyer was
lying to me but the metropolitan police
said no such
statement is in the notes of the police
officer and you see this is relevant
because from the beginning
when
haldeman called
director helms and to his great credit
he and his deputy were the two men
in the one agency that stiff armed the
white house and would not let the white
house through my friend john dean
corrupt them
john went out there three three times in
the week later trying to get him
involved in the cover-up and they
stiff-armed him again
then they began the cover-up story that
cia was behind it so you see there's a
pattern and a relevance to this i
appreciate your answer thank you tim jim
you jimmy with that do you remember
anything about a struggle for the key
i don't remember a thing about that i
know nothing of that
you would let me comment on the struggle
okay i was there so i guess so so god
now we're going to do about a sixth hour
on
new discoveries because there's the
recover i was the uh there was three of
us there was five of you we had two sets
of handcuffs
uh it's difficult to handcuff five
people together with two sets so what we
did as you recall we put two of you
together and two of you together and
there was one that was not handcuffed at
all we couldn't
while i was the i was the
searching officer
i was actually doing the physical
searches of all of you
carl schaffler was um making notes of
what i was recovering and from where
during this uh time when you know it was
as you know as you commented on it was a
it was a rather uh scary position we
didn't know who you were
and i think you found out who we were
mr martinez who used the alias gene
valdez that night as you all remember
using your aliases two of you used the
same one and we we laughed about it in
the cell block
and i said fellas you know you got to
get your story right now i know none of
these are names but now both of you are
using the same name we all look at each
other left
uh mr martinez
was reaching into his pocket
attempting to get rid of this when carl
saw him now i wasn't paying any
attention directly to him except he was
against the wall
and then i heard carl reach over and
tell him to take his hand out of there
and threw his hand up against the wall
and reached in and recovered the spiral
notebook with the key tape to it
so struggle yeah it was a struggle it
wasn't a major struggle
uh but he should have been reaching in
there we told him to keep their hands
still and don't move we've done a
general pat down we didn't know
you could he could have a 22 uh
pencil gun in there
so that's what the struggle was about
you see what ron ziegler meant about a
third rate burglary
uh i think unfortunately we're going to
have to close this panel there's another
panel to come
and we will all be busy heckling from
there while you're up here then uh and
asking questions let me me i want to
thank this panel for what was for me a
wonderful experience i didn't realize we
could still continue learning things
when uh
oh i've just been given 15 more minutes
not in 25 years in television has that
ever happened to me
you're on yeah thank you i'm of the
voice of america
good morning gentlemen thank you
my name is andrew barrack and i have a
couple questions and the first one is
have we agreed
on what they were looking for in the
watergate
i don't think we've really ever knew we
had a theory
um and uh i don't believe we were ever
able to put it on because we finally got
off the air
but there was some evidence that um
richard nixon was terribly uh afraid of
embarrassing information coming from his
brother
uh f donald dixon and that he had been
working with howard hughes and larry
o'brien had been a consultant
and there was some information that that
embarrassing information
was in uh larry o'brien's office they
once thought it was in hank greenspun
safe who had the las vegas sun and the
same burglar group broke into that safe
and they didn't find anything
so there is a basis of feeling that uh
there was some
uh suspicion that the democrats were
gonna come out with some very
embarrassing information about the
nixon's brother
that is one guess it seemed like a
stupid operation
what would they really find
uh in the democratic national committee
headquarters uh but that's about the
best we could come up let me let me add
to that because i've done a little
looking into that myself uh that that is
about right but that is not entirely the
whole story if you go through fred
emery's book and and then go through the
holdemon diaries and carefully see all
the references to larry o'brien you will
begin to get the mounting feeling that
president nixon worried very much that
lawrence o'brien democratic national
chairman and indeed who had been on on
the payroll as a consultant to howard
hughes in a previous period when bob
mayhew was his chief agent there and bob
mayhew was also the one dealing
with also the one who was dealing with
bibi rebozo and providing a hundred
thousand dollars
in an illegal campaign contribution that
rebozo kept in cash on behalf of him so
they were very worried about two things
one was that they'd go back to donald
nixon and the brothers loaned from
hughes which had happened
back in the early 60s or late 50s even
but much more recently that there had
been an illegal campaign contribution
made from the hughes organization and
that uh uh
the president who never quite said it
quite clearly to any of his aides but
kept referring
to the florida thing the the the uh
o'brien thing we got a and they want
they wanted they would it was a neurotic
fear
that oh larry o'brien was going to burst
some big explosion at a very key point
and they needed to find out what larry
o'brien knew
the second question is let me just add
one footnote to that and talking to
people after the fact
because this was one of my questions as
well you know what were they looking for
what has really become very apparent to
me is it was a fishing expedition they
didn't really have anything that
specific
uh in mind
and
i suppose one of the
one of the difficulties after the fact
is to have to look stupid about things
you're doing and you should have had a
you know a very focused
motive and doing all this well i don't
think that existed and i think people
have tried to invent something after the
fact i think jim for example i i had one
conversation with him once uh about this
very question years and years ago the
last time i had seen him and and i said
well why did you bug spencer oliver's
telephone
and he said john he said it was a target
of opportunity and i said jim what do
you mean what's a target of opportunity
he said well i had another bug in my
pocket and uh
i just saw this this big office and it
looked like a good place to put it and i
didn't really know where i was was
placing it is that correct jim no
john you you have an interesting memory
my credibility
throughout the whole watergate testimony
was never successfully challenged by any
single one lawyer not one another
yes okay
um
what i referred to in the conversation
with you
is that when you talked with me
you said jim
i'm writing a second book
i need some dirt on cia
if you'll give me some dirt
i in turn will cooperate in your civil
suit you're bringing against bayley
which incidentally was successfully
settled
out of court for improper representation
of me
you this is this is the
unfortunate memory that you have it's
very slippery and you slide over some
things and you omit the things that are
key um
do you have some further comments
what about this gentleman's question why
don't we finish answering them
i i've uh another question that is the
the picture of richard nixon that
appears
on the screen and and uh that we've
talked about inside washington there are
considerable amount of people in middle
america who think he's he was a good
president
good man
nice man what does your personal
experience say about
this man was he a villain who created
this i'd like to answer that it it has
always astounded me that with all the
coverage watergate got
print media and tv
so many americans don't seem to get it
that richard nixon directed every
activity in that white house despite the
fact that he says
and he never said anything but this that
he that that he made some mistakes some
errors in judgment and he leaves it
there the implica that he's trying to
imply that
his mistake was that he
came to the rescue of his young zealous
aides that he was preoccupied with the
affairs of state while his
aides went out and and and uh took part
in all these shenanigans and that is not
the case haldeman and richard nixon were
the co-conspirators
and that changed a little bit in april
of 73 but and i i can't document that
but it is true that's the way the white
house operated nothing happened that
richard nixon didn't okay nothing and
it's preposterous to think
that anything of the magnitude of a
break-in of the democratic national
committee headquarters
didn't come from richard it preposterous
it could not happen i would stake my
life on that i mean that's how
that's how he directed everything and
that was the point of my testimony
before the judiciary committee showed
that he was a detailed guy he was not
floating around
uh
uh unconcerned with what was going on at
the committee to re-elect dan i know you
have something but i want to get a
couple of other questions in go ahead
thank you um as you can tell i'm fairly
young and was my mom said she spoon fed
me through the hearing something she now
regrets because i've developed into a
full-fledged sort of watergate junkie
i've been researching it for some time
and i want to thank discovery channel
for bringing this panel together because
for people like me this is on the order
of those those explosions happening on
jupiter or
a beatles reunion or something like that
but i would like to uh first of all just
a quick comment from mr mccord frank
sturgis did say in 1975 quoted it does
not take a brain surgeon to see that
watergate was a cia setup but i really
would like to address
unfortunately and i'll try to keep a
brief lengthy question to miss percy
and also to brian lapping if he's
available
uh well he will be okay in the second
moderating the next panel okay you can
consider that a continuation that's okay
um we all know that there's been a lot
of sort of revisionist sort of stuff
written about watergate and i'm not
going to get into
how accurate is or isn't uh we all could
see too that uh this series tells the
so-called conventional story of
watergate in effect rejected the
conspiracy theories and he began work in
june 1992 and hired an eminent historian
stanley cutler who i see sitting there
to uh to help you tell this story
and you've said that you tried to look
at the
revisionist stories that they just
didn't stand up
however i'm holding
in my hands three items
which i've
photocopied and highlighted i'm willing
to distribute to anybody here where did
you learn that line about holes here in
my hand
senator mccarthy wheeling west virginia
was where i picked it up
um
and the three items consist of number
one the proposal to the bbc
that the producers originally submitted
which exactly mirrors the table of
contents of some of these revisionist
books i'm holding the correspondence
between brian lapping and the authors of
one of these revisionist books which
shows
that they offered him quite a bit of
money one of these revisionists to come
aboard as a historical consultant they
pursued him for seven months before
hiring dr cutler
and said uh i'm convinced we will make
the series you want made
we want to tell the post dean
post-woodward story to the world there's
no substitute for a relationship with
you and finally i'm holding transcripts
of the telephone discussions between mr
lapping
and one of the authors of these
revisionist books in which she not only
denigrates the mental faculties of
professor cutler but suggests that mr
dean is a liar and uses those words now
i would like to know your reaction i
would like to know why you pursued these
revisionists for seven months to offer
them all sorts of money agreed with
their thesis wholeheartedly and it says
rather late we've come upon your book
and thought mighty these chaps have done
some amazing work i and my colleagues
have all read it we all think that the
quality of your research is outstanding
etc etc etc do you feel like addressing
this thank you
well i think it's really brian who would
want to address this and totally out of
order
is the machine working i'd like to stand
up where the camera can see you i mean
this is tv man
i have i have to begin answering this
question by a very simple confession
we are journalists
and we are terribly excited by the idea
of getting new information
and a book was published that appeared
to contain striking new information
about watergate and i was very excited
and so were some of my colleagues but
i'd like to take a step back from that
earlier because the idea for doing this
series came to us from fred emery fred
had been the washington correspondent of
the times during watergate and he said
this is a story worth retelling and
norma and i replied
i hate to use such crude language i
won't use such crude language we said
fred absolutely not it's a dead story
we'd never succeed in selling this
who wants to hear a 20 year old story
that has been regurgitated in 250 books
and so fred who was pretty determined
left us thinking we were mad and we
thought he was mad and then we found a
book silent coup which seemed to have
amazing new insights and it's absolutely
true what you've just read out um fred
and the colleague and i flew to florida
to meet len kolodny one of the authors
of silent coup
and i was very impressed with the
material that they had discovered and so
we put a proposal to the bbc and the
discovery channel to pursue the content
of their book and it's quite right i
said to them that we wanted to pay them
to be consultants to the project and
indeed one of them was paid one of the
two authors of that book was paid to be
a consultant to the project
but gradually as norma and fred and paul
mitchell here and the remaining members
of their team
worked their way through the detail in
that book they found it simply wasn't
true right well i'm sorry that i can't
say about all the detail i couldn't say
that about key incidents which seemed to
them to be turning points and they came
back to me in london and said brian you
have sold a completely false bill of
goods
and there's a subsequent document which
isn't one that's in your hands which is
a document that i wrote to the bbc and
the discovery channel reporting on the
first stage of the research done by this
very high quality team of journalists
that we had sent to washington and
around the united states
and it was entitled confessions of a
switch salesman i had to say that the
original bill of goods that we had
submitted to the bbc and the discovery
channel was unsound and i was very sorry
about it we had worked extremely hard to
stand it up
and i have to say as a matter of fact
that on the first visit that we paid to
florida and fred and i flew back
together in an airplane fred emery here
and i'm accustomed in these airplanes
it's pretty uncomfortable that on the
return flight from america to europe i'm
accustomed to getting a little sleep the
only occasion in which i did not get a
single minute sleep was that flight back
fred spent the entire time going through
with me the details that already he was
beginning to suspect were wrong with
that revisionist version we didn't
abandon them we retained them as
consultants because we wanted to check
every aspect of the story and norma and
fred and paul kept at it testing the
evidence and the reason we produced the
story we did which you dismiss as the
conventional version is that having
checked everything repeatedly we came to
the conclusion that the version that sam
dash had established with quite a lot of
work over all those years seemed to be
true and may i had one sentence and that
then i'll sit down there's a moment
which you've seen this morning when sam
dash went out with jim hamilton having
just learned of the existence of the
tapes to see john dean that was going to
prove as sandesh said in
explaining why he went out whether john
dean was going to be deeply embarrassed
by the discovery that a taping system
existed or whether he was going to be
delighted and for me that is the turning
point
that little incident which you've seen
this morning the turning point in our
judgment as to whether we should pursue
the revisionist story or sam dash's
story and the fact was dean was
delighted to discover there was a taping
system the taping system confirmed what
he had been telling the senate inquiry
and we've since checked a great many of
the details not me the production team
norma and fred and company paul
they've checked a great many of the
details of what was said in evidence
against the documents the tapes and the
transcripts of the tapes and what stands
up is that story
and there's this is no secret i mean
i've written it twice in the daily
telegram and the times higher
educational supplements so this whole
story is in your packets yeah
it is not for me or for any of us to
knock anybody else's work or anybody
else's book and i think brian may have
gone a little bit far in saying things
were wrong uh we've found they just
weren't true and so on what norma and
paul mitchell and i found in doing our
researches was that this did not tie
into watergate
all the evidence in that book that we
looked at
fascinating much of it
incredible a lot of it
but we couldn't tie it right down to the
watergate break-in and what had led to
that and that was why we didn't pursue
it is that right
and the authors of that book had a
taping system of their own it turns out
because they interviewed me on the phone
and turned out later i heard
as part of a suit followed by john dean
against the publisher and authors of the
book for libel as part of found out that
they had talked to me on the phone and
taped that phone up conversation without
asking me so we go on and on and on next
dan could i answer that one question of
the reporter who made the statement
about yes go ahead yes
the reporter who asked the question made
the statement that um frank sturgis said
this was a watergate operation for the
cia operation anybody
including sam dash who has ever dealt
with frank sturgis in any investigative
agency in washington will tell you he is
a pathologic liar there goes another
libel suit okay
he's he's in the company he's in the
company of oliver stone jim garrison and
your good friend fletcher prouty
fletcher is not a pathological liar but
he's a liar
bam
thank you
i have a question from mr dean
uh my name is kathleen monday i was a
secretary to the so-called white house
plumbers
uh and my questions are twofold now the
first one is when did you find out about
the special telephone that was installed
in room 16
in the plumber's office
and what went through your mind when the
fbi found out that the telephone number
was listed in my name
and that they wanted to talk to me and
want you to bring me back from europe
i believe you're in the series as a
matter of fact uh in one of the
programs i'm not sure which one i
learned about the
the telephone as a result of the fbi's
investigation
and they had picked up in in their
um
checking of uh
mr hunt's calls howard hunt's calls that
there was this other telephone
and with the
when we learned that
the concern was that someone would
get a hold of you and no one knew what
you did or did not know
and the
ellsberg's dr ellsworth or dr ellsberg's
uh uh psychiatrist
break-in as you know was one of the now
now know was one of the reasons that uh
much of the cover-up of watergate was of
such concern because of the parallels
so that's really when when we learned
about uh you're having
the uh the telephone
and the fact that you were out of the
country rather than have someone just
sort of blindside you
uh that's when fred feeling came to get
you
could i ask you a nitpicking question
how what airline did you fly back from
london then
i believe it was pan american right it's
wrong in the movie or in their series
we have a british airways plate but
sir well it's a bbc production
[Laughter]
thank you um
john dean mr butterfield it's a pleasure
to have the opportunity of asking you
one more question
i'm ray thornton and
we talked while i was on the judiciary
committee
presented to the judiciary committee was
documentary evidence
indicating that transcripts of the
earlier watergate break-in
were being transmitted to the white
house and were being rejected as being
incomplete we had initials
indicating that those documents from the
first watergate break-in
were going to the white house and that
the second break-in the one that was
apprehended resulted from the
material being presented not being
sufficient i would like to ask either of
you if you know whether uh there were
conversations to confirm that
documentary so can you say who you are
i'm ray thornton i'm a member of
congress i was on the judiciary
committee and i will be on your second
panel but i won't have a chance to ask
john and mr butterfield whether the
second break-in was ordered as by the
president as a result of the incomplete
data from the first breaking are you a
congressman are you referring to
transcripts that were prepared by the
bugs that were placed in the dnc
i believe that is correct well i i don't
and jim mccord would be a better witness
on this but i don't i don't believe that
they had a taping system of any kind i
think it was a rather informal
note taking but jim you correct me okay
please are you speaking of tapes or
transcripts let me transcript
transcripts resulting from the first
break
let me give you the mechanics al baldwin
at the howard johnson
listened to the conversations prepared a
transcript verbatim were irrelevant he
felt relevant
he gave them to me i gave him to gordon
liddy or in one case he took some
transcripts when i was out of town
delivered them to the guard there who
gave them to gordon liddy
liddy told me he gave them to john
mitchell and that magruder saw them so
those men saw them now
my understanding
i have no direct knowledge is that in
turn mitchell or magruder
passed them over to haldeman's office
that is to getting strong
by initials well right now i i have
never seen any of the transcripts or
summaries uh and i don't think alex has
either uh to my knowledge i've never
heard that can i just add something
because we had the evidence and
there were actually photographs with
thumb
on them and there were transcripts that
sally harmony lady secretary transcribed
from baldwin and that we did get the
information that when mitchell saw it he
thought and using his term was a bunch
of [ __ ]
and told liddy to go back in again and
do it better and liddy ordered it back
again because the mitchell had
criticized them but they weren't
transcripts typed from a tape they were
trump those they were notes
but they were the result of
eavesdropping the first equipment that
had already been installed so this was
the second uh effort to penetrate right
thank you congressman i'm afraid
no i was we've run way over our a lot of
time for this panel for which i will
offer no apologies
uh how to connect i had a a wonderful
time and if you've learned anything from
this you will have learned that there
was some president who once said that
one year of watergate was enough we
should stop wallowing in watergate
and i suspect that with constant new
revelations coming out is that we will
wallow in watergate for yet a long time
to come thank you very much
[Applause]
well i i'd like to add our thanks to
this panel it's extraordinary and please
know that to the extent that they choose
they will be available to
interact with you during the second
panel as well
so
i'd like to very briefly tell you that
the next
bit of tape will be summaries of our
fourth and fifth episodes
entitled massacre and impeachment
and then we will assemble another
distinguished panel
to take your questions and offer their
reminiscences
so if i could i'd like to roll our
second tape segment
next a tribute to former senator george
mcgovern
last month the national archives hosted
a symposium on the career of the former
south dakota senator
we'll hear from senator mcgovern
morris dees of the southern poverty law
center and vern newton fdr library
director
they discuss civil rights foreign policy
and the mcgovern 1972 presidential
campaign
the program's about two hours
for those that just came we went a
little over our last session and um
bill brandt's will be talking here in a
minute but we had a very interesting
discussion going on vietnam and george
mcgovern was sitting here and we were
talking about two wonderful papers by
larry berman and bob mann with a little
different
views and we wanted to give senator
mcgovern an opportunity to comment
before we get started with the next
session senator
[Applause]
well this program has been wonderful up
to this point as far as i'm
uh concerned i must confess i've had
times when i wondered if i was sitting
through a kind of a dress rehearsal for
my funeral
but uh
the the
the difference is that uh i can speak
back so far
and
i i was asked by doug if i would just
say a couple of words about
the papers this morning by professor
berman professor mann i'm going to make
it just very brief there were a couple
of questions raised here that
it might be useful for me to comment one
professor berman suggested that there
was a probability that we knew in the
senate
those of us who were dissenting about
the doubts
that existed in the minds of lyndon
johnson robert mcnamara and others which
have been coming out
in recent months the
only comment i can make on that is that
i had no hint
of any doubt in the minds of
president johnson
or secretary uh mcnamara quite the
contrary it always seemed to me that
they were firm
and unyielding and undeviating
in holding to the course that they had
set
in vietnam i doubt if senator fulbright
or others
had any inkling of the degree of doubt
that existed for example in the
president johnson's mind as early as 64
and 65 until these recent uh
materials have been
made available to us just in the last
few months i was astounded
to
read what
president johnson was saying his
dialogue with senator richard russell of
georgia just as i was astounded in
reading robert mcnamara's book
to learn of the doubts that he had
during this period so i just offered
that as a
clarification
point
on
the
thesis that
professor mann developed briefly about
why a senator
who was obviously as opposed to the war
as i was
was so
reluctant
to break
sharply
and dramatically with the administration
on that point i think the answer is the
the one that professor berman
suggested that i was trying
not to present a case that i thought
would be uh
quickly rejected as just too far from
the conventional wisdom i've found in
politics you have to do that regularly
you can't get
so far out in front that you lose
any kind of appeal to the people you're
trying to influence there was another
reason for being somewhat restrained
about criticism of the war in
1963 and 1964.
and that was my conviction that
president johnson was probably going to
carry on
the war policy until after
the 1964 presidential campaign
it seemed to me at the time that was why
he wanted the gulf of tonkin resolution
to take that issue out of the 64
presidential campaign senator goldwater
had been hammering him
for not accelerating the war especially
the aerial
bombardment and in the gulf of tonkin
resolution you had what seemed to be a
shrewd political move on the president's
part
to pull that issue out of partisan
politics by getting us all all of us on
record
on the same
resolution i never saw it at the time as
an endorsement of the war effort
i saw it as an endorsement of
what we were told was a measured
response on the part of the johnson
administration to what we were also told
was an unprovoked attack
on two american destroyers we later had
reason to question that
but at the time
it seemed like a way to uh
in a sense
make it less
profitable for senator goldwater to go
after the president on that issue that's
the way it was explained to us
by senator by senator fulbright and
others who were pressing for it on the
senate floor
there was also the feeling at that time
that we not only wanted to do nothing
that would exacerbate president
johnson's problems in the
64 presidential campaign
uh but also a feeling that you had to
kind of get the country back together
after the trauma of the kennedy
assassination here was a
a
experienced vice president suddenly
thrown into the presidency and a feeling
that at least through the coming
presidential campaign we all ought to
try to get behind him that was certainly
my view as a loyal
democrat but also as a patriotic
american it seemed to me that
was the course to follow
and i honestly believed
when we campaigned for president johnson
in 64 that he would stay with his pledge
and no wider war
we're not going north we're not going
south we're not going to send american
boys
to fight the battle that has to be
resolved by asian boys i swallowed all
of that whole
i thought that i knew
johnson well enough to think that his
major interest
was in domestic politics
in the great society
and that
the sooner he could
get this war
behind him the better so i was somewhat
uh astounded when i saw evidence shortly
after
that landslide victory of 64 that in
fact he was going to begin
escalating the war
and that is when senator church and i
and others became more
public and more vocal
finally coming around to the position
that the only way to stop this war was
to terminate the
uh funding uh for it
anyway those are some observations that
uh
as near as i can recall the mood of the
time i wanted to
lay on the record here today
[Applause]
hello i'm vern newton and as the program
notes i'm the director of the franklin d
roosevelt presidential library and also
the moderator for this afternoon panel
and just to clear up any confusion the
panel is actually beginning at the time
and the program is due to end
so i don't know how doug's going to
juggle all that but i'm sure he'll
figure out a way
our panel this afternoon the first
panels on mcgovern and the anti-war
movement by way of my own pedigree i
just note that some of us thought the
1972 mcgovern campaign was the sequel
because we were in chicago in 1968
and
at the time and the heat of all that was
going on the hope was that there was
still a rational sane alternative and
that was in the form of george mcgovern
and that would be the first ballot
alternative to the kennedy the
mccarthyites to the uncommitted what we
call the soft humps and uh and uh that
all went up in the smoke and uh
uh chaos and and blood of chicago but
nonetheless it was for many of us our
first association
uh certainly on a national scale with
george mcgovern and one that was very
inspiring
i went on and subsequently headed up the
vietnam moratorium committee in new york
and then
where we used to boast that we'd print
out millions and millions of leaflets
and hand them out at street corners in
all the five boroughs of new york and
throughout the state
and i became convinced that in the
course of that we were probably not
changing a single mind
and my mother who was the republican
county chairman out in iowa once
observed to me that no anti-war
protester had ever handed her a leaflet
or any or spoken to her about the war
so i packed my bags and moved out to des
moines iowa and opened up something
called the great plains moratorium
and which included the dakotas and
minnesota missouri and iowa and it was a
very exciting time and there we felt we
were changing
hearts and minds on
on the issue of the war but we also
decided after the spring of 1970 to
close the moratorium down that it had
done all that it could do that was a
highly debatable issue both within the
moratorium structure and from outside
and we did close it down and a few weeks
later nixon invaded cambodia and a lot
of people said uh that the fact that we
decided to disband the moratorium in
effect
was the green light for nixon to evade
cambodia i'd like to think that's true i
don't think there's any documentary
evidence that there is
i don't think we ever had quite that
influence but we ended up then in
washington a number of us working on the
mcgovern hatfield of amendment 10 the
war
in the spring of 1970 and by that time
it was also fairly obvious that rather
than protest solely in the streets that
there were political alternatives and
for me and for many of you in this room
that was the mcgovern for president
campaign in 1972 i just one story about
that i was
among the many things i did in that
campaign i was the representative for
senator mcgovern on the platform
committee some of you may remember that
was the first year the democratic party
held regional hearings around the
country prior to the convention so we
held platform hearings all over the
country in sioux falls south dakota as i
remember sioux city iowa new orleans san
francisco pittsburgh
and so on and one night we were in new
orleans and dick nustat harvard
professor was the temporary chairman of
that platform committee and we were all
meeting i mean the wallace people the
humphrey people everybody was we were
all pals by then and uh so we're all
going out to dinner together and we met
in in new stats uh hotel room to to go
from there for dinner and and nustat was
uh
on the phone back to the office of the
dnc and so he was talking and getting
messages and everything like that and
the very andy said what
what
well i'll be damned and he hung up the
phone and we all left the room and
headed for the elevator he was giving us
messages and then i said well what was
that last part about and he said oh the
damnedest thing i ever heard of they
caught five guys breaking into the
watergate last night
um so at any rate that was uh
that was some of uh my perspective on
those years and now to tell us what was
really happening during that campaign
and during those those
years we have two professors um
bill brands was introduced to you this
morning by
professor schlesinger he is at texas a m
university
he has a he's done a lot of work on lbj
as a book coming out on tr in a few
months and then after him we'll hear
from randall woods who's a professor at
the university of arkansas uh who's
going to talk about mcgovern in the
anti-war movement and professor woods
has written a book on bill fulbright and
has
now worked on a one volume work on lbj
so professor brown
thank you vern
one of the reasons i went into history
uh rather than political science or
journalism is that
i wasn't sure that i wanted to deal with
the subjects of my investigations
talking back to me
um
now i find myself
being preempted by the subject of my
investigation
who explain
why he did the things that i'm going to
try to explain that he did
well be that as it may um
i'm going to be talking about mcgovern
and lbj
the vietnam war didn't have to tear the
democratic party apart
if george mcgovern and lyndon johnson
had had their way it wouldn't have but
the war unleashed passions that were
larger than either man which is saying
something
obviously in the case of the fam
flamboyantly volcanic johnson but no
less surely in the case of the quietly
determined mcgovern
and mcgovern and johnson found
themselves caught in a riptide that left
one half of the party stranded on the
beach while the other was swept out to
sea
of course the renting wasn't confined to
the democratic party that same riptide
ran right through the american body
politic as a whole
in certain respects then the story of
mcgovern and lbj is the story of the
modern democratic party
of post-war liberalism and of the
precarious nature of the consensus on
who on which america's end of the cold
war rested
but it's also the story of how two men
who couldn't have disagreed more
strenuously on the defining issue of
their day could do so civilly even
constructively and therein i think lies
the lesson for our day
the story begins in
mcgovern was a representative from south
dakota who had two immediate goals the
first was to win election to the senate
the second was to get john kennedy
nominated and then elected to the
presidency
johnson the senate majority leader from
texas had a single overriding goal to
win the nomination and then the
presidency for himself
obviously these two sets of goals
weren't entirely compatible but mcgovern
and johnson being practical politicians
found enough common ground between them
for productive collaboration
indeed in june 1960 some sizable acreage
of that common ground was located along
the missouri river in south dakota where
the congressman and the senator each
swung a shovel to kick off construction
of the big band of dam the last in the
chain of great multiple purpose flood
control irrigation power projects that
span the geography of the upper missouri
valley and the history of public works
back to the beginning of the century
mcgovern introduced johnson in the
warmest terms
quote speaking not simply as a member of
his political party but as a student of
american history mcgovern said i regard
lyndon johnson as the most masterful
senate leader in our national history
in a technique he would employ again in
1968 then on behalf of bobby kennedy he
went on to clap johnson on the back
without quite embracing him
if events should bring senator johnson
into the white house he would go down in
history as one of our greatest
presidents when mcgovern entered these
remarks into the congressional record
along with johnson's speech on the
occasion johnson responded in kind
i cherish your regard for me he wrote i
hope you know that i want to do
everything i can to reciprocate your
warm friendship
johnson offered to campaign for mcgovern
but knowing that he and kennedy weren't
the most popular men in mcgovern's home
state he declared george i'll come to
south dakota and campaign for you or
against you whichever you think will get
you the most votes
between the force and the against
mcgovern narrowly lost his senate bid in
what turned out to be a very republican
season in south dakota this left him
prospectively without a job
naturally he began casting about one of
his casts landed on johnson's desk dear
lyndon he wrote while those recurrent
for all those returns from cook county
were still steaming congratulations on
your magnificent victory the election of
you and senator kennedy made it possible
for south dakota to rejoice even while
we were suffering a personal defeat
mcgovern went on to signal his
availability i should like you to know
that i would be honored to fill any role
in the new administration which you
gentlemen think i am capable of handling
johnson was willing
the loss of george mcgovern to the
senate is i think a really serious one
he commiserated i regret it more than i
can say
he went on nevertheless i know your
efforts on behalf of our party and our
country are only beginning
and that you and i will be working
together on many matters in the days to
come
mcgovern wanted to be secretary of
agriculture and many influential
supporters wanted him to get the job but
orville freeman had greater pull and
mcgovern wound up as director of the
food for peace program as we heard
earlier
although he remained in this job for
just two years his interest in foreign
aid especially food and agricultural aid
lasted throughout his career and in this
area he and johnson generally saw eye to
eye not always by any means after
johnson became president and mcgovern
won election to the senate mcgovern took
exception to what he and many other
liberals saw as johnson's strong arming
of india during that country's famine
crisis of 1965-66
when johnson kept india on what was
called a short tether in aid in order to
encourage reforms of the indian
agriculture and distribution system the
experience frayed many nerves johnson
grumbled in his memoirs about mcgovern's
criticism of his india aid policy but it
turned out well in the end when india
agreed to to reforms that did indeed
contribute to that country's eventual
self-sufficiency in food and johnson
released the wheat he had been holding
back
other issues between the two men were
more complicated
johnson was pleased at mcgovern's senate
victory in 1962 and he threw out the
hospitality mat at once welcome to
washington
he declared lady bird and i are looking
forward to seeing you in the coming year
the vice president invited the freshman
senator to a reception at his house on
52nd street come early and stay late he
insisted
the good feeling remained when johnson
assumed the presidency 11 months later
upon kennedy's assassination and it
disposed mcgovern to support the new
president nine months after that when
johnson laid the tonkin gulf resolution
before congress mcgovern was already
voicing reservations regarding american
policy in vietnam but during the summer
of 1964 party solidarity in the face of
the hardline candidacy of barry
goldwater dictated closing ranks behind
the president with some misgivings
mcgovern accepted the assurances of the
administration and j william fulbright
chairman of the senate foreign relations
committee that the measure was necessary
to demonstrate the resolve of the united
states to resist aggression in southeast
asia
mcgrovern would later call his vote on
the tonkin measure quote the vote i most
regret i should have known better he
lamented
mcgovern's support for the president
remained solid through the election that
autumn
lyndon is no longer trying for just 50
states now he's going for overkill
mcgovern declared in a campaign press
release pointing to four farm bills that
had passed by a dozen votes or less in
the house he went on and we need a
little more overkill capacity in
congress
well overkill is what the democrats got
in the 1964 election perhaps more than
was good for them or the country
fortified by his landslide victory
johnson escalated the war in vietnam
shortly after his january 1965
inauguration
sustained heavy bombing began in
february followed by a major increase in
american ground forces during the second
half of the year
mcgovern's misgivings grew but he didn't
want to break with the administration
without giving johnson a chance to
defend his actions he called the white
house in march to request a meeting with
the president johnson aide bill moyers
urged the president to talk to the
senator
bill thinks this would be helpful jack
valenti explained to johnson mcgovern
will be making a lot of speeches in the
next few weeks
mcgovern arrived for the oval office
meeting with a prepared position paper
but johnson cut him short don't give me
another goddamn history lesson he said
i've got a drawer full of memos from
mansfield i don't need a lecture on
where we went wrong i've got to deal
with where we are now
during the next half hour mcgovern
managed to make his principal points the
administration he said like its
predecessors was seeking military
solutions to what it based was a
political problem the united states
should set aside its emphasis on
alliances and concentrate on building up
the non-aligned states of southeast asia
at the moment the president had the
support of the american people but this
wouldn't last if the country maintained
its present course in vietnam the
president should seek a negotiated
settlement one that would appeal to the
same noble sentiments that undergirded
his campaign for civil rights at home
this was where the administration and
the country could put american ideals
into effect
johnson would have liked nothing better
than to agree but he simply didn't
didn't think that negotiations would
produce a satisfactory settlement
yet he seems to have impressed mcgovern
that he sincerely desired peace
this impression or maybe it was the
lobbying of arthur schlesinger and
others persuaded the senator not to
attack the administration for its
dubious handling of certain aspects of
the dominican crisis during the spring
of 1965 even as other democratic
senators
and leaders notably fulbright were
bailing out
without minimizing his differences with
the administration on vietnam mcgovern
still managed to sound supportive in
september 1965 he delivered a strong
speech affirming johnson's policies now
to be sure the largest part of the
speech lauda johnson's handling of
domestic affairs the medicare bill the
elementary and secondary education act
the voting rights act to name only the
most recent measures sponsored by the
administration represented what mcgovern
called a more outstanding legislative
record than any other president in our
national history including the
heretofore unmatched 100 days of the
late president roosevelt
the historian in mcgovern wasn't content
to confine himself to american history
he approvingly quoted a remark by max
lerner regarding johnson that quote
nothing like his magnitude and
effectiveness as a lawmaker has been
seen since hammurabi and sometimes i
wonder whether even the man from babylon
could have kept up the pace of the man
from texas
regarding foreign affairs mcgovern
averred that the problems the nation
faced in that arena were more complex
and less responsive to the leadership of
any single head of government he
acknowledged that he had not agreed with
everything johnson had done regarding
southeast asia quote but we all know
that the president is working tirelessly
to find a satisfactory solution to the
tragic war in vietnam and to end other
threats to world peace i have never
doubted the president's commitment to
peace and i believe that when the full
record of his administration is in it
will be a record on the side of peace
including an end to the war in vietnam
johnson read mcgovern's remarks as
carefully as he read everything that was
said in his old stomping ground and in
this case he liked what he read he
directed larry o'brien to relay that he
was quote deeply grateful for mcgovern's
support three months later he took the
occasion of a dinner given in honor of
mcgovern to send congratulations quote i
fully share the pride which must warm
the hearts of your fellow south dakotans
as they honor you tonight
and i look forward with confidence to
our continued association in america's
behalf
but the association at least the kind
johnson desired wasn't to last
early in january 1966 following a
personal visit to vietnam mcgovern
informed the white house that he was
going to give a speech in the senate
criticizing administration policy
johnson tried to head off the attack
i do want you to know once more the
president replied that there is
literally no place i would not go and no
person i would not meet in the interest
of a decent and peaceful settlement in
vietnam
but mcgovern was not to be deflected he
challenged the central premises of the
bombing campaign currently in temporary
abandons citing several reasons why
bombing was counterproductive in the
first place it was obviously failing to
halt the flow of troops and supplies
from the north to the south second it
cost america dearly in lives lost and
pilots captured third it tended to unite
the north vietnamese behind their
government fourth it was blackening
america's reputation around the world
mcgovern went on to attack the
fundamental premises of the war effort
he denied that vietnam was vital to
american interests and he quoted such
military experts as matthew ridgway and
douglas macarthur regarding the folly of
fighting a land war in asia the united
states had reached a crucial turning
point he declared quote the war in
vietnam will either begin to move this
year toward a peaceful resolution
however slow and uncertain the road or
it will degenerate into a deepening
morass that may claim the lives of our
sons and the sons of asia for years to
come
yet even in distancing himself from
administration policies mcgovern took
pains to credit johnson's motives
i am deeply grateful he said to
president johnson who carries the
heaviest burden of us all that he has
stopped the bombing of north vietnam in
spite of the objections of some of his
advisors i am deeply grateful too for
the president's vigorous efforts in
recent days to find a diplomatic
breakthrough
mcgovern quoted a statement by johnson
reiterating the president's desire for
peace and he concluded
i have the faith to believe that however
difficult the task president johnson has
the will and the capacity to achieve
this purpose and achieving it to win
that high place in history that blessing
of immortality
reserved for those who make peace among
men and nations
again johnson was listening when
mcgovern spoke the senator's speech sent
the administration into full damage
control mode johnson ordered the
pentagon to formulate a rebuttal as jack
veleni explained in a memo to robert
mcnamara which included a copy of
mcgovern's speech quote the president
wanted you to have it and to get answers
to each of these assertions and
suggestions so that we can be able to
answer them
although the press made much of this
break in democratic ranks mcgovern
quietly informed the white house that
rumors of his defection were greatly
exaggerated he had been quoted in
newsweek as questioning the
administration's peaceful intentions
this he said was utterly untrue i have
never made any such statement
he told bill moyers i think the
administration's peace offensive is
genuine i applaud it and i will support
it in every way i can
here he added a qualifier that probably
vitiated his disclaimer when johnson
read it while of course reserving my own
independent views on the vietnam problem
as a whole
yet he concluded with another
affirmation of support let me express my
deep appreciation to the president and
to those of you around him for what i
believe to be a thorough going and
genuine effort to reach a peaceful
settlement
yet for all his a vowels of faith and
the president's sincerity it was
becoming increasingly obvious to
mcgovern that the administration's
approach to vietnam was fundamentally
and tragically misguided i'm just
appalled by lbj's handling of vietnam he
told drew pearson it seems to me to be
the most incredible and monstrous
mistake in our national history he added
perhaps with some regret at his own
actions
who would have guessed it in the 1964
presidential race
with the passing months the president
and the senator drifted farther apart
mcgovern received no further invitations
to the white house although he had the
feeling that johnson was keeping track
of him as indeed johnson was the boss
gets wild about him sometimes harry
mcpherson observed joseph califano
johnson took every opportunity to perry
mcgovern's thrust against administration
policy in september 1967 mcgovern
insurgent in the into the congressional
record a letter from northwestern
university economist robert eisner
opposing a tax increase to cover the
cost of the war in vietnam the
administration responded via letter from
gardner ackley the chairman of the
council of economic advisers explaining
why eisner was wrong ackley added
it is not my purpose to argue with you
or eisner about the merits of the
vietnam war however i do feel very
strongly that to advocate bad fiscal
policy as a means of protest against the
war is a disservice both to legitimate
protest and to sound economics
a month later the white house caught
wind of reports that mcgovern was trying
to discourage attendance by top
administration officials at a conference
in rapid city sponsored by the
democratic national committee
quote i assume he is to be present for
the meeting as skeptical de vera pearson
remarked of mcgovern whether or not he
has been trying to push us out it would
seem dangerous to leave the meeting to
his tender mercies for defense of
administration policies
well the meeting in question wasn't left
entirely to government to mcgovern's
tender mercies interior secretary stuart
udall held up the administration's end
by itself this didn't assuage white
house fears especially since the
highlighted speaker invited at
mcgovern's special request was eugene
mccarthy
what did alleviate administration fears
at least somewhat was mcgovern's
unexpected announcement of support for
johnson's re-election in 1968.
the announcement was unexpected the fact
of mcgovern's support was not
not surprisingly the question of a
challenge to johnson's reelection from
within the democratic party preoccupied
the white house as opposition to the war
mounted various liberal individuals and
groups were organizing around plans to
dump johnson in 1968. whether these
would amount to anything kept
administration staffers awake nights and
with their ears to the ground days but
as of the middle of 1967 white house
officials judged that opponents of the
war really had nowhere else to go as the
cooler heads among them would surely
recognize to the extent that the peace
movement made inroads among democrats
the republicans would be less inclined
to nominate a candidate determined to
end the war the gop front-runner at the
moment was richard nixon hardly a
peacemonger did the peaceniks want to
elect him
for this reason the white house wasn't
particularly worried robert kennedy had
been criticizing the president's
handling of the war especially the draft
but a memo from the white house staff to
johnson in august 1967
predicted that kennedy would go into new
hampshire and campaign quote against the
draft and for president johnson
the memo went on quote any other dump
johnson moves within the democratic
party will hurt the peace efforts
because no responsible delegates would
allow their names to be connected with
the drive against a democratic president
george mcgovern according to this memo
fit the profile
white house staffers had reason to
believe that mcgovern along with wayne
morse was behind a recent retreat of the
americans for democratic action from a
dump johnson feeler put forward earlier
it reflects their feeling this memo
declared that personal attacks on the
president would be politically
disastrous
the ted offensive knocked all bets off
the table half the country it now seemed
thought johnson's policy was too rigidly
aggressive and the other half thought it
was too flaccid but almost no one
thought it was right
all of a sudden mccarthy's challenge
didn't seem quite so quixotic as became
apparent in new hampshire johnson's
march 31 announcement that he would not
seek re-election suddenly open the field
to anyone who might want to jump in a
free-for-all impended
another man might have gloated that the
president had been driven from office
and plenty did but mcgovern quickly set
to work trying to hold the party
together in a sioux falls speech in
which he endorsed bobby kennedy without
actually endorsing him mcgovern inserted
a line lauding the president quote may i
add that president johnson has taken on
new stature and dignity by the mag by
the magnanimous manner in which he
placed his view of the vietnam issue
above his desires for re-election
johnson appreciated the gesture six
months later after the worst summer and
fall the democratic party had suffered
in living memory johnson sent mcgovern a
note of congratulations on his
re-election and mcgovern responded in
kind quote as you come to the end of
your presidential service i do wish you
and your family godspeed in the years
ahead
four years later the positions of the
two men were reversed
johnson led the democrats into the
election campaign of 1972.
excuse me mcgovern led the democrats in
the election campaign of 1972 johnson
watched from the sidelines at his ranch
in the texas hill country considering
the central anti-war theme of his
candidacy many observers expected
mcgovern to keep his distance from
johnson and vice versa many who didn't
know johnson guessed that he wouldn't
want anything to do with a man whose
campaign focused on a repudiation of the
centerpiece of johnson's foreign policy
but those who knew johnson recognized
that his loyalty to the democratic party
ran deeper than his antipathy to the
communists of north vietnam
i believe the democratic party best
serves the needs of the people johnson
declared after mcgovern won the
nomination i believe that when i entered
public life i believe it today therefore
i intend to support the 1972 democratic
ticket i shall vote for george mcgovern
and sergeant striver for president and
vice president of the united states
the former president didn't disguise the
quote widely differing views
he and the nominee had especially on
foreign affairs but that needn't prevent
cooperation quote the democratic party
can come can accommodate disagreement
the senator senator and i can be candid
about our differences without being at
cross purposes in our objectives
when mcgovern visited the ranch a few
days later johnson was
characteristically more candid i know
you think i'm crazy as hell on vietnam i
think you are
so let's omit that instead let's talk
politics which is exactly what they did
and which as i said at the beginning of
my remarks is the moral of their story
thank you
[Applause]
i'm very glad to be invited to
participate in this conference it it's
been very profitable uh for for me
particularly lunch uh with senator
mcgovern and and senator bob dole and
the other distinguished guests
i teach at the university of arkansas
the main campuses in fayetteville
and
president clinton recently decided to
locate the presidential library in
little rock which is not the main campus
so i feel that i had a free hand so i
approached senator dole informing him of
this and asking him if he would consider
donating his papers to the university of
arkansas
he said he'd take it under consideration
the activist foreign policies of the
post-world war ii uh
period that produced the war in
southeast asia
were a product of the melding of
conservative anti-communists who defined
national security in terms of bases and
alliances and who were basically
xenophobic
and
liberal reformers who were determined to
safeguard the national interest by
exporting democracy and facilitating
overseas economic development
george mcgovern played a key role in
breaking up that unholy alliance in
destroying the consensus that supported
u.s involvement in vietnam
mcgovern's dissent from the war uh in
southeast asia and his critique of
america's cold war policies were
products of his education his unique
personal traits the era in which he
lived and the political culture that
nurtured him and served as a vehicle for
his ambition
george mcgovern comes from a long line
of prairie dissenters robert lafollette
william borah gerald nye
are among the more noteworthy
he shared the populist and progressives
fear of concentrated wealth and private
monopolies
his phd dissertation at northwestern was
a scathing indictment of coal mine
owners in the events leading up to the
ludlow massacre in colorado in 1914
it's hardly surprising then that the
junior senator from south dakota became
an adamant foe of the military
industrial complex
in a speech in the senate on august 2nd
1963 he proposed a reduction of 5
billion dollars in a military budget of
53.6 billion dollars
it's hard for us to believe to realize
in the post-cold war period how
inflammatory that proposal was
beginning in 1969 mcgovern acted as a
vociferous and relentless critic of the
proposed anti-ballistic missile system
then being pushed by the nixon
administration
like j william full wright and other
anti-imperialists he argued that the
continuing build-up of nuclear
stockpiles far beyond the point where
the major adversaries in the cold war
could wipe each other out was absolutely
absurd
mccovern's vehement opposition to the
war in vietnam even led him to embrace a
version of the merchants of death thesis
it seems to me wrong that while some
americans risked their lives on the
battlefield he observed in 1968 a few
turn extremely generous profits by
supplying the weapons of war and by
exerting political pressure for newer
bigger and more expensive weapons
like his progressive forebears mcgovern
argued that the political power
structure should concentrate on perfect
perfecting domestic society broadening
and deepening democracy eliminating
poverty and promoting social justice
the cold war and obsessive
anti-communism he argued were diverting
america's attention from a much needed
social agenda and the war in vietnam was
eroding the foundations of republicanism
democracy is based on a fundamental
respect for the dignity and worth of
human life he told the senate and the
funneling of 10 percent of the gross
national product into weapons of
destruction was undermining that spirit
he indicted the war in vietnam for
diverting monies as he put it urgently
needed to rebuild our decaying explosive
riot ridden city slums to strengthen
educational recreational and employment
opportunities in rural america
to clean up our polluted rivers and
streams
it would be ironic indeed he said if we
devoted so heavy a proportion of our
resources to the pacification of vietnam
that we were unable to pacify los
angeles chicago and harlem
but unlike lafallette borah and nye the
junior senator from south dakota was not
a pure isolationist
he agreed with henry wallace whom he had
supported in 1948 that the united states
ought to share its largest with the less
fortunate of the world
he insisted that the alliance for
progress rather than military aid to
dictatorial regimes would defuse what he
called the dynamite on our doorstep
that is the revolutionary nationalism
which was providing the soviets and
chinese communists an ideological
opening in the americas
on june 17 1965 mcgovern introduced
comprehensive legislation to put the us
in the forefront of an effort to end
hunger in the world
as you've heard it's come the basis of
an administration it became the basis of
an administration-backed bill the food
for peace act of 1966.
such a position made political sense
from the representative of a farm state
but mcgovern went further arguing that
the alleviation of hunger overseas what
was both a moral obligation and a
strategic necessity for the united
states
hunger he said is the companion of
communism food is freedom's first line
of defense
in many ways george mcgovern's critique
of american foreign policy paralleled
that of the new left which was in the
main a revolt among american
intellectuals and college students
against liberal politics
like tom hayden i have stone and stalton
lind mcgovern railed against the
military-industrial complex his argument
that in its obsessive anti-communism the
united states had everywhere arrayed its
power against indigenous revolution thus
identifying itself with a dying
colonialism parallel the soft
revisionism of such young historians as
thomas patterson
at times mcgovern even flirted with
economic determinism
for those businessmen to whom a large
portion of the world represents an
essential area for expansion he wrote
communism presents a dangerous challenge
to capitalist ground rules
i have long been concerned he said over
the growth of huge industries who claim
whose claim to existence
and uh and to profits has been based on
the insecurity that has characterized
nearly all of the 20th century
because of their size their influence is
far out of proportion to their concern
for public interest
mcgovern's frank portrayal of the united
states as an avaricious empire certainly
conformed to the writings of william
appleman williams and gabriel coco
he believed moreover uh like other uh
proponents of the new left adherence to
the left in participatory democracy he
was no elitist like j william fulbright
he championed the right of personal
dissent sympathizing with those young
men who had to choose between serving in
a war they did not believe in going to
jail or relinquishing their citizenship
mcgovern continually refused to be
identified with anti-war activities that
he believed to be beyond the pale
by participatory democracy he meant the
exercise of the vote by every eligible
man and woman not direct control of the
decision-making process by the masses
it was this belief coupled with a
conviction deduced from the 1968
democratic national convention that his
party had been captured by
representatives of the
military-industrial complex by
anti-communist ideologues and by
political bosses that led him to
champion a movement to restore the
democratic party to its grassroots
he took a dim view of protests and
demonstrations for the most part in a
speech at the university of wisconsin in
the fall of 1965 he branded draft card
burnings as immature impractical and
illegal
though he participated
in several demonstrations he believed
that they were distractions from the
main task
mcgovern refused to take part in the
april 24 1971 march on washington
only persistent effort to secure public
support for congressional action to cut
off funding for this war this year can
reel can yield a real result he wrote an
anti-war activist in 1971.
that is why i have been concerned that
so much attention has been focused on
the demonstrations and so little on the
hard work that is necessary to build
solid public support for mcgovern
hatfield and other measures
his dissent tended to be private
individual
as a man of conventional morality and
conservative personal lifestyle he
feared chaos
a breakdown in the political and social
order might very well lead to a
disintegration of the moral order
in a 1970 article entitled the folly of
undisciplined radicalism mcgovern
condemned tom hayden and huey newton
jerry rubin and abby hoffman
what i personally resent most about some
american radicals he wrote is their
willingness to jeopardize the chances of
constructive change by flaunting their
own foolish and destructive tactics
religion
was a key element in george mcgovern's
descent
his father as you all know was a
wesleyan methodist minister and for a
brief period after the war he himself
attended seminary
like william lloyd garrison he believed
that man was bound by a higher law in
his 1968 speech against the draft he
reminded his listeners that the western
powers had prosecuted german military
and civilian officials after world war
ii for obeying their government rather
than their consciences
in his 1967 senate speech on vietnam
mcgovern quoted virgil
easy as the descent to hell
night and day the gates stand open
but to recline the slope and escape to
the other air
this indeed is a task
like j william fulbright mcgovern
believed in dissent for dissent's sake
america he said was not a completed
institution a particular geographical
location or even a collection of people
it was a process quote a method of
liberating the skill and energy of
individual men
the highest paid patriotism he declared
in 1967 does not lie in blindly
accepting the ideas of the past or the
policies of the present
but rather in the willingness to
question and challenge all that we are
and all that we do
in this way the united states could he
said correct our errors before they
overwhelm us
open debate would satisfy the intensely
conservative desire to keep us faithful
to our own ideals
it is tempting he said in the midst of
immediate dangers and difficulties to
sacrifice principles and even liberties
to the necessities of the moment
not surprisingly not surprisingly then
mcgovern saw himself as something of a
bellwether a visionary who would stake
out the correct position and then wait
for the more politically timid to follow
he was proud of the fact that only he
and jennings randolph voted for his 1963
amendment to cut appropriations for
defense research and procurement by 10
percent
he was also proud of the fact that in
september of that year he became the
first u.s senator to come out public
publicly against the war in vietnam
in a 1969 speech to clergy and layman
concerned about vietnam he quoted ralph
waldo emerson
if a single man plant himself on his
convictions and then abide the huge
world will come round to him
there is no doubt for most of his
descending career george mcgovern was
swimming against the political tide at
both the national and the state level
like fulbright mccoy mcgovern detested
joe mccarthy and mccarthyism
despite his fundamentalist religious
upbringing or perhaps because of it the
south dakotan distrusted individuals who
claim to hear the voice of god whispered
in their ear and distrusted true
believers who placed ideology above
human life
mccarthy was a pure opportunist he
realized but those who flocked to his
banner were anti-communist zealot
zealots intolerant xenophobic ignorant
it was they who constituted the real
threat to his american way of life
thus did he regard his 1960 senatorial
contest against the red baiting carl
munt as a contest between good and evil
in a 1966 senate speech he quoted
learned hand
the spirit of liberty is the spirit
which is not too sure that it is right
the spirit of liberty is the spirit
which seeks to understand the minds of
other men and women
the spirit of liberty is the spirit
which weighs their interests alongside
its own without bias
like so many other anti-war activists
mcgovern mcgovern was inspired and
instructed by the civil rights movement
on the issues of full citizenship and
equality of opportunity for african
americans he was a liberal although his
liberalism was based more on moral
conviction and political ideology rather
than on first-hand experience south
dakota if i'm not mistaken is not home
to a large number of penniless black
sharecroppers or impoverished ghetto
dwellers
the junior senator observed to the new
york state young democratic convention
in 1964 that quote the negro people have
set in motion a moral revolution based
on the judeo-christian ethic and the
politics of jefferson and lincoln
mcgovern insisted that the black
community's commitment to non-violent
civil disobedience stemmed from its
american experience
from the philosophy of henry david
thoreau
and most important from three centuries
of suffering and powerlessness
citing james baldwin's notes of a native
son mcgovern insisted that quote the
frustration that drives the negro into
the streets the lunchrooms and the bus
terminals is a desperate act of caring
about the american ideal
indeed he noted with enthusiasm that
black writers and activists were calling
upon america to come home to return to
the ideals that had been the main
springs of political and social life
since the since the revolution
throughout his dissent against the war
in vietnam and more specifically in 1972
during his presidential campaign
mcgovern would echo that call
in 1966 he quoted baldwin again
what time will bring
what time will bring americans is at
last their own identity
mcgovern believed that and rabid
anti-communism and the war in vietnam
was robbing the country of that identity
george mcgovern is a liberal who wanted
to promote social justice democracy
equality of opportunity and civic
responsibility by hearing to the
principles embedded in the new testament
the constitution and the declaration of
independence
he is a conservative who believed that
zealous anti-communists the
military-industrial complex and
political opportunists were radicalizing
the country driving it away from its
founding principles
in the aftermath of a 1971 campaign
swing mcgovern expounded to aid pat
donovan
quote the greening of america such an
exciting book
what it all boils down to are the simple
old values that my father and my sunday
school teachers taught me 40 years ago
it's the best in the judeo-christian
ethic out of which come the american
declaration of independence and the bill
of rights
consciousness 2 one of the chapters in
the book tells what the youth rebellion
is all about
what the kids are saying to us is why
don't you live up why don't you live in
the spirit of the new testament and why
don't you reaffirm the great ethical
values of the old testament
why don't you live up to the concepts of
the declaration of independence and the
bill of rights
this is what people are groping for
mcgovern said that sense of their own
significance and in relationship to the
community
that i really think is the message we've
got to get across
we know how to reaffirm the ancient
verities and the enduring principles of
the nation and do it in a way that
addresses itself to contemporary
problems
the theme of george mcgovern's 1972
presidential campaign come home america
is also i think a fitting summation of
his anti-war philosophy
thank you
gentlemen thank you uh true to the
spirit of 72 we're running way behind
schedule uh but i i noticed that daniel
ellsberg has probably filled up an
entire legal pad with comments and uh
doug brinkley promised this morning that
we'd hear from him and so mr helsberger
if you could uh make a few comments i'm
sure everybody would appreciate it
i'm up here without my legal pad you'll
see or illegal tad the um
uh actually my comments were not what i
was planning to say but what i was
hearing because i've learned a lot today
i think it's extremely
cogent and fascinating analysis and i
was making notes on those in fact i do
have i feel like responding a little bit
to a couple things we heard
several people have taken senator
mcgovern
to task actually today in a way that
does credit to your friends and
associates who would provide such uh
penetrating uh criticism on your 75th
birthday i'm not sure i look forward to
that on my 75th birthday
but
they were holding up a very high
standard
i happen to think the standard is is the
right one
we don't apply it enough of what one
might have done what one should have
done what one could have done
even though it's a standard that they
feel that george mcgovern failed in some
respects
i was listening to that and applying it
to myself
and
i can answer i think in one way
specific questions that have been raised
here several times today did mcgovern
nowhere i i believe
that mcgovern did not know
either what was being planned in 64
by lyndon johnson or 65
or reservations about it by anybody in
the administration
or anything that would have given the
lie
to uh johnson's statements
i i believe that easily
my answer is to why he didn't know
one answer would be
i didn't tell him
and for that i feel quite responsible
now mcnamara could have told him as
someone suggested others could have told
him in a better position as i but
actually i was in a good enough position
my safe in the pentagon as assistant
special assistant to the assistant
secretary of defense in 64
was filled with documents
showing that lyndon johnson would almost
surely carry out barry goldwater's
bombing campaign
and other campaigns soon after the
election that there was the american
public was being hoaxed by fraud there
was no real choice between the
candidates on this point
i knew that
very specifically
i knew that statements that senator
mcgovern referred to
that in voting for the tonkin gulf
resolution he was he was voting for a
measured response to an unprovoked
unequivocal attack on american
destroyers
were plausible for him to believe
because he had been lied to
by lyndon johnson
mcnamara rusk and others in secret
testimony before congress before the
senate
i had the documents that could prove
that
i didn't think of putting them out
that's perhaps an explanation or giving
them to senator mcgovern or to mansfield
or specifically to the foreign relations
committee it didn't occur to me
but in recent years that has seemed to
me perhaps an explanation but not an
excuse
it seems to me a failure of the
standards that should be put to american
officials in the executive branch
like myself
now senator morse and gruning both test
both volunteered in 71
after
i had given those documents the same
documents that had been in my safe in
64. i gave them in the form of the
pentagon papers to the senate foreign
relations committee in 69 and then later
to the new york times
senator martin gruning both volunteered
to testify uh in my trial in some
fashion grooning actually did
but morse told me in the summer of 71
having read this part of the pentagon
papers
if you had given us those documents
in 64
to the senate foreign relations
committee which i had
i had in my
safe that bill would never have gotten
out
of the foreign relations committee for a
vote
and if by some chance it had
it would have been voted down
george he was telling me that what
johnson used thereafter with a good
basis as the functional equivalent of a
declaration of war
would not have existed at that point if
i had simply done what i now perceive a
few years later and what more should
i clearly should have done knowing that
congress was being lied to knowing that
the whole electorate was being hoaxed
basically in a most serious way
and that we were being lied into a war
basically of enormous proportions a war
that the electorate was about to
repudiate
when goldwater
openly
declared proposed it
on election day
november in november of 1964
i represented the defense department at
an interagency group
uh chaired by bill bundy in the state
department
to discuss
alternative forms of carrying out the
goldwater policy
which the elect the voters were that day
repudiating in a historic landslide
uh we considered essentially nothing
that would have meant getting out of
vietnam only different ways of bombing
in particular now we didn't discuss that
the day before the election because it
might have leaked even at that late date
it would have showed voters that this
dimension of the campaign which was a
major one was a fraud that there was no
real difference between the candidates
we didn't do it a day after the election
because there was no time to wait in
this chaotic revolving door situation
that they described the bombing had to
get underway very quickly i was against
the bombing
i was there for reasons that
george mcgovern was referring to
somewhere i was supporting my boss
robert mcnamara who at that time
proposed the bombing i was supporting
the president
i was opposing
worse forms of bombing than we actually
chose seemed to me
but i was against it
and as i say it didn't occur to me to
simply tell the truth about that and to
unload so what mars was in effect
suggesting to me was that the next 58
000 american deaths
perhaps could have been prevented if i
had done what i now see i should have
done
so when it comes to meeting this
standard and saying i think george
mcgovern was
sincere totally i mean in 1970 and still
when as i heard this morning to my great
interest he was saying to his colleagues
we have all failed at this point and i
i'm sure that he did not mean to exempt
himself even up to that point though
he'd done more than the others
as i say that's a standard that i would
have to say i failed
i apologize to the american public for
that i feel very sorry very regretful
for it
okay moving ahead
we both learned from the experience in
fact we both were introduced to vietnam
about the same time i heard this morning
i went there in september
of uh in october of 65
and you were there in november
and began to see the war itself so we
learned and the uh effect i'll just move
ahead to the end of it
we did what we could
focusing now on george mcgovern rather
than me and that's something i think
deserves much more attention than it's
gotten here today
we've talked a lot about the campaign
let me see very fast on that
it was seen at the time and has been
seen ever since as a kind of feckless
doomed campaign
like a demonstration or a civil
disobedience or something that had no
chance of affecting the war and didn't
affect the war i think both of those
things are totally wrong
had bremer or someone else
after bremer
not shot george wallace
he was going to run
and uh nixon had failed in his what he'd
expected to do was to persuade him or
bribe him or extort him to get out of
the race
had he run
there would have been no landslide for
richard nixon it would have been a close
race and my guess is as best i can guess
it's a gift is that george mcgovern even
george mcgovern
uh in that sense would have won
certainly it would have been very close
i was just looking up the other night
george mcgovern got in 60 72 29 million
170 000 votes
in 68
humphrey got
31 million 170 000 votes 270 000 votes
uh
mcgovern had 93 percent of of humphreys
vote
you know we perceive the one as a viable
tough campaign
real serious and mcgoverns is impossible
the difference was of course
wallace was running in 68 and had he run
again as everyone expected him as he
would have done without shooting it
would have been a close race next point
would that have made a difference to
vietnam policy if mcgovern had one
and finally on that point i want to say
i think the general perception of that
is totally wrong there was a great deal
at stake in that election more than
people realized
i believed as of 69
and 71 and later and all the more till
today with more evidence
that richard nixon had no intention of
accepting a decent interval in vietnam
followed by a disguised defeat which
most people to this day believe was his
strategy his aim
and what he did i don't think he ever
accepted that and anything to the
contrary was as much a lie
as lyndon johnson's in 1964. as late as
the spring of 73 after the election
paris accords
i feel on the basis of a good deal of
evidence and very close analysis
the war would have continued in the air
as soon as the troops were out that
johnson nixon would have returned to
bombing
and that what we had the prospect of was
years more years more uh air war u.s air
war in vietnam and hundreds of thousands
of more vietnamese dead before saigon
became ho chi minh city
those were the stakes in that election
they really were very serious maybe i
don't know if even uh mcgovern to this
they you know
i want to talk to you about it but i'm
not even sure if you have that
conception
a key element in keeping that from
happening the key
was watergate which prevented nixon from
carrying out the bombing that he
intended and which kissinger was
proposing at that point
without watergate i think the war would
have continued the other key element was
and watergate got nixon out of office
which i think was essential the other
key element was the funds had to be cut
off by congress that war had to be ended
in a way no war had ever been ended in
history
mcgovern's name along with hadfield
is on the bill without which i believe
the war would not have ended when it did
the mcgovern hatfield bill started by
started by goodell a republican for
which he was hounded out of the
republican party as the christine
jorgensen of the republican party
carried on then by mcgovern in hatfield
to cut off the money for the war
without that
ford would have following nixon would
have
kept the war going i think in the air
and uh with that with the mcgovern
hatfield bill the process that led to
the cutting off of the fund ford was not
willing to buck congress on that
so uh i've always felt and i've often
felt
i i wanted to end the nuclear arms race
i've often said the way george mcgovern
was crucial to ending the vietnam war by
congress to find the executive and
cutting off the funds so i thank you
george for what you learned and what you
did on what you learned thank
i'm afraid i'm gonna have to cut that
off i i'd hope that we could get some
questions here but i can see that uh
we're behind schedule doug what do you
want we'll continue we'll get taken
later all right
we're gonna
bring the next session on on to the
campaign
thank you professor brands and professor
woods
we'll be able to take um a couple
questions and later we'll kind of
combine the the uh both but the people
that are taking part in the 72 campaign
um session can you come on up to the
front and make a changing of the guard
here in the next two minutes but it'd be
good if everybody stayed seated so we
don't lose too much
extra time
ours
[Applause]
hi i'm dan ellsberg welcome to my old
office building here
[Applause]
i used to uh
i used to work in i think the fourth
window from the left on the second row
up there and i had my own parking space
in the in the pot right in front of here
which was the highest perquisite you
could have virtually
i was here in 67 when we marched over
against the war
dave dellinger and others in fact i saw
norman mailer who was part of that just
yesterday
marched over from the lincoln memorial
and then because i had a pentagon pass
in those days i went inside
and i stood up
actually the main windows up there are
the office of the secretary of defense
it was robert mcnamara then
and i stood at an adjacent window
to mcnamara looking out at the crowd i
just marched over with
because i wanted to see the look on his
face when the yippies
succeeded in levitating the building
which they were working on
yeah
actually it was wonderful to see these
doves preceding us over here today
they were
fluttering in the breeze in 1976 on the
continental walk for peace and social
justice which was actually my first
arrest here in the pentagon after the
pentagon papers
same same day here
[Music]
and
the doves are the doves are still with
us
i was when i used to work up there of
course i dressed like this and i still
do when i get arrested i've always tell
people if you have a tie
i wish you would wear it for the cameras
when you get arrested to show everybody
watching that just wearing a tie does
not excuse you from the obligations of
citizenship
which which
includes which includes teaching the
people in there
how to say no how to protest
here
ken starr
is famous now is the
greatest disseminator of pornography in
the history of the world
but for real
[Music]
for real obscenity you've got to look at
the dod budget which they just agreed on
they're working on this year
here we have newt gingrich
boasting about the fact that he's added
nine billion dollars
to a pentagon budget to any uh high cold
war rate
nine years after the berlin wall has
fallen down there he's boasting that
he's added nine billion dollars and
boasting that in the same budget deal he
cut out
school construction
now
that's obscene that is obscene
he managed to include he managed to
include in that nine billion dollars
uh cargo planes to be constructed that
the air force didn't even want but in
his hometown of marietta georgia and for
trent lott here we're reading in ken
starr's report about illicit gifts
between the president and his lover you
know about a book of poetry uh funny uh
sunglasses and in that budget we have a
carrier a helicopter carrier that the
navy didn't even request to be built in
pasakula mississippi for trent lott's
hometown the majority again
that's real obscenity
[Music]
along the same lines
by the way the reason i'm so happy to be
here at this building with you people is
there people in this crowd
who at a war resistors league meeting
back in 1969
gave by their example of going to jail
to protest to refuse to be part of a war
that shamed their country randy keeler
bob eaton randy's here today if it
weren't for their example it wouldn't
have occurred to me to ask myself and i
was
i was walking in i was working in the
pentagon at that time i couldn't have
asked myself
what could i do
to help end this war if i'm willing to
go to jail as i am along with these
people and i thought it's something i
could do i could give tell what i knew
tell the truth give it to the pentagon
to the washington post the new york
times
7 000 pages of top secret material
there are
there are people watching us there are
people watching us from those windows
now where i used to work
i hope they can hear this loudspeaker
and if they'll go to the rear of those
offices inside those same safe drawers
where i used to work
and unload or copy
all the evidence of illegal
interventions of unnecessary wrongful
wasteful murderous plans
and dump
and unload that over to the new york
times or the post of this or the senate
that building will rise six feet in the
air and spin around levitation is best
done from the inside and they can still
do it
again
we're here as i say to protest twisted
priorities a press and a congress that's
obsessed with what the president does
with his cigars and very little curious
very tolerant very permissive about what
he does with his cruise missiles
psy hirsch has a story in the new york
times i heard she got a pulitzer prize
for exposing milai has a new york times
a new yorker rather article a couple of
weeks ago
about the total lack of evidence and
reason and uh
motiv real motivation at all for these
cruise missile attacks on a
pharmaceutical factory in sudan
he says that the four chiefs of staff
who work in that building four star
generals
were not part of the consultation for
that planning they were kept out of it
because hersh says the president knew
they would say no to this stupid and
murderous and unnecessary attack total
attack
the one man
of their uh the one colleague who was in
on that consulting was general
shelton the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff and the reason that he was
there was that they were sure he would
he would say yes to it now let's
remember why he has that job in the new
climate
the pre preceding nominee hi i see
louise ramirez here who i got arrested
with who set the pace for me at the
pentagon in nineteen
so here we have here we have a four-star
general
a four-star general
who has not learned to say no to the
president
uh when it comes to his actual job he
acts like a 21 year old intern he earns
his presidential knee pads we are here
to teach general shelton how and when to
say no that's what i learned from people
like randy keeler from bob eaton from
the others who went to jail from dave
mcreynolds who's been at this for a very
long time
what i say to the people the lesson of
vietnam and many other things for the
people in that building listening to us
there are times to say no to a president
even if it does cost you your job even
if you have to go to jails with oil
so i'm proud to be with you today
the people who taught me that today and
the others and thanks for being here
thank you
[Applause]
i think dan is a really good example of
how each and every one of us can really
make a difference as somebody who really
has made a difference
there are people here who have been
working on a number of struggles
and we come together here because we
know the importance of being here and
focusing in on the pentagon
i'm really pleased to introduce our next
speaker pam africa
pam as you know
needs no introduction
is with the international concerned
families and of course friends of mumia
[Applause]
on the move
long live revolution and down with this
rotten system
[Applause]
i want to point out
not only does this government
bomb main kill over in japan raping
robbing and stealing and uh but right
here in this country
this government bombed
11 men
women and children for standing up
speaking out about situations just like
this about the bombing of the water the
damning of the air the bombing with all
kind of pollutants and stuff in the air
that we got to breathe i'm saying when
people stand up against this government
this government not only go after them
like they're going in you know innocent
places like iraq iran japan um
you know okinawa you know all the
different places where these people have
murdered maimed and killed in our name
and are one of the things one of the
protesters was talking about on the way
here is the fact that this government is
powerless without us
i'm saying these armies
are made up of our
sisters now our mothers
our brothers our cousins our loved ones
who have taken upon themselves not only
to go to war against us but to go to war
against other countries in the name of
us we must continue to stay in our
neighborhoods educate in our communities
and uh a day without the pentagon is not
enough it got to be seven days without
the pentagon it got to be 24 hours
without the pentagon
and it can only happen it can only
happen with us
the pentagon is supposed to be designed
to
protect the people this is not a
protection of the people they say that
they go to these places to bring peace
but when in the world have you ever
bombed
maimed raped kill people to peace this
is cold-blooded murder and they're doing
it in our names
my brother mario is a member of the
continent's objectives every program
that we have and uh we make sure that he
is there
[Music]
but each and every last
um
[Music]
gotta do
is go into our communities a welfare
issue is an issue of dealing with this
pentagon as well an issue of anything if
you're dealing with the water the soul
the air if you're dealing with schools
if you deal with any issue make sure
that this issue be a part of we have got
to educate we cannot leave here saying
well my plate is full i can't do no more
it don't take you no time to turn around
and speak out about what's going on
invite a speaker to anything that you're
having dealing with this situation our
lives are on the line right now innocent
children are dying over in iraq iran in
the sudan and our children have been
bombed you know in our name um it can't
be said enough that we have got to go
into our churches our schools and
protest don't let this be a one-day
protest let's do it seven days a week 24
hours a day just like we inhale and
exhale that's how we got to do this
government exposing the wrongs in it on
the move
before i end
and talking about munya boo jamal this
government we do we need a whole lot
more mum yeah boo jamals there was a new
york times ad done for mumia that was in
friday's newspaper it was supposed to
show nationwide but the uh ad is so
powerful that they only did it in three
states
we're asking people to call the new york
times and demand that they reprint this
ad and it goes in all the papers just
like it was supposed to we paid 36
000
for this ad so that people can know the
truth about mamia the ad is just that
powerful i have copies of the ad for
anybody who want to give a nickel
donation a dollar donation 10 cent
donation so that we can make more ads so
people can see the truth um freedom move
nine who's also in jail for standing up
against this government my family was
bombed because we refuse to bow down
kiss up to this government our position
is god bless all of you our position is
that
no matter what you do and uh rodney king
was not a freedom fighter
you know um a lot of people who have
been shot and in jail are not freedom
fighters so i'm saying if you're going
to go to jail if you're going to die
then damn it die fighting this country
for the wrong that they are doing to
each and every last one of us on the
move and be a revolutionary until the
day you die
[Applause]
good afternoon my name
is with the war resistance league and
what's resistance in brooklyn
i'm very pleased today
to come here with the first of several
solidarity messages
we have people here and messages here
from all around the world from puerto
rico from east timor and i'm honored to
bring a message to you from south africa
greetings to all participating in a day
without the pentagon
after our wonderful conference this
weekend
i know you will be inspired and
energized
and full of determination
we must go forward to build a world
without war
i regret this is dennis brutus i regret
that i cannot be with you this
particular protest
but i'll be with you in many other
actions
for the road ahead
we say no to war
what do we say
we say no to the war machine
we say no to the pentagon
and we say yes to a just social order
and yes to peace
dennis brutus october 1998 the
coordinator of the south south summit
and i might add poet laurette of a free
south africa
hi my name is ellen davidson and along
with 20 other people this morning i was
arrested blocking the metro to prevent
people from coming to work this morning
[Applause]
[Music]
i have a message of solidarity from the
women's international league for peace
and
freedom the women's international league
for peace and freedom joins the war
resistors league at the pentagon on
october 19 to protest the miserable
policies of violence waste and meanness
perpetrated against humanity and the
environment while diverting precious
resources needed to sustain families
communities and nature
we fully support the wrl's call to the
people of the u.s to free ourselves from
the pentagon and to refuse to fund
military solutions
with them we are determined to turn
around the priorities of the government
military and corporate power brokers of
this country
we affirm our authority as citizens to
be decision makers and we choose food
housing and health care not bombs
missiles and guns
we stand with the wrl at the pentagon in
washington today on the side of people
justice and non-violence
thank you
[Applause]
hi again and i'm joanne sheehan i work
with the warby sisters league and i'm
the chair of the warby sisters
international
i have a statement of support from a
friend of ours who would hope to be here
today but couldn't who was here with us
also over the weekend
at our 75th anniversary conference
and that's charlie king
charlie has a question
how many folk singers could you hire for
1.7 billion dollars
the pentagon needs to kill our dreams
needs to turned us into zombies just to
get their bloody work done
they got pretty good at that during the
gulf war
today they will spend 1.7 billion
dollars and hardly anyone will notice
but you noticed
that people will notice you
your dreams will not die
you refused to be zombies
today you are more alive than you have
ever been
i want to sing your praise praises for
your courage and your imagination that
keep dreams alive charlie king thanks
[Applause]
before i introduce the next speaker
i wanted to show you a little piece of
paper you've probably seen some of these
they're green
they have pictures of dead presidents
and slave holders on them
they're very bad karma
and if you have any in your pockets you
should take them out of your pockets and
put them into little buckets that are
passing around in order that they may be
spent on something useful like
supporting the war resistors league in
this event
so if you have any of these get rid of
them there's people collecting them to
take your karma away
our next speaker used to be a much
larger man
he's smaller now he fasts all the time
some people wonder if he'll eventually
get so small we can't see him
but enough of him he's here to see
because while he shrunk in physical size
he grew in moral stature
and this brother has been out at the
front line for a long time telling the
truth and making people laugh
he gives a whole new definition to the
word stand up for comedians he stands up
for what's right dick gregory
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you let me first say we
thank and praise god that we have all
made it here safely today
and i pray to god that your return and
my return will be equally as safe
secondly let me say thanks to all of you
all that's here for the right reason and
give yourself a hand and let me hear you
out there
and before you leave here today look
around
because this is what real power is
that what that building and what this
silliness represent is not real power
understand that
they they over there drunk with power
drunk with drugs drunk with alcohol and
all that craziness but we are the ones
that have real power do you realize if
the pentagon would have had to plan
what we're doing today it would have
cost billions of dollars
we think about that
think about that they would have been
them they would look they would have had
so-called intelligent folks sitting
around the desk trying to figure out how
they're going to do it
look a idiot could do what they do
you know i mean you don't even need to
be smart to do what they do
and so i say to you
who have really made a difference and
it's just a thrill to come out here and
see all the folks that's been out here
in this movement day after day year
after year and let me tell you something
we're dealing with the mightiest they
talk about hitler nem nazi these folks
in this building here do stuff that
would make hitler blush
hear me
hear me good
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean we got an american press we got
television we got business folks that
think with the mentality of animals
and we're the ones that stand up for
truth and stand up for justice we will
win have no doubt about it and we don't
need to be validated by the new york
times or nbc or cbs or presidents or
evil old men and women
understand that
us being here today validates us
you know sometime today
before you go to bed tonight
i want you to think about
a big old grinder a big old grinder and
i want you to think of this pentagon as
a grinder
and then think of yourself as a grinder
because grinders do two things one it
can grind you down to nothing like the
pentagon or i can polish you up to a
light that the whole world
have to look at and see
and we represent that grinder that
polishes and there's a whole lot of
people guarding today guarding this
field guarding this insanity and they'll
be dead and buried but they spirits one
day will know that we are the ones on
the right side
we're the ones on the right side
[Music]
there's something evil you can anytime a
building that's supposed to be this good
for people need these many guards that's
god telling you something evil goes on
inside
[Applause]
and the beautiful thing about what we do
here we didn't need no guards to come
here
we don't need no guards to watch them
because we're not concerned about what
they do we concerned about when we can
put enough energy together to stop this
madness to stop this insanity
[Music]
so i say to you today
[Applause]
we represent light
and if you want to know how powerful we
are and if anybody in that pentagon want
to know how powerful we are go into a
dark room and shut the light off
and then pop the light back on
light wipes out darkness you don't
negotiate with it it don't argue with it
it don't debate it
and if the pentagon want to know real
power
then they need to go to bed early one
night
and get up early one morning and watch
the sun come out it's smack night time
clean out the sky and never make a sound
that's what power is about
and that's the power that we bring here
and that's the power that we say
to those of you that's here go back home
and tell the folks that we can win
we don't have to be intimidated by
people because all they represent is the
shatter of death they don't even know
how to kill people if they did it
wouldn't cost a billion seven 1.7
billion they don't even know how to kill
people
we the living
are the ones
that will shine light around this planet
and so i say to you today
i thank you
every tuesday night at sundown
to wednesday at sundown
i call on you to fast and pray with me
one day a week
that this insanity will end
we have the power inside of us we have
the forces inside of us you attack evil
with love you attack evil with kindness
you attack evil with gentleness and it
would win they don't have a missile
they don't have a missile they don't
have a bomb they don't have nothing in
their arsenal that can create new life
they ain't numbered a bunch of punks
they can't create new life
at all
[Applause]
is not the ability to kill power is the
ability to enhance my life we the ones
that have power
we're the ones that have power
their missiles they got don't mean
nothing the missiles of love that we
bring here the missiles of unity that we
bring here the missiles of kindness that
we bring in these are the ones that's
going to win out and i tell you
something brothers and sisters
10 million years from now
if there's anyone on this planet the
only reason america will be remembered
will be two things
it'll be remembered by this evil
pentagon and it will be remembered by
martin luther king the peace movement
and this movement that have worked
against all odds to make things better
not just in america but in the whole
world and if it wasn't for them too the
good and the bad america wouldn't even
get a blimp on the screen we will win
this one we are winning now i love you
god bless you peace be with you and keep
hope alive
[Applause]
[Applause]
my name is chris nye and i'm on the
staff at the war resistors league
many people know that we are one of the
ways that the war resistors league is
celebrating its 75th anniversary is
bringing the protest back to the
pentagon
and one of the things that's exciting
about being here
is that we have people from all walks of
life from around the world from across
the country but in some ways even more
significant than that we have people
across four generations of protesters
who are here to say we want a day
without the pentagon
and it's appropriate that our next
speaker
is a veteran activist
who has served as a mentor
and a colleague and a friend to all of
those generations
for movements on a whole variety of
issues
he went to prison to protest the draft
during the second world war
he subsequently
was involved in the struggle for civil
rights and has been an activist and a
speaker
on behalf of the poor and the oppressed
in this country and around the world i
asked him a few moments ago if he could
count or remember how many times he's
been arrested at this building and he
said that he couldn't but we know that
it's been many many times he has put his
body on the line in support of all of
our rights please join me in welcoming
dave dellinger
hi
gregory said
all the things that the
united states at its best would be
remembered for it'll be remembered for
you folks and it'll be remembered for
dick gregory
sometimes i think that gregory and i are
getting old
because
i have been inspired by him
for
maybe 40 years
which is close to half a century
now the us is a superpower
but because it is a superpower because
of
things like the pentagon
it is also 26
in child
mortality which is
often related to poverty
and
it was a terrible thing
the vietnam war in which at its height
200 gi's were coming home in body bags
and all kinds of vietnamese were getting
blown to smithereens
but
you should understand
that the
number of young people children and
young people
who die
unnecessarily
in the united states every six months
is greater than the total of the number
of gis who were killed during the entire
vietnam war
now i want to refer to another speaker
daniel ellsberg
and before i do let me just say
that the u.s today spends
28 billion dollars a year
to keep 7
500 nuclear warheads
in
ready for use
now
daniel ellsberg
said to me years and years ago
that the u.s has used
the nuclear bomb
12 times
i said gee
are you talking because i only know of
two times so are you you talking
they believe in freedom of speech
note the helicopter up there
anyway i said so are you talking about
the number of times that it had
explosions and killed people as a result
of you know from cancer and all the rest
of it
and he said no
if you have a gun
and put it at somebody's head
and say your money or your life
you may not have to pull the trigger but
you have used the gun
and that's the way the united states
uses the nuclear bomb
by now it's much more than 12 times to
control the world
now
i spoke about
the excess
pentagon budget which doesn't go
to
helping people medically or helping
people be educated or removing poverty
which is one of the crimes one of the
most violent aspects of the american
society
but i wonder how many of you know
that the u.s military budget
totals more than the eight next
largest
military budgets of the trump countries
the u.s military budget exceeds the
total combined
of russia japan france the united
kingdom
germany china italy and south korea
so let's take that money
let's shut down the pentagon and take
that money and put it into health and
education and remotely
leaving poverty
[Music]
now one other
one other fact that you may not know in
detail
is
that the pentagon today
6
500 employees
whose job is to sell arms
to other countries
and 75
of the sales to third world countries
are to opponents of human rights
fortunately more and more of us know
about the school of americas
and
along with some a lot of other people i
am going to be there on november 22nd at
fort benning georgia
[Music]
but
the fact is
that the military is used to gain
control of other countries
and it is also another fact about the
pentagon
those
uh 6
500 employees
very often
they sell the armaments
to
both sides of the conflict within the
third world countries
so why is that
not just to gain control
of the oil and the other resources which
i already said
but
the purpose is to make money for the
corporations
and so today one percent
of the
population
in the united states controls more
wealth than the bottom
95 percent
and this is
was never a democracy
thinking about slavery and genocide of
the indians
but particularly is evident now
that the one percent of the population
who control the most money
control
both parties the republic rats and the
others
do you know a single party
and
they control the government
so that is why
we
are not organizing i mean people
are not organizing huge demonstrations
to plead with the government to change
its ways because it won't
but only by civil disobedience
and by grassroots action will we do it
now
[Applause]
one concluding
optimistic note
charlie parker the great jazz musician
once said
jazz comes from who you are
where you've been and what you've
learned
if you don't live it it won't come out
of your horn
and that is true of social change that
is true of human equality
that is true of human justice a huge
closeness to nature
so
one of the
best things in this country today
is the people who are not fooled by
national elections
not fooled by just lobbying their
senator or congressman but are actually
carrying their ideas of human rights and
human equality
carrying it into their own lives their
own relationships their own community
so it's very important that what for all
the wonderful sister cities that we have
which are very important it's very
important
to
act locally and think globally thank you
very
[Music]
[Applause]
much as you know this is the 75th
anniversary of the war resistors league
and i've been asked to make a special
announcement
you will find copies of this special
anniversary issue of our magazine the
non-violent activist in the crowd many
people have copies and would like you
ask you to take multiple copies of them
with you home and share them with people
in your own communities the theme of
this issue is the future of non-violence
it includes a series of essays from
activists in a variety of issues talking
about the role of non-violence and
non-violent direct action as it relates
to the issues that they are working on
all of us connected to wrl
are obviously proud of the three-quarter
century tradition that we have
inherited from the past but in many ways
it's an insignificant history the
importance of that history
and of this day
is to rejuvenate the movement to rebuild
the movement to reconnect the peace
movement with other social change forces
going on across the country and around
the world to build the next 75 years the
next 150 years of resistance to
oppression and militarism dave's words
made many of those connections our next
performer is another uh person who in
her own life has made those connections
from supporting the civil rights
movement to supporting the peace
movement
she was honored earlier this year with
the wrl wrl peace award which went to
movement musicians as our source of
inspiration in good times and bad please
welcome odetta
[Applause]
hello to you
welcome to you
i was wondering what to do today
and i guess i should do what i do
and i guess basically that is
reinforcing
ourselves as individuals and unique
and celebrating the possibility
of our getting together
and bringing
this power and this force
up against uh hideous
power and force
and um i might ask you a few times to
sing along with me and i know you can
sing i heard you before
and this song is kumbaya my lord
translated that is come by here my lord
uh if you know it jump right in
sing real loud
uh you cannot almost sing
so you and if somebody looks at you
because they figure you're not in the
right key
look at them bless them and continue
singing
[Music]
lord
[Music]
someone needs your love
[Music]
[Music]
just listen to him
again again again
[Music]
oh
[Music]
pretty good
i was going to school when they had
music in school
[Music]
maybe we can get it back in
as soon as we renegotiate the monies
that are being wasted here
[Applause]
do you remember little red caboose
little red caboose
little red caboose behind the train
smoke stack on his back
chucking down the track
a little red cabooser behind the train
woo
sing it little red caboose
little red caboose
little red caboose behind the train
smoke stuck
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
two men's hands
can't
tell
a building now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
we
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
falling
[Music]
we'll see the day come round
we'll
one man's mind can't levitate this
building one man's head
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
two men's hands
can't bring
the building down
[Music]
we'll see the day come round
we'll see
[Applause]
one grain of sand
one grain of sand
[Music]
in all the world
one grain of sand
one little boy
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
love you soon
more than you will ever
ever
[Music]
i woke up this morning
[Music]
my
no he was crawling
up
[Music]
you
[Music]
say
[Music]
woke up this morning
[Music]
[Applause]
hallelujah
i'll do
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
who
believe in
true
[Music]
from
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody
turn me round
[Music]
turn me around
turn me round
[Music]
talking down this freedom
turn me round
turn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lord
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
hear how much you appreciate her
our next speaker joins us from
philadelphia she is the executive
director of the philadelphia jobs with
peace campaign and one of the national
organizers of the million woman march
please greet barbara smith
[Music]
all right
there's some noise out here in this
place okay
we're here to shut it down
okay
we're here to shut it down
we're going to shut the pentagon down
[Music]
in philadelphia do a lot of work i want
to talk about two areas today
one is with his welfare to work
and we know
but a lot of people who may be watching
and listening today
think that the stereotypical things that
they say about women on welfare are true
but we know
that the real welfare is our government
corporations the banks
they're the ones that's taking all of
our money
taking all of our tax dollars
off of the poor
they want to say and they want us to
believe
that welfare women
are
largely black and latino that is not
true
they want us to believe that welfare
women are promiscuous
lazy and illiterate
well i want to tell you who is
promiscuous
we are in washington d.c are we not
what a contradiction
they want to say that because we are
having our babies and trying to survive
out here that we are the ones
but what is the president doing and how
are they going after him with my tax
dollars
i don't if they want to impeach the
president let the republicans pay for it
out of their pockets and get out of my
pocket with it
[Applause]
this government is lazy let's look at
the health care system
they have that's right there is no
health care system
because they're too dark or lazy to
create something where we can all
benefit from it there's no research we
can't afford medications they're too
high and expensive
aids is just a joke to the government
they try to capitalize on on people who
are really suffering in this country and
just letting it run rapid but we know
that really amongst the people that
there are alternatives to drugs and that
there is a real spirit of life living
with aids and we have to celebrate and
we have to thank those people and we
have to support them and not let the
government just wipe them away
[Music]
they only want to talk about who's
illiterate they want to talk about the
education system once again is there an
education system i don't think so
we have young people that i organize
with in a community manchu in west
philadelphia the schools are a joke
what they have there
no arts programs no real history being
taught nothing around life skills
but i'm out there with these children
and they're getting hot they're getting
blood blooded up every day
okay because they have nothing else to
do
where they have taken away jobs they
have taken away the only drug store for
this population of 25 000 people and
supermarket burned down five years ago
and they have not replaced it
half the homes in this neighborhood are
underdeveloped you would think you were
in a third world country
yet this government wants to say to them
that they are the ones that are corrupt
and they are the ones that are um
illiterate but they're not i could tell
you this as much as i talked to those
children they at least knew how to spell
potato dan quail didn't know how to do
that
a day without the pentagon
what a glorious day
a day we could build homes
educate our children
stop building prisons for our children
and release political prisoners
provide affordable health care
clean the environment
create real jobs to increase the chances
of a better quality of life
a day we could create an atmosphere that
would be like heaven like looking out at
all of you angels today it's like heaven
because the days of the pentagon are
over that is like a living hell
the million-man march if you remember
they said that a million black men
couldn't come here to washington d.c
but they walked right over the white
house
two years later they said black women
couldn't come together in philadelphia
2.5 million women came to philadelphia
the million youth march they said they
couldn't bring the youth together in new
york giuliani with his madness with his
craziness because i was there and those
youth came together thousands of youth
because they want a life and they don't
not want their tax dollars spent on the
pentagon
if they can do it we can do it
we can shut it down
they said it was an earthquake here
today
that earthquake was the war resistance
league shutting it down
and that earthquake is gonna be heard
all around the world
they're listening to us now
and i say we can shut it down
military spending
concentrates employment among those who
are already well off
most employees of high-tech
industries and defense contracts already
enjoy higher wages and less unemployment
than minorities
low-skilled workers women and teenagers
increasing the military budget while
further cutting domestic spending harms
those groups that are already suffering
the most
so when we go back to our neighborhoods
and our communities we have to organize
we have to reach across class lines we
have to reach across race lines we have
to come together
all of us the allies that help those
marches they're here with us today we
have to work together our house is on
fire it don't matter what your sexual
orientation is if my house is on fire
help me get the water and put it out and
what we got to do
what we've got to do
is collaborate and work together and
take this message back
god bless you peace out
[Applause]
[Music]
having recently returned from the war
resistors international triennial in
croatia
please join me in welcoming
wrl member vietnam veterans against the
war member and black vets for social
justice justice member greg peyton
[Applause]
all right uh i just want to say it's
really overwhelming to see
so many people here to see the past to
see the president see the future of
where our movement is going
uh i'm a vietnam veteran and i was one
of the people that were deceived by that
building back there to leave here and to
go fight a war that i didn't know
anything about and as a result of my
involvement in that i came of age in
vietnam and i recognized that i had no
business fighting that war and when i
came out i've been organizing talking to
young people ever since about what this
establishment is about and the lies and
the deceits that they're going to
continue to carry against us and our
children everyone has to remember that
even though we're rallying here today
this is not the end this is just one day
of many days that we have to keep the
pressure on in order to bring down this
this pentagon and this enormous budget
that they use for death and destruction
all over the world
it's very important to remember that
as we speak our schools are being
militarized junior rotc groups are
sprouting up all over our schools it's
not unusual to walk downtown and see a
bunch of young people walking around
with with blue blue and and brown
uniforms on it reminds me of 1938 and a
country called germany when they had the
brown shirts so i'm telling you if you
think it can't happen here just watch
and see what's going on
we're all moving closer and closer to
fascism in the name of
of of trying to avoid terrorism what
they're saying is they're going to take
back our rights as people so that they
can help us fight terrorism but the real
terrorists are them because they never
tell us the truth they never give us
clear-cut answers on what they're doing
and how they do it
so i just want to remind everyone that
our children are being bombarded daily
by this destruction this thing called
the pentagon as we look if if the
military
the military is the third leading
sponsor of sports programming
so when you go watch your tv sports
program you're going to see
advertisement for a budweiser
for a chevy camaro and for the military
and you know in fact if in fact they
were really uh
commercial people that would be brought
up for false advertisement it's an
adventure it's a job education all these
things are non-existent we know that the
number one thing that the military is
about is armed forces so it's time for
us to take this battle back to our
communities back to our neighborhoods we
need to talk to our families we need to
organize our families you know this is
important like dave was saying we need
to think globally but we have to act
locally and we have to do it now thank
you
let me ask you a couple of questions
which would you rather have smart bombs
or smart kids
why would you rather have war or art
does everyone here know that the
national endowment for the arts
endowment is equal to the cost of one
wing of one b-2 bomber
what do you think about that
and one of the ways to shut down the
pentagon
is to stop paying for it
our next speaker claire hanrahan from
the national war tax resistance
coordinating committee is going to tell
us all about that please welcome her
[Applause]
god bless this reign
[Music]
i'm really energized being here after
spending time with the 75th war
resisters league anniversary with some
very very fine people
i'm here to tell you what you already
know
we do get what we pay for we just have
to turn around and see where all our
money's going
as i speak to you today i do so mindful
of my two older brothers daniel and
thomas
as teenage soldiers in vietnam they were
utterly changed
it was the militarism that distorted
their youthful idealism
into the service of death
they returned from that war wounded in
body and soul with the agent orange
toxin coursing through their systems
and one after another they died
like so many veterans do
i
i've refused to pay war taxes since
1981.
[Music]
that's the year i took the pledge
that's when i decided to break the
deadly habit of paying for war
since then my life has been an
experiment in revolutionary poverty
because we know
it's not just our tax dollars that fuel
this pentagon but our lifestyles of
waste and habitual consumption
[Music]
this privilege we maintain on the backs
of the destitute of the world
and it's upheld by the pentagon in its
deadly force
i'm just one of ten thousand war tax
resisters in the united states who
openly refuse to pay for war
there are many ways to disengage
i live on the economic edge
and it's not with the destitution of the
oppressed
it's a liberating experience and a
choice
i've i've raised a fine daughter i've
survived half a century
i'm a writer and a gardener and i get
around town on my bicycle
[Music]
[Applause]
i have some allies out here helping me
along i'm self-propelled and
self-employed and in the spirit of emma
goldman i'll dance at every chance
[Applause]
y'all are making it easy thank you i'm
we know some war resistors will refuse
to pop to file and pay
some will refuse a portion some will
refuse to pay any at all
but most are also peace taxpayers
we'll redirect these refused war tax
dollars into constructive programs into
over 32 alternative funds throughout the
country
each year we deliver more than 50 000
dollars in these refused taxes to fund
community needs
the national
campaign for a peace tax fund many of
you support is an effort to gain legal
recognition of the right of conscience
in matters of paying for war
but we cannot wait until congress says
it's okay not to pay for war the time to
break the addiction is now the bombs are
falling now
as much as 50 percent of every tax
dollar working people
extracted from your wages is put to the
service of death we know this
and we know that this militarism
according to the writer dorothy sully is
the inevitable byproduct of the economic
system in which we live
the bombs are falling now
we are waging war against the natural
world that we exploit she has written
we are waging war against our own need
to live a simple life we live in a state
of cold war between the rich and the
poor
and the poor are perishing in it the
bombs are falling now this militarism is
killing us
what then shall we do
as as we gather here to block the doors
of the pentagon to declare a day without
the pentagon to say no business as usual
we must remember that there may be
people working here who truthfully
believe they are laboring in the service
of peace
ensuring our freedom to gather here and
resist
to show our descent
as we attempt to block the doors to
their workplace the source of their
livelihood
as we ask that they stop participating
in this business of desk i ask each of
you
when will we stop paying for death
when will we risk our own financial
security our economic privilege to
obstruct this business
[Music]
who will block the doors to the
to the post office on april 15th when we
voluntarily submit our taxes to the irs
the taxes that fuel this death
we are all responsible
we're all guilty for the militarism that
is crushing this world defiling the good
earth reigning death on countless
innocents
targeting not the dangerous leaders whom
we fear but the women and children the
old and the infirm the teenage soldiers
we must withdraw our cooperation
as global citizens we are complicit in
these war crimes we cannot say we didn't
know
how long tax
how long will you persist in this deadly
submission
leo tolstoy knew that peace conferences
alone cannot free us
but simply
he says by the conscience of each one of
us
forbidding us to participate in violence
and asking in amazement
why are we doing that
we peace seekers show more fear of the
irs and its threat to our property and
privilege
than our willingness to take even a
modest financial risk for peace
and many of us who have found employment
within our own peace movement
are faced with the dilemma of having war
taxes deducted from our pay
and submitted to the irs
why are we doing that
dorothy day understood that the war the
racism the poverty in the world is not
going to be changed just by words or
demonstrations
it's a question of living our lives in
drastically different ways
[Music]
our gathering here is powerful
it's important that we make our descent
visible
but this is not enough
we must help each other to break this
deadly addiction to the lifestyles that
are fueling the devastation and to
paying the taxes that uphold this filthy
rotten system
juanita nelson
one of the pilgrims of the war tax
resistance movement
has been resisting war taxes for over 50
years
[Music]
[Applause]
that's as long as i've been alive
juanita reminds us that we must hold up
to the light practically every breath
that we breathe in terms of non-violence
in terms of how the practice matches the
preachment
take a deep breath
claim your freedom
seize your power
look your fears in the eye
step a little closer to the edge
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
well i don't know if they seeded the
clouds in order to keep people away from
this demo today or not
well we know that um
despite any efforts to try to keep
people away from hearing the messages
that are being spoken from this stage
and from seeing the wonderful collection
of people who are gathered here in
attendance despite any efforts to try to
keep that message from going out
we have c-span here broadcasting live
across the country everything that's
being said from this stage
this morning some of us were up at 4 15
doing early morning interviews and we
were on the today show
and all of washington dc was so worried
that we might interrupt the flow of
traffic that we made all of the traffic
reports saying that there could be
protests at the pentagon which still
consumes more than one billion dollars a
day of our tax dollars
i have a couple quick announcements that
i need to make
i'd like to ask meg starr
and ronnie fellaras to come to the side
of the stage over here meg starr and
ronnie fellerath
also would like to know if there are
people in the crowd who have umbrellas
that they would be willing to loan
um to other folks here in case the rain
picks up again
and finally one of the organizers of
this event
has
lost a black denim jacket the black
denim jacket has gone missing from one
of the organizers so if you see one
around and you don't know who it belongs
to please let one of us know
one of our concerns about the pentagon
and the presence of u.s militarism
around the world
is that it promotes a policy of racism
and a policy of divide and conquer
it used to be that the pentagon
justified its budgets with a communist
threat today the justification is the
terrorist threat yet we know that
there's no greater terrorism than the
threat to destroy the entire planet or
the ability to launch missiles anywhere
in the world with impunity and kill
innocent civilians
[Applause]
but as a piece of evidence about the
kind of thinking that goes on in that
building that's in front of me that is
behind you
when we negotiated the permit for this
space for legal space on public property
when we negotiated the permit with the
pentagon police one of the things they
told us is that you can't get near the
building
because muslims might infiltrate your
group and leave explosive devices near
the pentagon
[Music]
[Applause]
our next speaker is from an organization
that works tirelessly and consistently
to debunk those myths and to show that
muslims and arabs are our brothers and
sisters please join me in welcoming
kamal nawaz legal director of the
american arab anti-discrimination
committee
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks
i guess i was one of those who
infiltrated
uh
i just wanted
i just wanted to give a warning earlier
i just wanted to assure people that i
really wasn't part of customs there by
the way that i was dressed as i was
walking around i've gotten some funny
looks and some funny comments the only
reason i was there i'm dressed like this
today is because
i was informed to come here the last
moment adc wanted to send a lawyer just
in case anything happened over here so i
just wanted to assure anyone everyone
that i wasn't part of custom
uh i didn't really have a prepared
speech because i came in at the last
minute
you know
adc we
we join you in making today and we
support your effort in making today
a day without the pentagon and while
there are many issues around the world
where the work of the the pentagon
has affected the world or people in a
negative way i want to focus on a couple
of issues not to say that they're more
important than others but to show as an
example of the of the repercussions of
having a a a military policy that's a
or foreign policy that's made based on
military militarism
and one of the one of the most one of
the biggest consequences i wanna
i think one of the biggest horrors in
the last 20 years of something that this
has done it's what's going on in iraq
today and this is something i really
want to spend a minute to talk about
because i really do not want anyone to
ever forget about that as of today since
we have 1 million and 200 000 iraqis
that have been killed directly related
to sanctions
directly related to sanctions that i at
least myself i do i do i blame this this
institution right here i do a claim
blame the government and
the
the us government they tell us that the
reason they want sanctions is because to
supposedly stop someone like saddam
hussein from having weapons of mass
destruction so we went to him we tell
them okay well we have a deal for you
why don't we lift the economic sanctions
and we keep military sanctions on them
this way we can assure that they will
never have weapons of mass destruction
but you can be sure that people can eat
every month five people five thousand
people are killed because of lack of
food in a country was one of the
wealthiest nations on earth and they
said no we can't have that why not no we
just can't have that
and and this is this is a function or
this is a a consequence of when you have
a pentagon that really does not care
about humanity or a situation where
humanity is a is a is a low point on a
totem pole
i met one time with a group of p in a
with a group of people i met with
president clinton
and he said then and like he said in
millions of speeches before well because
i'm a southerner i i care about you know
race relations and equality and so on
and and i told them you know that really
has to apply throughout the whole world
we're an interconnected community now
and in any situation
especially today see in any situation
what what most people don't understand
when you when you repress people or when
you torture people when you hurt them
long enough sooner or later they're
going to lash out
so if you can have a situation an
example for example south africa during
the apartheid regime i mean the the
black south africans for many years they
didn't go out demonstrating and throwing
stones in the streets because they had
nothing better to do it's because they
felt discriminated against they felt
that they were persecuted until finally
the system is changed now where at least
theoretically you have a country where
they under and in the law they have
equal rights and you know you no longer
see south africans out there
trying to burn down things
another situation we have in the world
is israel i realize there are many jews
here and i don't mean to offend anyone
here now here's a situation
where
in the last two years they have
demolished 1200
homes for palestinians both christians
and jews
and muslims saying that we need these we
need this land so that we can house jews
from around the world now i agree
i agree that i think you know jews who
are being persecuted around the world
they should have israel as a safe haven
but you cannot do it through a racist
policy where you can you make someone
else homeless and put this in
so
so so now now you have a situation for
example
you know you take a person you demolish
his home you take his business you
demolish his business you put his child
in in jail you deprive the problem of
every means of earning a living and then
one day this guy says what the hell am i
living for i might as well just go blow
myself up
and take anyone i can take with me
because my life sucks basically
and then and then rather than react to
the
to the source to the source of these
problems they will they have contingency
plans now to deal with terrorism and one
of the side effects of it they can't
make is they can't let us come closer so
people like me
they're scared of people like me rather
than dealing with the roots of the
problem
so all i'm saying i i really honestly
when i stood up here 20 seconds ago i
had no speech i had no idea i thought
nothing i didn't know what i wanted to
say
but i guess
i guess i'm going to conclude by saying
this
if you do not
again it's it's the the world community
is getting smaller with technology the
way it is today
it's no longer europe is no longer days
away europe is is becoming now
anyway the world is becoming
interconnected
you ca either you treat everyone at an
equal level you you have an equal policy
that does not differentiate one over
another one person over the other jew is
not better than muslim muslim is not
better than christian arab is not better
than jew you will continue to have
problems yes there will be people that
will one day go blow themselves up if
you push them far enough why did these
people a few years ago was in cali in a
blacks in uh
in california they went and burned down
their own neighborhood it's not because
they they wanted to live to live in
chartres
houses
it's just a way of saying we're
frustrated we want things to change so
maybe we could look at the root of the
of most of the problems rather than
always just try to find an answer once a
problem arises that's all thanks
you know there's a fancy word that gets
thrown around a lot on the television
by politicians and corporate boardrooms
it's called globalization
but there's an old world old word that a
lot of us use and it's called
imperialism
[Music]
[Applause]
and as opposed to true internationalism
globalization is really nothing but a
fancy new word for an old word that all
of us are here to say no to
[Music]
our next speaker is someone who speaks
with a profound understanding of
imperialism
someone who comes from
the united states own colony puerto rico
and to introduce him i'll ask meg starr
to come to the microphone
hello
thank you for all being here today
it's a nice day to shut down the
pentagon a gloomy day a day the pentagon
deserves but we don't
um
i just want to say my affinity group
resistance from brooklyn is joined and
honored by being joined by dave
dellinger and paul magno in our effort
today to help shut down the pentagon and
we're dedicating our cd today to the 15
men and women of the puerto rican
independence movement who are here in
this country in prison because when
they're free they're going to be working
to get the us bases out of puerto rico
and defeat the u.s military so their
cause is our cause so i just wanted to
say in honor of them there's a puerto
rican chant where you say the name of a
prisoner and you say presente which
means they're with us in our hearts so
if you could help me do that can you say
presente
alejandrina torres
oscar lopez
cilla berrigan
thank you very much and now i wanted to
introduce luis nieves falcone dr luis
nieves falcon
anyone in the puerto rican activist
movement says oh yes he was my professor
and he's inspired me so much i became an
activist but he's not just a professor
he is also an activist he became a
lawyer only in order to be able to visit
the prisoners and work on their
international
legal arrangements and he's from puerto
rico and he's from the organization for
international human rights in puerto
rico dr luis nieves falcone
[Applause]
puerto rico had to be present in this
meeting against militarism
[Applause]
because
if anyone can talk about the impact
the pervasive impact
of militarism it is puerto rico
in puerto rico there are more military
personnel
per person
than in spain during the franco regime
in puerto rico there are more military
persons
per puerto rican
than in so than in nicaragua during the
somosa regime
why is it
that the united states has such a
display
of military force in puerto rico
because militarism is
the hand
that supports colonialism in puerto rico
militarism is the hand
that maintains oppress the puerto ricans
that is why
the american militaries in puerto rico
is all over the island
in latin america they might say
we are frightened that the u.s marines
might come into our country
the marines are in my country they are
all over my country 14 american bases in
this small island
and in addition to that
there were surveillance and persecution
of any puerto rican who
backs independence
but in addition to that
puerto rico is very important to the
american military strategy
from puerto rico
were sent the forces
that invaded cuba
the forces that invaded dominican
republic
the forces
that invaded panama
in puerto rico were trained
the forces that were to operate in iraq
afterwards so
it is not only the suppression of the
puerto ricans but it is also the use of
puerto rico as a springboard in order to
suppress freedom in other parts of the
country
for that reason
in puerto rico we who fight
against militarism
have a saying
you understand that
to help
that is we have to put out
those bases
because while the majority of the
population is poor
while more than half of the puerto
ricans have to receive food stamps you
have this all these big military
expenses puerto rico cannot be any
longer
a springboard for the american imperial
imperialistic activities
but in addition to that brothers and
sisters
it is this military
in combination with the repressive
agencies of the united states
that keeps our dissenters
that keeps our opponents
in those vastly yes where they are
inhumanly treated
we have 16
puerto rican political prisoners we have
six women we have nine men that every
day
suffer the torture of the incarceration
the most inhuman one and naturally
this has related this is related to
colonialism and militarism we have to
get rid of militarism we have to get rid
of
colonialism and only after we do that
we will be able in puerto rico
in the caribbean
and in latin america
to enjoy peace
and justice
and tranquility so
the struggle must continue because we
must assure
the peace and the tranquility of the
region and with my people
alcara
[Music]
usa out of puerto rico
usa out of puerto rico
usa out of puerto rico
usa out of puerto rico
usa out of puerto rico
thank you louise did you all notice that
at least when we started speaking the
sun came out get your sunglasses on
that was just a temporary shower to test
our festivity here whether or not we're
really strong enough and we're not made
of something that's going to go away
when the rain comes for we are here for
the long term i'm betty hoover director
of the american friends service office
here in washington dc and i'm really
pleased to be part of this event
we've been around as many you know for a
long time since 1917 working for peace
with justice
we have a couple of announcements that
i've been handed ronnie from the new
york city bus please report to the back
of the stage
and also make
[Music]
be aware
that the peacekeepers are coming around
with yellow sheets for sign in we want
to make sure that we've got
record of everyone who's been here today
with your name and address so we can
keep working together as i look around i
can connect the dots i see young and old
and and
people who are from very many different
parts of our peace community and it
seems to me that as a people are united
we can never be divided what do you
think a people united can never be
united a people united can never be
divided
a people united can never be divided
thank you all for being here today and
i'm going to bring on now a speaker
while our we have a musical group that's
going to be getting ready behind us so
try to ignore all that movement behind
us while we have bring on the next
speaker
who is david mcreynolds he's with the
socialist party he's been a long-term
time activist 40 years or so working for
peace so give your attention now to
david mcreynolds
[Applause]
you are truly the beloved community
to sit here through all that rain
i think most of you have heard that
pinochet was arrested yesterday in
london
[Applause]
i understand henry kissinger is now
fearful of traveling anywhere outside of
this country
[Applause]
we are here to speak
for the health the well-being
and the freedom
of everyone in this country
and throughout the world
we are here to set at liberty
every mother son and daughter trapped
inside that building behind you
that they might have lives that are
fruitful and useful
not only do we want to end war we want
those people freed of the burden of
carrying on militarism
we are here to speak we are here to
speak for the sick
and the cold and the hungry
in our own land
and in every part of our world
those who could be healed
and comforted and fed
with the money that is drained by the
military
we are here to challenge the nonsense
that more than 270 billion dollars is
needed to protect this country
this country has demilitarized borders
with canada and mexico
this country has enormous oceans on the
east and the west
by an accident of nature we are almost
totally uninvadable
what in the name of god do we need 270
billion dollars worth of military for
[Music]
do you know
that the money we spend on the military
is more than seven times the total spent
by every country listed as an enemy
libya iran iraq north korea cuba that
deadly island 90 miles off or add them
all up our budget is seven times more
than that
and they couldn't get here if they tried
we are a fortunate nation
we are a rich nation that is wasting our
money
why are we spending that money
why did the republicans just vote
billions of dollars additional which the
pentagon did not even ask for
for a star wars program
when we cannot even stop
planes flying across the mexican border
with marijuana and cocaine
and we're going to spend billions of
dollars on a star wars program the
reason is because that is billions of
dollars in the pockets of the corporate
structure that's our money our tax money
going into their pockets
fear is being used
fear is being used to persuade us to
give that money
we are told to be terrified of
terrorists
the most terrible
violent act of terrorism that has
occurred
in the last 10 years in this country
was carried out in oklahoma city
by an american citizen
a soldier who was trained
by the pentagon and who fought in the
gulf war
and who brought that war home and killed
so many in oklahoma city that is our own
terrorism come home to haunt us
not muslims not palestinians we
we
are the ones who have trained the
terrorists
we
we are the nation that terrorizes the
planet
[Applause]
there is a reason for this expenditure
and that is
there is i'm sorry there's a reason for
our fear of terrorism and that is
because we have imposed so much on the
world the school of the americas which
is in this country and has trained
assassins and torturers to be sent forth
to latin america central america
indonesia no wonder there are those who
are afraid that justice might come back
and haunt us that the instructions we
have taught might return home
and what drives all of this what caused
this country to send a half a million
people meant young men into vietnam and
caused two million people to die it is a
corporate structure
the corporations that are fearful of
losing their markets the corporations
that make enormous profits off of the
off of the pentagon budget
those of us who are here are not just
warby sisters league and not just
pacifists
there are also a broader coalition
including the aircraft
my friends in the socialist party are
here all the way from california
the committees of correspondence has
endorsed this rally solidarity has
endorsed this rally we have a broad base
of support not just those of us who are
in the warby sisters league let me
finally close by saying as we approach
the year 2000
what kind of society do we want do we
want to use our money to build prisons
for our youth rather than educating them
do we want a government that has been
hijacked by the corporation so that as
dave dullinger noted we have no voice
any longer in the political process the
corporate structure buys themselves of
politicians
or are we going to say the military
budget
is a theft from our children
it is a theft from the future
it is a rape of the planet and we are
going to build a movement sisters and
brothers
which can take back america and to take
it back from the corporate structure
which has stolen this land from us and
then we shall see that building behind
you that building won't be torn down
don't tear down property we're going to
transform it into a medical center which
is what it was designed for in the first
place march on
[Applause]
do we know what we want
what do we want
when do we want it
what do we want
when do we want it
we do know what we want oh right now
we're going to bring up a group from oh
actually i've got another announcement
to make since we are being broadcast
nationally we'd like to give out a
couple of telephone numbers the new york
office of the war resistors league
number is 212-228-0450
and since this is the age of electronics
also you can access them by email wrl
igc.apc.org
i'm going to bring on now a group of
activists who are speaking are working
and speaking for uh women and children
particularly
uh
they are uh rachel
rachel cornwell is going to be speaking
for the asian pacific center for justice
and peace their offices in d.c rachel
come on up
[Applause]
good afternoon
i especially wanted to speak today about
the issue of women and children in asia
and the effect of the us military
personnel
on their lives there and on the
environments in the local economies in
asia
recently there have been several high
pro high profile cases
of sexual violence against women in asia
by u.s military personnel
in 1992 uh yoon kumi who was a bar woman
in korea was brutally murdered her body
was mutilated a coke bottle was inserted
into her womb
a umbrella was inserted into her anus
and washing detergent was poured all
over her naked body
in 1995
in okinawa a 12 year old schoolgirl was
abducted by three military personnel her
hands and feet and mouth were duct taped
and she was gang raped and then left for
dead
these cases are significant because
they have galvanized local communities
to mobilize against the us military
personnel
us military presence
but in the larger picture
there are only two
of thousands and thousands of acts of
violence against women and children and
they're only part of a system of
systemic violence
that turns
young people young american people into
war machines
and encourages them
to
become part of the system especially
we're concerned about young people in
our communities of color where the us
military is recruiting very heavily
to take the
most promising young people
and encourage them to be all that they
can be
and
this is just another system of violence
and we have to work against that
we have to offer people more
opportunities
um
last week the asia pacific center for
justice and peace was very honored to
host 55 women activists from japan the
philippines korea and the united states
who converged in washington
to bring the issue of u.s military
presence and violence against women
to washington
and we had a briefing in congress and
had meetings at the state department no
one at the pentagon would see us um but
we are really encouraged that these
systems of violence against women and
children will end
and
as long as there are militaries there
will be miles there will be nan kings
but we can't stop these acts of violence
against women and children unless we end
military systems
so i think we need to think about
redefining security and demilitarizing
ourselves and our own ideas about
security the way that we've been taught
that security has to be with guns and
bombs and missiles and nuclear weapons
and i think that
this is a wonderful start and we can
all work together to revision what
security means and how we want to
protect our local communities and our
women and our children thank you
[Applause]
free asia us out free asia us out free
asian usf
[Music]
okay i think that we're ready for some
for a muse for some music mike wheaton
and his group
oh that was a nice sound mike wheaton
and this group are part of our peace
movement here in washington dc
mike is um a second generation at least
peace activist some many of you might
might know of
mike's father phil wheaton who's worked
with us on many issues so mike comes to
us today with a group called haleo they
are a latin funk rock jazz kind of group
and never quite can put a name on them
but i think you'll enjoy them let's give
a warm welcome to mike wheaton and
[Applause]
all hello now we're getting a little bit
of water dropped on us here but uh we're
going to try to start something out that
you can sing along too
puerto rico
[Music]
stands beside
[Music]
me
[Music]
no
together
we shall not be moved
black and white together
we shall not be moved
[Music]
do
[Music]
just like a tree that stands beside the
water
[Music]
m
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks
[Applause]
one thing we try to do in this band is
mix uh salsa and rock as you can tell
we like to try to do an original song it
talks about
the powers it be and the things they uh
the things they do wrong
it's called blue light
[Applause]
okay
do you need to play with your volume can
i put it on the floor
take your
oh wait
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fences when the cops pulled him over
said son where have you
[Music]
been attitude
[Music]
yeah the love falls down again
making every last one of us
[Music]
there don't seem to be no angels
coming down like
that falling down
[Music]
down
[Music]
[Music]
falls down again
[Music]
they don't
[Music]
more monitoring the more piano in the
modders
[Music]
[Applause]
more piano in the monitors
[Music]
hell they can hardly breathe
factory said they met the standard
all things could improve
diana can't afford a lawyer
and the company suggests she moved
yeah my law falls down again
such defendable
[Music]
yeah the law falls down again
every last
[Music]
coming down
[Music]
down
[Music]
we don't need a bunch of cops to bust us
don't need no experts to take a stand
we just want a little bit of justice
if you want some justice to scrap yeah
we don't need a bunch of fools to rob us
don't need no experts to take us there
we just want
[Music]
hey
is
[Music]
hey
[Music]
is
[Music]
you want some justice let's clap your
head
[Music]
you want some mercy subscribe
[Music]
thank you mucha gracie
[Applause]
[Applause]
i don't know if anybody uh noticed well
i'm sure you did we announced it at the
concert yesterday and i'm sure you've
heard it by now
uh general pinochet of chile was
arrested in england
we'd like to uh
dedicate a couple of songs to that one
is to uh violeta para
who was a chilean folk singer
during that time period
a song called thanks to life gracias
[Applause]
one
two three
[Music]
is
[Music]
today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Music]
fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
yes
[Music]
is
[Music]
we might need people to hold the tent
down thank you he's gonna go flying away
from us
thank you amongst other things
thanks guys
[Music]
well getting a little bit more rain here
trying to hold up
[Music]
there's another song this time we're
going to sing
a little song for the generals here this
is called
and the translation is
that general that general that fools you
that kills you
that eats you
um
rise up rise up we've got the ability to
rise up against them that's right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um stuff that
we're gonna play an original tune here
anything amy
[Music]
every strand of a braided hair
but it's so hard to get shamey on the
worm
lying beside ourselves
[Music]
i didn't fall in love
[Music]
hey
anything baby
[Music]
a year ago
[Music]
she woke a double shift trying to make
ends meet
she still sometimes thinks she's gone
around the bench
[Music]
hey
[Music]
anything
[Music]
i know mistakes can shake us off
and you wake up
[Music]
you confused change
[Music]
what do i know
what do i know about love
i know mistakes can shake your soul
wake up confused
[Music]
you don't change
[Music]
this is
[Music]
but i don't understand
[Music]
you gotta
believe want you to know whatever the
next day brings i'll be watching
[Music]
any
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like to introduce the band members over
here on drums
we have alejandro
[Applause]
i met alejandra about five years ago and
he's the man
on base we have a adriana lastra
de puerto rico
and i met her about five years ago and
she's the woman
[Applause]
and i'm my
santo
queen
and he writes it all he does it all he
plays it all
you ain't seen him played nothing yet
[Applause]
well i hope you don't um don't mind all
the songs in spanish we're gonna do one
that you know anyway so
whether you speak it or not you know
this tune
do
[Music]
my
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now that everybody's having fun and
dancing we'll do a little bit more of
this
there's another original song the um
bass player cooked up a couple of weeks
ago
isn't it fun how music suits
[Music]
[Music]
be
[Music]
love
[Music]
do
[Music]
alejandro
[Music]
adriana
[Music]
do
[Music]
i like it like that
[Music]
a
[Music]
thank you very
of the new much war resistors local the
root and branch collective
and
i'm in what about
okay hi
um so our local root and branch
collective is here from new jersey and
i'm very honored to introduce a member
of our local root and branch as well as
a member of the war resistors league
executive committee sachio ko yin who
did a direct action direct action for
disarmament this past august thank you
very much here's satya
hello there friends i apologize if my uh
voice is not doing too well today i see
there's some interesting things
happening way back there i wonder what's
happening um but i'm sure maybe we'll be
able to figure that out a little bit
later
um i just wanted to tell you that on
august 6 i went with my friend daniel
seekin to a missile silo a minute man 3
missile silo and at that place
we drew a broken rifle on the silo lid
and we
painted a mural on the silo lid
and
in full solidarity with this upcoming
action of the day without the pentagon
we began not out of a spirit of anger
not out of the spirit of vengeance
but out of a spirit of creation out of a
spirit of beginning a process of
disarmament with our gentle
sledgehammers we began to symbolically
disarm this weapon of indiscriminate
mass destruction
and as we ceremonially beat with our
sledgehammers this
minuteman three
we had a sense of profound peace and a
sense of perhaps the beginning of real
disarmament
so
to make a long story short we're
expecting our trial on
november 2nd to take place perhaps we
will take
have as much as six and a half years in
prison due to a sabotage charge which
might be filed with the grand jury even
as we speak
um
but uh
this has brought about a wonderful
opportunities for speaking in colorado
in fact even in in uh
even to the air force academy uh we will
be speaking on that day uh as soon as i
get back on the 21st so it's been a
wonderful process and again in our
statement we mentioned the day without
the pentagon and this day is of such a
great value and such importance and
again i see such amazing things
happening way back there i guess we'll
have to wonder
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
people do know that folks have a range
of different ways to protest and justice
and we know that some of the folks who
were planning to come to this event were
planning to consider disobedience we had
an action recording which people talked
about earlier and it looks like some of
the groups are also doing some actions
right now
i want to tell you who's coming up next
in terms of speakers but i have one
little brief announcement if any of the
folks within the sound of my voice are
planning to ride home with mario hardy
they need to come to the backstage area
also want to let people know to please
try to pick up after yourself so that
the crew of folks that we have available
for the rest of the afternoon for the
next hour or so doesn't spend another
hour after that so we really appreciate
that we have coming up next someone
who's come from what is now my hometown
of new york city he's an attorney he's
also acting with the local chapter of
the national association of korean
americans john kim following kim will be
sachikomitsu
has come to us from linking peace and
life all the way from japan and
following her sonja ostrom
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
good afternoon everybody uh somebody are
joining the secret digital business
section but uh those who wanna
you know
just listen to the speeches you're
welcome to listen to my speech
as a korean american
as a american patron i'm very honored to
be here today
speak
on issues of the world and peace and
busy
[Applause]
special thank you to world registry
league for organizing today's rally
[Applause]
activity
[Applause]
by the way you know when i wasn't coming
down i was
called by david letterman and he asked
me here
can i think of a top 10
for pentagon and i
talked about something about the top 10
for the battle
number 10
pantheon is the largest
polluter in the world
number nine
the biggest
king
the biggest pig in the world
number eight
the worst source of terrorism
number seven the cesspool of racism
number six
the worst pimp for military prostitute
prostitution around the world
number five
the biggest merchant of death
number four
the most
ferocious aggression
number three
the best friend of the military
dictatorship
number two
the worst manufacturer of weapons of
mass destruction
number one
the world champion of militarism and
military waste
you know as you know
the pentagon prices recently asked
for more military money
and
surprisingly
the u.s congress
and the president
agreed to give
about nine billion dollar ball
for the pentagon
isn't this a great tragedy
this outrageous
pork barrel giveaway
of our tax money
to the military industrial complex
in this country
at the time
when the core way is over
and we are only
the remaining superpower in the world
proves again that the military
industrial campus
is the real rulers
and masters of america today
how
much arjuna was
right when he won
the accessible military power
of american military industrial complex
when he stepped down from the presidency
some 40 years ago
and how sad
he would be today
in looking at the incredible waste of a
pentagon
and
it's a happy bad partner the republican
party
according to a
report of the center
for defense information
our annual military spending
is about
500 billion
if we include our foreign military sales
veterans benefits
and our interest on the past military
spending
to finance this huge military spending
and achieve a balanced budget at the
same time
the republican-controlled congress
has been cutting back
on our
our basic benefits for the poor
disabled and the children
raising taxes
on the working families
and the legal immigrant as well
are you aware
that the ins recently
checked up its various application fees
anywhere from 30 percent to 400 400
percent
the naturalization application fee
will go up by 150 percent in coming
january
from present 95 to 250
this is nothing more than
another way of raising taxes
upon the most powerless
vulnerable people in this country
this corridor attack of the
establishment
on the working poor disabled
and the immigrants
is
not surprising
at all if we look at
the past
ugly history of what uncle sam has done
in the third world
how many bombs did we drop on korea
vietnam cambodia and laos
how many asian people
did we kill and cold blood
in the name of national security
just in the korean war alone
u.s military dropped more bombs on korea
than all the american bombs dropped
during the world war ii
and the pentagon is still keeping
about 40 000 american
gis in south korea today
some 45 years after the ceasefire
of the korean war
do you know how much we spend for our
military presence in korea
some said it's three billion dollars a
year
but the the true cost
is 23 billion a
year if we add
our military costs
for japan
the total
spending
for the pentagon
in maintaining the status quo in the
east asia
is about 50 billion a year
and
there are many
scenes of the pentagon that you can name
it
but one of the deadliest scenes of the
pentagon is that it has
refused to sign
the landmine treaty
that has been
signed by more than 130 nations around
the world
and
the reason they say
they refuse to sign this landmine treaty
is that they want to protect the lives
of american gis in south korea
now does that this mean
the korean people's life is less worthy
than american gis
and this is a classic example
of american racism
that is
the in the background of american
militarism
by refusing to sign this a
landmine treaty
we are becoming another outlaw
a local nation
in the international community
landmine is nothing more than
another weapon of mass
destruction in slow motion
how can we condemn iran for its
development of weapons of mass
destruction
while we are keeping
and threatening the use of all kinds of
weapons of mass destruction
pentagon's refusal to sign the land mine
trees is nothing more than
another
military sharpening
okay
uh in something up
that i would like to
say
that the uh
history teaches us that we cannot
overcome american racism
without subduing american militarism
and i'm deeply moved
that there are many courageous american
peace activists today
who are willing to stand up
against the dark forces of american
militarism
and you are good examples of such of
just forces for peace
in this world
i applaud the feather baron of daniel
bergen
and other pleasure brothers and sisters
i applaud those peace activists
who are arrested in trying to shut down
the school ameri of americas i
approached those peace activists who
were arrested this morning at the
pentagon
i also approached
those
53 anti-land mine peace activists
who were arrested on october 7
in blocking the entrance to the alliance
tax system in minnesota
alliance tech is the largest producer
and contract with a pentagon
in producing anti-personnel landmines
on october 8th the next day
19 more people were arrested at the
alliance corporation entrance
among those arrests were
three juveniles
and three sisters of mercy
ages 72 73 and 74.
let's give a hand to these courageous
and just warriors
and in closing
i would like to make some suggestions
first
let's make this kind of anti-military
peace rally on annual event
second
next year let's meet at the capitol hill
first and have a rally there
and then march to pentagon
number three
let's build up anti-military anti-racist
peace coalition at the home and abroad
number four
let's run more people
for u.s congress
who believe in peace and justice
we cannot leave our congress
to those shameless greedy corrupted
hawks
who sell out to the military industrial
complex
number five
let's set up a national legal defense
fund in support of those who engage in
civil disobedient disobedience
[Applause]
u.s militarism
down with the pentagon
down with the u.s racism cut the
military's budget in half
bring our boys home
please dividend now
she is now
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
just a moment please
[Music]
my name is sachiko mitsunagar
i came from japan to attend a day
without a pentagon
with nagi fujita
at the delegates of linking peace and
life it's my great pleasure to give an
address to you on behalf of the chairman
toshki mameta
and our 400 members
first of all
i'd like to express our sincere support
to your goal and actions to fight
against military armaments and violence
which create nothing
for human peace and happiness
your movement in the united states
has similar concerns with our movement
in japan
please understand
that today's military strength of japan
has been built up with the strong
support of the united states
after the world war ii
japan resumed its armaments in 1950
and now our troops called self-defense
force has grown up to be the strongest
army in asia
with high-tech equipments
on the same level of the u.s forces
without nuclear weapons
also japan is spending the second
largest military budget in the world
in april 1996
president clinton and prime minister
hashimoto
issued the joint declaration on security
treaty
to redefine the u.s japan uh
sorry joint declaration on security to
redefine the u.s japan security treaty
and agreed to revise its old guidelines
and in september 1997
the revised guideline for u.s japan
defense corporation was released
the content of the text was clearly a
war manual
furthermore in september 1998 last month
both governments agreed on proceeding
toward conducting joint research on
developing the theater missile defense
system tmd system giving north korea
street as an excuse
all of them are violation of the
constitution of japan which declares the
renunciation
of war
relating the new guidelines
a bill called situation in areas
surrounding japan has already been
introduced in the diet in order to
legalize all kinds of logistic support
and military cooperation of japan
it is evident
that our government aims to make it
possible to dispatch japanese troops
abroad at any time anywhere by this
legislation
however on the other hand
it is also true that our self-defense
force has never but
participated in any actual finding since
this formation in 1950
and also
they have never killed anyone
even just only one man for this half a
century
i think this is completely different
from your troops
it is because the constitution the
renunciation of war existed in our
background
this is a prize of peace loving people
in japan
so we must not allow passage of any
guidelines related bills in this coming
session on the diet
in order to block passage of the bill
situation of areas surrounding japan
we will hold a joint lottery on october
21st in tokyo and osaka with some labor
unions and peace groups
in this situation removal of u.s bases
from japan
especially from okinawa
has become much more essential and
indispensable to stop u.s japan military
actions
so your peace actions like a day without
a pentagon are extremely encouraging for
japanese people for struggling who are
struggling against their government
because the u.s government is the best
supporter
and the best partner
of our government which is going to send
troops overseas and use the armed force
that's why we came here pentagon today
in addition to this armament we have
another important duty in japan
that is to make our government to take
the responsibility for japan's past
invasion of asia-pacific region
during the world war ii and to realize
full apology and compensation to all
victims
because japan japanese government has
never taken any responsibility for their
war crimes such as sexual slavery of
so-called comfort women forced labor
nanjing muscle medical experiments by
unit 731
mild treatment or personal awards
poison gas chemical weapons and so on
these crimes have already been denounced
in the international society and more
than 20 lawsuits have been filed to
demand the government's apology and
state compensation for korean chinese
and other asian victims
our group has also been supporting some
suits on forced labor of drafted koreans
however
japanese government still refuses all
claims from these victims
we think japan must preach not to repeat
invasion of any countries by making
sincere apology and full individual
compensation for their past war crimes
linking the issue of disarmament with
the issue of world responsibility is a
policy of a movement of linking peace
and life
brothers and sisters our american
friends
how nice to hear that the grassroots
anti-war
peace movements exist in both sides of
the pacific ocean
let's keep a good fight to knock down
the u.s japan military alliance and
let's make a great advance for peace and
justice together thank you
[Applause]
hi
my name is sonja ostrom and i'm
representing two groups today i'm
representing peace action
and i'm representing abolition 2000 so
you'll notice i do have two heads
and
what i do believe in
is complete
complete
nuclear
disarmament
and we have to work for that
i think if there's nothing else that's
going to happen in the year 2000 it's
work that abolition 2000 is doing and
the rest they have a thousand
organizations in the network around the
world
and the time has come to put the genie
back in the bottle it's time to get rid
of all nuclear weapons all over the
world
when
fr when uh pakistan and india
tested they tested because they had been
trying to get the united states to sign
up to do something even a little bit to
show that they would be
working toward nuclear abolition and
they couldn't get them to do it now
they're the ones who are saying yeah
we'll sign the treaty we'll do it we
signed a non-proliferation treaty and
what do we do we spend money on
stockpile stewardship
we pretend that we have to keep our
stockpile up to date and so what we do
is spend billions billions of dollars
to make sure that we have lab equipment
to do testing that we call subcritical
testing so we cheat and lie and steal
and do everything wrong
and get away with it and spend billions
of dollars that could be used as you all
know for really good purposes in this
world there's no reason why we should
allow this country to rule the world and
to rule the world with this nuclear
power we've gotta get rid of it and
we've gotta get rid of it now
jacques cousteau said
that if
chemical weapons and biological weapons
are weapons of evil then certainly
nuclear weapons have to get
are the most dangerous weapons of all
and they must be gotten rid of so that's
where we're at and we're working
the year 2000 to have what we call a
nuclear
uh convention
that is uh we don't we know that by the
year 2000 we're not going to get rid of
nuclear weapons no matter what we do
today
but the time has come
and we have enough
real
interest throughout the world 87 percent
of the united states says we don't want
nuclear weapons and yet the government
doesn't listen because they make so much
money on it
and they have been putting billions into
livermore labs so that again they can do
more testing and come up with bigger and
more horrible kinds of weapons and we've
got to stop that we really must do
something every organization that's here
should be joining abolition 2000 because
it's a network it's not an organization
it really is just every group saying yes
we agree we want to get rid of nuclear
weapons that's the first and primary aim
of what's happening in the world today
and not just here in this country but
all over we know
that there is no excuse
that we can't use such weapons
that we are it is totally immoral and
that we certainly can't tell other
countries that they can't have them
while we keep them and keep them on the
alert and right
now the problem of what's going to
happen with computers in the year 2000
it's pretty frightening because we could
have an accident just because of the
change
of
what
in 2 000.
um
52k right
and when that happens
we know
that
the government has already said well
we'll treat it as a tornado
and if that doesn't work well
we might destroy the world
and they think it's a joke
but it's not a joke and we really do
have to do something about seeing to it
that there are
no
more nuclear weapons that kind of power
does not give us hope that kind of power
does not feed children all over the
world that kind of power does not put
books in the classroom paint on the wall
so this government can say that it's all
right
all right not to paint and fix up
schools and then we complain when our
children don't do well how can they do
well sitting on broken chairs and filthy
classrooms and then we expect them to
learn
they can't learn under those conditions
and no one should be expected to and we
have to learn where our priorities
really are and do something about them
we have got to get rid of all nuclear
weapons thank you
well i have an update
people recall that 23 people
expressing their right to dissent in the
united states expressing their outrage
at the abusive military spending at the
pentagon and expressing their real
concern about growing militarism this
morning 23 people were arrested doing
civil disobedience actions i have
information that back there this
afternoon seven more people were
arrested people are continuing to
protest back there some folks are
starting to come back and so we want to
make sure that we continue the program
here in addition remember that everyone
who comes up here speaking is not just
speaking to whoever's here we're
speaking to whoever is at home watching
on c-span so we've got that national
audience and for that reason we're going
to go ahead continue the program the
next speakers up i believe are the most
important here you know very often
people will say youth are our future
youth are not our future because they're
here already they're providing
leadership they're providing inspiration
and strong words and one of the most
active groups of young people fighting
war and militarism in the us are people
in youth peace and they're coming up
next
[Applause]
oh
my name is derek francis and i'm helping
to represent youth peace thank you
got it
we are youth peace
we are a national group of youth working
to end militarism racism sexism
homophobia and classism through
non-violent action
we serve
as a microphone to amplify the voices of
our peers we say violence is not a
solution to anything and so we work to
provide our peers with non-violent
alternatives
today we affirm the strength and truth
and
today we affirm the strength and truth
in our own voices and our steadfastness
and hope as youth
tells us that our voices will be
responded to with action
when we are small we often ask the
question why
without reservation
as we grow older we are taught to
abandon one ability to question in favor
of blind acceptance
as youth piece the questions we ask
increase every day
[Applause]
why do we care more about oil than iraqi
children
why do we continue
to allow the military to use youth to
kill and be killed carrying out their
racist economic policies
[Music]
why do we have money to spend on jrotc
in our schools
meanwhile our schools are unsafe
crumbling our books are out of date and
our teachers are untrained
[Music]
why are people of color like james burns
still being murdered by racism
[Applause]
why are women still being battered raped
and murdered by their male partners
[Music]
why are youth allowed to be brutalized
criminalized and repressed by racist
police
and i'd like to know why young people
and old people and people in between are
being met with such brutal force up at
the pentagon when they're showing
non-violent protest exercising their
democratic rights to free speech it's
because this institution trains people
to meet force with force to kill
and we need to teach people in this
country to love to have an open mind to
show understanding instead of close your
eyes and smack you down
[Music]
we know that they don't have anything we
need inside that building we know that
the answers to our questions we're only
going to find them in the action that
we're taking here today and that the
action you all are going to go home and
do in your communities after today
[Music]
word as youth peace we're rejecting the
system of violence that's murdering us
around the world and we've turned our
hearts and our minds into demilitarized
zones so we can go out and do this work
free of all the oppression around us
and we're going to continue to agitate
and organize until it's all over
we are youth peace we are not only the
future we are also the president and
we're demanding change now
please remember that last line they are
not just the future they are the now so
in your organizations don't treat young
people as if when you all grow up we'll
deal with you deal with them now you'll
find that's where the leadership is
we have just a couple more speakers and
i want to speak to the importance of
information as power of knowledge as
power we've got a national audience
today with this live broadcast by c-span
we've got a number of other news outlets
here and videotape and radio and audio
tapes going around but it's important
also that we have people rooted in the
movement creating the information that
goes out around the country and around
the world our next speaker is a
journalist who focuses on human rights
on peace and non-violence issues and he
has some inspiring words for you alan
now
[Applause]
thank you
right now inside
the pentagon
and in hundreds
of american bases
u.s bases around the world
there are hundreds of thousands
of citizens of the united states
who are working
inside the american military apparatus
there are also many over at the
cia
inside the state department
there are many people
inside these
bases and buildings
who joined the military
who signed up
because i think
they wanted to fight for freedom
defend the
country up for the underdog
and these are noble goals
if you ask most americans
what the united states stands for
overseas
many would say
well that's what we do
when injustice is being done
when
the weak are being crushed by the strong
the united states
comes in
to help
and maybe sometimes we try to help too
much but that's the mission
we try to bring
to people overseas
freedom and civil liberties
as people
enjoy them here
now that's a great idea
it would be a good thing if it were true
but unfortunately
[Applause]
sadly
and lethally for many people around the
world
that is not in fact
the work that is being done by the
pentagon the cia and the state
department
in case after case
it's not that the ideals
that so many americans believe in
freedom justice are wrong
those are right the problem is
that those who run the united states
those who make the policy
president clinton
the secretaries of state and defense the
leadership of congress
have continued a long-standing practice
of the united states
of being willing to use violence
terror torture and massacre
against people in countless countries
because they stand up for freedom
because they ask for justice
because they criticize regimes
that are allies of washington
in east timor
a small nation between australia and
indonesia
in 1975
the people of timor who were seeking
independence
after years of colonial domination
were suddenly confronted by american
c-130s
flying over the beaches of dilly the
capital of east timor
out of those planes they're dropped
indonesian military paratroops
armed with freshly supplied us machine
guns and m-16s
they were landing on the beaches of
timor because just 16 hours before
president gerald ford and henry
kissinger
had given the go-ahead to suharto the
military dictator of neighboring
indonesia to stage this invasion of east
timor
and as president ford
stood at pearl harbor
commemorating pearl harbor day for this
was on december 7th 1975
as he was giving a speech
saying that never again should the world
tolerate sneak attacks the u.s must be
the guarantor of peace in asia as this
was happening
those u.s armed those u.s sanctioned
those u.s financed indonesian aubry
troops
were sweeping into the homes of dilly
and dragging people out bringing them
down to the harbor down to the
aryabranca the white sand beach and were
shooting them into the sea with those
freshly supplied us weapons
that was the beginning
of the most what is perhaps the most
intensive proportional genocide since
the nazis
a third of the population of east timor
has been massacred since then
by the indonesian armed forces
which have been armed financed and
politically backed by every
administration from ford up through
clinton
that occupation continues to this day
to this day the u.s continues to block
the united nations from taking action to
enforce the two nc two united nations
security council resolutions that call
on indonesia to withdraw the indonesian
government to withdraw its troops
without delay
in 1991 i happen to have
the chance that few citizens of this
country have
to witness things from the other end of
the m16
you could say that we're linked to
people in places like east timor by a
metaphorical m16
we're here at the trigger end where the
decisions get made inside buildings like
the pentagon
as to whether the bullet gets pulled
in team where they're at the accident
where the bullet comes out
on november 12 in 91 the timorese held a
procession
from the motel catholic church the santa
cruz cemetery on the other side of town
thousands of people came out
led by young people waving
banners that defended their church that
called for freedom that talked about the
two hundred thousand dead
there were nuns at the head of the
procession singing hymns and when they
got to the cemetery the aubry the
indonesian armed forces marched on them
in formation 12 to 15 abreast wielding
american m16s
they swept upon the crowd which was
hemmed in by the cemetery walls
and they opened fire on that crowd
they gunned the people down
because they were gathered in protest as
as we're gathered here
and they didn't stop until that road was
slick with blood
i was standing there in the middle of it
i was there with amy goodman from wbai
pacifica radio we were standing between
the soldiers and the timorese
but they just
enveloped us swept around us and opened
fire
and then
as they were continuing to slaughter the
timorese the soldiers put the rifles to
our heads seven or eight of them there
were hundreds perhaps thousands of
troops there and all
it seemed they were deciding whether to
execute us
but it seems that the thing that turned
the tide was when we convinced them that
we were from the united states
the same country their weapons were from
i think they realized that there might
be trouble there might be a political
price to pay if you executed americans
it's the u.s after all that's the was
the patron of the suharto dictatorship
that is to this day the patron of the
aubry which continues to repress and
terrorize inside indonesia as well as
occupied timor
they'd never paid a price for killing
timorese they were slaughtering the
timorese right in front of us but
perhaps they would be trouble if they
killed americans
so they lifted the rifles from our heads
we were able to escape from the scene
later that day report the massacre to
the outside world but the timorese were
trapped on the road at least 271 dead
if this were an
exception
it would be one thing
but unfortunately
this is the rule
dozens upon dozens of other examples
of where the u.s
foreign policy and military
establishment particularly its
paramilitary sector
a string of some 180 military bases
including places like the school of the
americas but the school of the americas
is also the only the beginning
facilities at places like camp perry in
virginia
quantico and virginia
where intelligence and military
operatives from around the world are
brought in and given training
where u s operatives are sent out to
places like guatemala
where for decades
the us has armed and trained and
financed the hedos the g2 the guatemalan
military intelligence service that has
coordinated the assassinations and
disappearances
that together with the massacres in the
mayan highlands have claimed some 120
000 lives
at the g2 base in hue tango
in the northwest they actually have a
crematorium
to dispose of the bodies the tortured
bodies
but that didn't stop the cia that didn't
stop the pentagon
from sending in north american trainers
to work inside the g2
to improve their technique
same in neighboring honduras battalion
316
a military death squad that in the 80s
was implicated in dozens of
assassinations and disappearances
trained by u.s army rangers in texas
trained by the c i a
the nicaraguan contras sent into
nicaragua
responsible for some
sixty thousand civilian deaths
general galvin the commander of us u.s
southern command said at the time
that they were being deployed to go
after soft targets
co-ops
farms schools where people couldn't
shoot back
in salvador el salvador
i had the opportunity to interview a man
named general chele medrano
former army chief of staff former head
of the national guard
who described to me in 13 hours of taped
interviews how he
working with the american green berets
the c i a the state department
established the salvadoran death squad
apparatus first during the kennedy then
johnson administrations
continuing on up through the 80s and mid
90s
his account verified by dozens of other
interviews
so you would actually have u s trainers
at the salvador and army general staff
i interviewed a man named ricardo castro
a salvador and company commander
who was placed on the cia payroll
served as a translator for one of these
north american trainers
who would give instruction to people
from the treasury police national police
national guard
in interrogation techniques including
electroshock torture
more recently in haiti
a group called the frapp
a paramilitary terrorist group
launched at the behest
of the defense intelligence agency
the chief of the frapp emanuel constant
carried on the payroll
of the cia
as the frapp was going in to see soleil
in port-au-prince setting it on fire
abducting people like mrs alert belance
a rice seller who was a backer of the
popular movement hacking off her hand
with a machete
i interviewed ponstant i interviewed the
intelligence people who worked with them
it's a verified fact that he was on the
cia payroll
as his group was carrying out these
terrorist acts first under bush then
under clinton
you know there's talk now of impeaching
president clinton
there's talk now of
bringing him to justice
for matters concerning sex
if this were civilized country
if we were part of a civilized
international order
we would be discussing today
president clinton not in that light
but in the light that they're now
discussing pinochet in spain and britain
general pinochet apparently justice has
just caught up with him
just been arrested in britain
on the basis of an order from a spanish
magistrate
calling him to account for the thousands
of disappearances and assassinations
under his command
that's a good thing
it makes sense to apply international
law
across borders even to high officials
when president bush a number of years
ago said that saddam hussein should be
put on trial for crimes against humanity
because of what saddam hussein has done
to the people of iraq and kuwait
i agree
it's a good idea
but if you're going to talk about
applying international law
you have to be even-handed
you have to be fair you have to be
objective
and if you're going to say that the law
should apply to saddam hussein
and he should not be exempt just because
he's a head of state
you also have to be willing to say that
it should apply to george bush
that it should apply to bill clinton
that it should apply to secretary cohen
inside the pentagon secretary cohen
earlier this year flew into jakarta
as brave young people were coming out
into the streets of indonesia
calling for democracy calling for
freedom
as they were facing the guns of the
aubry the indonesian armed forces
u.s trainers from the jset program
sent out of this building
were flying in to instruct those troops
in techniques including advanced
advanced assassins advanced sniper
technique
military operations in urban terrain
air assault
sea assault
psychological operations
as this was going on secretary cohen
flew into jakarta
he met with general proboa one of the
most notorious of the indonesian
generals who's also the indonesian
business partner of merrill lynch
went to his copas headquarters
the home of the commandos who've been
implicated in massacres
and extrajudicial executions and
tortures and occupied timor in west
papua in aceh
and patted them on the back
promising them continued u.s training
and
assistance in the nuremburg decisions
it is stated that those to be held
accountable for crimes against humanity
include not just the principles meaning
those who pull the trigger
but also accomplices
including politicians or statesmen
and we all know what an accomplice is
if you give a gun to someone they rob a
gas station they shoot the clerk you're
an accomplice
if they come back and tell you and you
give them another gun and this happened
say 70 000 times as it did in salvador
120 000 times as it did in guatemala
200 000 times as it has an occupied east
timor you're definitely an accomplice
that describes
fairly precisely the relationship
between the senior u.s officials
and atrocities on the ground now this is
what not what the american people have
chosen
you know there are many cases in history
where great atrocities have been
committed with public support
slavery in the united states the white
american public knew about it
it was fine with them they let it go
hitler had popular support in germany
these things happen historically
but i believe that is not the case in
the contemporary united states
it is not the case that the american
public has been asked
okay
do you think it's a good idea to be
giving instruction and electroshock
torture
do you think it's a good idea to be
giving training an advanced sniper
technique to an army that's now
confronting a popular uprising for
democracy in the streets
do you think it's a good idea to be
gunning down people with american m16s
in front of the santa cruz cemetery
simply because they had the courage
to stand up and ask for freedom
i think if that question were posed to
most americans they would say no
but because of the way the american
press
has failed to do its job
because of the way the american
political system
has failed to bring these facts home to
the american public that question has
not been asked
you can't be morally outraged about
something you've never heard about
people are not going to be marching on
the pentagon about east timor if they
don't know the facts
but to the extent that we are able to
get the facts out
to the extent that we are able to talk
to people
there's a very powerful case to make
a case that i think decent americans
across political lines this is not a
matter of left or right democrat or
republican liberal or conservative
it's not a matter of whether you're a
member of the military or not whether
you're a veteran or not
anyone who believes in certain very
basic principles we shouldn't be gunning
down unarmed civilians
we shouldn't be driving people into
hunger by imposing repressive regimes
anyone who believes in that
can rally behind the cause of saying
enough with this policy
enough with this multi-billion dollar
paramilitary apparatus
the trains were people in repression
we can stop it if enough stand up
the case of east timor is a good example
thousands of people around the country
have organized have mobilized put
pressure on congress working through a
bipartisan coalition
and through groups like the east timor
action network we've succeeded in
cutting off much of the military
training and weapons sales
that has weakened the confidence of the
indonesian army
it's helped to some extent the people
who are now out in the streets in
jakarta now on this out in the streets
in dilly risking their lives
and actually having a real chance for
winning their freedom within the coming
months
right now their bills in the congress
which you can
support
a measure h.r 3802 by representative
loewy to cancel
ban all military training
to regimes like the indonesian aubry
regime
h.r 39 18 by representative mckinney
to cut off the weapons spare parts
ammunition
h.r 258
by representative loewy and many others
to endorse self-determination a free
election for east team war
you can hook up with groups like the
east timor action network which you can
reach at 914-428-7299
that's 914-428-7299
you can hook up with groups like the
school of the americas watch which this
november is going to
return to fort benning
say
we don't want to be training
a new generation of repressive forces
before it was salvador
now it's troops coming up from mexico
from colombia from elsewhere where the
next wave of paramount paramilitary
repression is being prepared
people at the other end of the m16
in places like
haiti
east timor
indonesia
they're doing all they can
they risk their lives when they stand up
they risk their families
but they can't demonstrate on the
streets of the united states they can't
vote in american elections
they can't pressure american
corporations
they can't reach out to people in this
country and say do you know what's being
done in your name really
do you know what's really being done
with your tax dollars
if we pose that question
to enough americans
i think we'll get a powerful answer back
an answer that can shake this building
and lift some of those m16s from the
heads of people in so many countries
abroad
so thanks for coming out
also finally
if any of you are interested
in hooking up with a new group that
we're trying to get off the ground that
would complement the work of the
existing groups
and try to mobilize new constituents
beyond the existing activists
people like veterans people like
immigrants and refugees from countries
where the u.s has backed repression
workers and communities endangered by
capital flight
with the fact we shut down and head off
to places like indonesia and haiti in
search of more repressed labor
forces please
there's a group called justice for all
just getting going
if you're interested in this you can
contact justice for all at box 20363
new york new york 10025 that's box
20363 new york new york 1025.
it's a very simple question
it's a pocketbook issue
because this undermines jobs and
communities when you back repression
especially labor repression overseas and
it's a moral issue it's a matter of
simple decency it's something that
decent people everywhere including
any who might happen to work inside this
building including any in military bases
if you don't believe in gunning down
people who speak for justice and speak
for freedom
if you think the u.s should get out of
their way
take the m16s away from them
then stand up and say so when we can
stop it thank you
that's here for alan he sounds to me
like he's telling us how our tax dollars
have been working for us right
well it sounds like we need a revolution
what do you think
[Applause]
we have a request for him to repeat the
names of the organizations the ways to
contact ellen okay i guess the plane was
going over uh for these teamwork action
network the phone number is
914-428-7299 that's 914-428-7299
and for the justice for all group uh box
20363 new york new york 10025.
thank you
okay and now to talk to us about
revolution
violently of course is devin who is a
young poet songwriter singer from the
twin oaks community in virginia let's
listen and
join along with devon with revolution
thank you
[Music]
that's great thanks
uh
can they hear me
you all hear me
get my feedback oh there it is
[Music]
so i was just playing up there oh
ah my seat's buzzing
um i was just playing up there on that
wall it was pretty it's pretty exciting
i know
yeah it wasn't it was all right but i
was gonna play the same song that i
played up
i'm just gonna there on doing this while
i'm playing
do you think
okay
this is tracy chapman's song
it's called uh talking about a
revolution
what do y'all think of revolution
you think so
come on now
little bit of smiles or something maybe
[Music]
hear my guitar right
now guitar
don't you know
talking about a revolution
sounds like a whisper
don't you know
talking about a revolution
sound
like a big yell
while they're standing in the welfare
line
crying at the doorsteps of those armies
of salvation
wasting time in the unemployment lines
sitting around
waiting for a promotion
don't you know
talking about a revolution
poor people gonna rise up
and take what's theirs oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
four people gonna rise up
and get their [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
finally the tables are starting to turn
talking about a revolution
finally the tables are starting to turn
talking about a
revolutionary while they're standing in
the welfare lines
crying at the doorsteps of those armies
of salvation
wasting time
in the unemployment line
sitting around
waiting for a promotion
don't you know
talking about a
revolutionary sound
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
oh the sun is right in my eyes
oh thank you
so i was thinking paxus was like you
want to play and i was like yeah yeah i
want to play but like
i don't i've only written like a few
songs obviously that wasn't mine
and um
i must admit a lot of them are kind of
like self-obsessed like i'm doing this
i'm doing that as opposed to like we're
revolutionary so i was trying to think
of like
there's a song i really like by gillian
welch
that um right on
i don't even know what like it's
released on but um it's called patiently
waiting it doesn't really have to do
with it but like the concept like
patiently waiting
anyways
it's about being finished patiently
waiting
thought that was kind of appropriate
because like
we don't really want to wait around and
we're certainly not patient are we no no
no
[Music]
well nothing new has passed this way in
a long time
maybe nothing's ever gonna come
and nothing seems to grow outside my
window
i guess i better go and get me some
well i wanna get some other gold in the
hills that's making people nervous you
know they get scared of the cold and the
chill start praying god preserve us i
can't believe how long i've stayed two
more days till i get paid and i find
that small town boy i'm dating tell him
i'm done patient twitter
[Music]
well i've had fun just holding hands at
the movie show
and i spent good times tearing up the
town
oh
but i spent cold nights waiting out
front of the movie show
they got half the hands that held me
held me down
well i wanna get some other gold in the
hills that's making people nervous you
know they get scared of the cold and the
chill start praying god preserve us i
can't believe how long i've stayed two
more days till i get paid and i find
that small town boy i'm dating tell him
i'm patient with him
[Music]
it wasn't me
[Music]
some folks never get their share of the
sweet life
and others come around a little late
oh but i got this feeling i'm sitting at
a stoplight
it seems like good things come to those
who hit the road when they know what
they want and i want to get some other
gold in the hills that's making people
nervous you know they get scared of the
cold and the chills start praying god
preserve us i can't believe how long i
stayed two more days till i get paid and
i find that small town boy i'm dean tell
him i'm done patient with him
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
oh she says that's it so thank you
thank you
it's okay
it's fine
we have a couple of quick announcements
the sign in sheets are currently at the
food and water table if you want us to
remain in touch with you and you haven't
given us your name and address please do
that now before you leave
we know that six to eight people were
arrested at the wall more updates will
be following stay tuned for additional
information
and we will be making bus announcements
shortly to let people know about
transportation out of here
our next speaker is from the king
muhammad anti-military project we'll be
speaking about militarization in africa
rounding out our concerns of
transcontinental internationalism and
anti-militarism please join me
yes
ron
okay
there will be an announcement after the
next speaker about the new york city bus
ronnie fellerath is the new york city
coordinator don't bombard her with
questions we'll be making an
announcement about the new york city bus
in a moment but now please join me in
welcoming obi egbuna
on behalf of the pan-african student
youth movement
we wish to
thank the war resistance league
and we salute you in your 75th
anniversary
as you come together today to deal with
this initiative entitled a day without
the pentagon
the children the sons and daughters of
africa are no strangers to the pentagon
and no strangers to us militarism at all
those of you who know the pentagon and
understand the pentagon's focus know
about the joint
cultural exchange training program
where the pentagon is going into africa
to intensify the us military presence in
africa
as though we haven't had enough of
puppets in africa as a result of this
we can take a look starting in 1990
liberia the doe government was
overthrown a military government that
got us dollars
we can take a look at the government in
nigeria babangida that got u.s dollars
we can take a look at the government of
syed barry in somalia that between 1968
and 1990 was financed by the us
it is always interesting to focus on the
pentagon and focus on what is called
foreign policy because when you focus on
this you recognize that the democrats
and republicans are the same because
when bill clinton bombed
sudan and bombed afghanistan the first
person to praise him was newt gingrich
so when you come to focus on domestic
policy sometimes they make you think
they're different because their tactics
are different but when you take a look
at the way they treat the continent of
africa you see that their objectives are
the same
when we come to take a look at the fact
that most of the dictators and all of
the dictators in africa as they attempt
to orchestrate a facelift they want to
take us from military neocolonialism to
civilian neo-colonialism where we trade
in these leaders that are brutal and
when you take a look at the picture of
africa you don't only focus on the
military regimes take a look at the
military mercenary outfits like unita
and angola renamor mozambique all as a
result of pentagon programming just like
this and it also makes you focus on
something else it is not the chemical
weapons being produced in iraq and libya
that are the biggest threat to human
existence it is not the nuclear weapons
in pakistan and india that are a threat
to human existence but in all actuality
it is the 268 billion dollars that the
u.s and the pentagon put towards
militarism that is the biggest threat to
humanity today
all of the time we have to focus on
united states militarism and make sure
that this is properly understood
this is why in the african community we
say we have launched this king mohammed
anti-military project you understand why
we choose those symbols and you
understand that there's no contradiction
today they want to reduce martin luther
king to voter registration drives and
the march in washington in 1963 and this
means that when you focus on and now
it's even in vogue for people to
intellectually make the announcement
that his most militant work was against
the vietnam war but if we don't continue
that work the best tribute you can pay
to one is to continue their work we
picked elijah muhammad for the same
reason he's been reduced to his conflict
with malcolm x but those of you who know
the work of the honorable elijah
muhammad know during world war ii he
went to jail and the position that the
nation of islam took was not the
pacifist position of just dealing with
the morality of war but they said that
no africans should fight for the war
because american military was the devil
and that still is the position we take
today in the african community
we also understand that when we come to
deal with the way they want to deal with
africa we recognize that they have a
trail of blood we look at bukase in the
central african republic we look at all
of the spending we take a look at all of
the people who want to talk about that
america has yet to have a stable health
budget they want to deal with the
question that america doesn't have a
stable programs for education all of the
money lies within militarism all of the
money lies within the budget
we recognize that through this this
project is going to allow us to pay
attention to the stop the violence
movement in the african community when
we talk about that they want us to
confine it to domestic issues confine
our make us think that africa is foreign
to us but when they come to deal with
foreign policy we recognize what goes on
in somalia is not foreign to us what
goes on in nigeria is not foreign to us
what goes on in haiti is not foreign to
us where africans face the threat of
military military presence we know our
human existence is a ver is in danger
automatically
we also recognize and congratulate you
that you wish to do this during a
democratic administration and you're
dealing with a president like bill
clinton whose political fantasy is to
replace john f kennedy as the ultimate
liberal
and as a result of paying attention to
that we know that as they talk about
they like to vilify certain people they
want to vilify cert they want to vilify
the government of cuba when this is the
seventh year in a row that in the united
nations the vote was 157 to two and they
talked about the fact that they're not
going to uplift the embargo against cuba
you still see hostile policies people
can't even travel where they wish
africans have always been persecuted for
their travels from the days of ropes
into dubois to communist china where
kwame toray was the student nonviolent
coordinating committee's national chair
and had his passport seized minister
louis farrakhan was persecuted for his
world friendship tour we see this
everywhere that is why youth
organizations in the african community
must come together must form coalitions
with other people and defy these travel
bans and go where we want
we pay attention to the question of the
military basis and that is why we once
again wanted to focus on this joint
cultural exchange training program and
the militarism that it creates the fact
that they now want to also make use the
banner of multi-party democracy to
ensure that they have a presence in
africa all of the time so even though we
they want to change the leaders from
having camouflage to brooks brothers
suits working more along the angle of
the international monetary fund of the
world bank they still want to make sure
that they're not ready to dismiss
militarism you now have colin powell the
ultimate buffalo soldier not only
recruiting africans to fight in the
military in the united states he wants
them to fight in the british military he
wants them to fight in the italian
military he wants them to fight in the
german military and be african nazis
but when we pay attention to that we
recognize that it is our responsibility
to make sure that no more african youth
go into the military at all and then
from there we deal with military bases
we deal with military policy we're going
to go into the prisons inside our
community with this project we're
targeting african men and women who are
incarcerated for murder and we want to
know if they have any relatives who
killed in military combat and if they
have they will pose a question to them
you killed for drugs we killed for drugs
we killed in the prostitution racket we
killed in the numbers racket you've
killed for oil you've killed for gold
you've killed for diamonds you've killed
for the natural resources of the earth
what makes you a murder any more
different than ours and we will use that
as a platform to challenge the buffalo
soldiers in our community to challenge
those who promote the tuskegee airmen
and create a climate for us to think
that militarism is a legit option to
human life
we also want to launch a great dishoness
campaign where it will give us a chance
to go to the african churches those who
have a history of practicing the social
gospel go inside of the mosques in our
community and those who recognize that
just because they embrace islam they're
automatically a target of u.s military
policy we also want to use this because
we recognize that some of the most
atrocious military acts have been
committed in the name of religion and as
they talk about
all of these countries that are threats
to a military resistance the biggest
military state is the zionist state of
israel also financed by america
also financed by the u.s
as a result of that we say that we are
going to intensify our efforts in the
african community and we are simply here
today to tell you we stand in solidarity
with you and we encourage you to
continue to take positions against the
military we encourage you to continue to
raise the question of how they get to
budgeting and we will take care of the
rest
because we recognize as africans we are
always at the forefront and always take
the most militant positions on some of
these most critical questions anyway
we recognize that as a result of that
also they want to make you think about
we have to show just how much money the
us has given to some of these
treacherous regimes because we can make
sure that they aren't able to wipe away
their trail of blood and as we show the
ones in africa we encourage our brothers
in latin america and sisters in latin
america to show the money they gave to
pinochet to show the money they gave to
samosa to show the money they gave to
batista we encourage our brothers and
sisters in guatemala to do the same
thing we encourage our brothers and
sisters in asia to show the money they
gave to kim yong sam to show the money
they gave to the kumitang in china to
show the money they have given to all of
these reactionary regimes so as they try
to make scapegoats out of regimes like
pol pot's regime in cambodia and any
others they can choose we can show that
the most treacherous regimes have us
stamp and approval all over them
conclusion
once again we want to
salute you for your resistance today and
we feel that this climate will bring
about one unified african people young
one unified socialist africa thank you
very much
i have an arrest update
nine members of resistance in brooklyn
and two members of the westpac affinity
group were arrested moments ago blocking
the pentagon driveway in solidarity with
puerto rican political prisoners
[Music]
i know there's a lot of people out there
who have a lot of energy left
i know that i right now i'm pretty tired
the call to action for this event
started out by saying
we're tired of being told by the
politicians
democrats and republicans
that to rescue the federal budget social
programs must be cut we don't believe
them
we're tired of being told that nothing
could be done about unemployment and
poverty racism and illiteracy
homelessness and hunger we say that's a
lie
we're tired of seeing the obscene
funding of the military and the criminal
neglect of our communities we will
correct that obscenity
we are tired of being told that the
military is the only solution to
conflict we know there are alternatives
to violence
[Music]
we are tired of the lies and the secrecy
committed in the name of national
security
we are convinced that only the truth
will lead to peace
we are tired of this country's addiction
to militarism
today we take the first step in breaking
that addiction
this day without the pentagon the second
day without the pentagon is merely one
more step in the struggle until we reach
the great day when we are freed from the
burdens of militarism when we live in a
world without the pentagon and i expect
that everyone here will continue to work
together to continue the struggle when
you go home that today was not just one
day out of many when you hung out on the
grass and got rained on but that today
is a renewal of everyone's commitment to
work for justice and non-violence and
peace in a world of justice and equality
want to thank everyone for coming today
there will be a few logistical
announcements that will follow this wrap
up
and
um so just hang tight the important
thing is those of you who came on buses
you know or should know when it is that
your buses are leaving so please be sure
you're at the right place at the right
time if you don't know we'll be making
some additional announcements in a few
moments about that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
just ahead here on c-span 2 a portion of
today's washington journal program with
two international